Jetzt können wir einfach anfangen. Einfach so geht's einfach los. Aus dem Nichts.
Ich hab nach der langen Zeit vergessen, wer ich überhaupt bin.
Das hast du neulich schon geswittert, Peter.
Peter?
Ja, er hatte irgendwie ein Speicher voll in seinem Namensgedächtnis und hat seinen eigenen Namen, sein eigener Name ist rausgescrollt.
Aus der History. Das ist noch mal scheiße, wenn man aus der History denkt.
Ich hab ihn gelöscht und er sollte mich dann einfach dran erinnern. Das wird er verloren. Seitdem bin ich Beate.
Ja, der Peter.
Bei Tim bin ich Peter.
Ja, willkommen bei MobileMax. Ab heute nicht mehr mobilemax.de, sondern mobilemax.de. Wir haben so eine Art Rebranding oder ein Refreshing durchgeführt. Man könnte auch sagen, wir haben einen neuen Server aufgesetzt und mal dieses alte verkackte WordPress weggeworfen, bzw. du hast das gemacht. Vielleicht fasst du einfach mal kurz zusammen. Wir fangen heute mal mit Interna an und wir stellen uns natürlich auch noch vor. Stellen wir uns, wie haben wir das immer früher gemacht?
Ich bin Dennis und ich war mal links.
Du warst Dennis, du warst immer links.
Und ich war Max, jetzt war es auch Peter, das war ja auch Beate, ich bin hier der Windows-7-Nutzer. Ich habe meinen Dell-PC mitgebracht.
Endlich keine Netbooks mehr.
Endlich keine Netbooks.
Und ich bin Tim und mache hier die Runde komplett. Und ja, wir wollen hier wieder über Macintosh reden und sonstige Sachen und ihr könnt euch schon in etwa denken, was die Themenlage heute im Wesentlichen bestimmen wird.
Die iPorn-Girls.
Da gehen wir später noch drauf ein. Aber wir wollen jetzt erst mal zwei, drei Sätze sagen, was hier passiert ist. Also wir haben unsere Webseite mal neu aufgesetzt und die alte Webseite im Wesentlichen weggeschmissen. Denn da lungert er sowieso noch eine ganze Menge Scheiß rum, der er eh schon lange nichts mehr hätte suchen sollen.
Also erstmal lag dann auch irgendwie im Weg so ein kleines Wiki rum, was wir jetzt endlich mal entsorgt haben, was ganz, ganz furchtbar war. Dann war Johnny langsam ein bisschen nervös, dass jedes Mal Spreeblick down war, wenn eine neue Folge von MyMex rauskam. Das ist relativ simpel zu erklären, das lag einfach daran, Apache, hart einkompiliert, kann nicht mehr als 256 Instanzen gleichzeitig offen haben. Das heißt, wenn 256 große Dateien runtergeladen wären, ist einfach Schicht im Schacht. Das Problem wollte ich schon seit Ähnlichkeiten mal umgehen. Ich habe dieses magische Wort vom Reverse-Proxy gehört. Das ist quasi ein Proxy, der da vorgeschaltet wird.
Welcher?
Ich nehme das mal als, ja, den kann man nutzen.
Das ist der, den man meistens nutzt.
Keine besonders esoterische Wahl, aber okay. Ich wollte jetzt auch erstmal irgendwas befreuen. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht so sehr tief im Thema drinne bisher. Bestimmt kann man da auch noch einiges viel, viel besser machen, als ich es jetzt gemacht habe. Auf jeden Fall ist es ja mal aufgesetzt. Wir können ja mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert. Auf jeden Fall ist es jetzt ein anderer Server als der. Früher war es ein Sprengblick um Mobile Max auf einem Server. Jetzt sind es zwei komplett getrennte Maschinen. Das heißt, wir haben fast unsere eigene Maschine jetzt für Mobile Max. Da laufen nur noch ein paar andere Webseiten drauf im Augenblick.
Genau, wir haben jetzt auch mal unsere Domain unter Kontrolle. Das war nämlich dummerweise auch lange Zeit nicht der Fall, sodass wir jetzt auf mobilemax.de umziehen und mal alles irgendwie aufräumen. Der Zustand ist jetzt, während wir hier sprechen, noch nicht vollständig aufgelöst, aber das wird sich demnächst in euren DNS-Servern entsprechend ergeben. Und ich denke, der eine oder andere Bug ist in der Webkonfiguration auch noch drin. Stimmt's?
Garantiert.
Genau. Und was wir dann auch mal dabei weggemacht haben, ist halt irgendwie das alte WordPress. Und das neue kommt jetzt irgendwie deutlich leerer daher. Da sind da vor allem keine Restspuren mehr von diesem ganzen, von dieser O2-Liaison. Die ist sowieso schon lange, lange, lange nicht mehr gab. Also das war halt ja mal so, dass dieses Mobile Max als Projekt gestartet wurde, als Blog von O2. Und die haben dann da irgendwie Werbekapazität dauerhaft gekauft. Und daraus hat sich das dann sozusagen finanziert, dass da Leute rumgebloggt haben. Bis ich dann irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hatte zu bloggen. Und dann wurde es, wie ihr alle wisst, ein Podcast. Und dann machen wir das eigentlich mehr oder weniger unabhängig. Und seit Anfang dieses Jahres ist halt auch diese ganze O2-Konstruktion, die es da noch in Resten gab, weggefallen. Aus verschiedenen, nicht näher weiter hier interessierenden Entflechtungsgründen hat das sich eben jetzt alles so verzögert. Jetzt haben wir das halt einfach mal gemacht. So, mit anderen Worten, wir haben hier keinen Sponsor. Ob wir vielleicht noch mal irgendwann einen haben, steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Zumindest befinden wir uns derzeit in keiner Diskussion dahingehend. Das Ganze ist hier einfach nach wie vor Privat-Podcasting mit Spaß an der Freude.
Ja, finanziell von Kraus Mafai.
Genau. Und irgendwie Kinderarbeit in der fünften Welt. Ja, außerdem halt es hier, wer schon die Not Safe for Work-Folge mit Holgi, die ich gemacht habe, hier gestern gehört hat, der weiß schon Bescheid. Ich habe jetzt sozusagen, ich sende auch nicht mehr aus dem Wohnzimmer, sondern ich habe mir in nicht allzu weiter Entfernung dieses Wohnzimmers ein kleines Büro angemietet und bin jetzt hier ganz fleißig dabei, mir ein Podcast-Studio aufzubauen. Wenn man hier drin sitzt, dann sieht es schon auch ein bisschen danach aus, aber an dem Hall erkennt ihr, dass der Ausbau einfach noch lange nicht abgeschlossen ist.
Hier noch die Eierkartons, ne?
Ja, die Sachen mit Eierkartons, die kommen natürlich als erstes. Also mit Eierkartons werde ich es nicht machen. Es soll ja auch hier ein bisschen edel aussehen, wenn man nicht vorkommt wie in so einem Hühnerstall. Ich werde hier verschiedene Experimente machen. Das wird sicherlich viel mit Molton zu tun haben. Weil Molton ist irgendwie gut. Das wird sich zeigen. Das hängt auch davon ab. Molton ist einfach baumvolle. Molton ist toll. Molton gehört eigentlich in diese Kategorie Heißkleber, Gaffa-Tape, Kabelbinder. Weißt du, was ich meine? Diese einfachen Errungenschaften unserer modernen Welt. Rad. Mit denen du einfach alles bauen kannst. Nee, Rad ist eine grundlegende Technologie. Ich rede von einem konkreten Produkt, um einfach so Sachen zu fixen und zu bauen und fertig zu kriegen. Dachlaken gehören auch noch ein bisschen dazu. Ja, wenn man jetzt auf die digitale Welt übertragen würde, könnte man jetzt auch mit sowas kommen, aber das will ich jetzt gar nicht so sehr bemühen. Tatsache ist, Moltern ist super und ist gut gegen Schall und ist gut gegen Licht und andere Sachen und kann sich überhaupt sehr gut verwendet werden und ist auch noch in der Regel brandresistent. Also ist überhaupt eine tolle Sache. Ja, das ist hier das kleine Studio und ihr erkennt es halt daran, dass es heilt. Vielleicht sollte ich es Valhalla nennen. Gut, aber jetzt haben wir es abgeschlossen.
So, der schlechte Witz für dich.
Wir sind wieder online, wir streamen live und freuen uns, dass ihr zugeschaltet habt. Und vor allem lesen wir dir den Chat.
Wenn ich mir die Webland-Protokolle angucke, würde mich nicht wundern, wenn wir noch mehr Stream-Unterbrechungen als normalerweise haben.
Ja, naja, das wird interessant sein. Also ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher. Wenn jetzt hier ein großer Laster vorfährt, dann könnte es ein bisschen wackelig werden. Ich habe nämlich hier noch keinen eigenen Internetanschluss. Das wird aber wohl noch kommen. Allerdings habe ich meinen Alice-Anschluss geupdatet. Ich habe jetzt da das Upgrade gemacht von der Spaßkategorie in die Office-Kategorie. Und angeblich ist das dann halt tatsächlich, was übrigens mir der Alice-Support immer dementiert hat, aber andere Kunden mir mittlerweile bestätigt haben, dass sie da keine Disconnects mehr machen. Das heißt, sie machen schon noch Disconnects, aber nur auf Layer 2, also nur auf dem Links-Level, sodass du das auf IP-Level nicht merkst. Insbesondere wegen der Tatsache, dass du eben auch eine feste IP-Adresse kriegst. Die habe ich jetzt zwar noch nicht zugeteilt bekommen, zumindest weiß ich noch nicht, dass es so ist, wenn es so ist. Weil man muss sozusagen erstmal diesen neuen Vertrag kriegen und dann nochmal in dieser absurden, hässlichen Alice-Kunden-Webseite, die so eine Melange aus AOL-Portal und Titten ist. Weißt du, da ist ja immer diese Frau...
Bei Titten bin ich jetzt wieder aufgewacht. Ja, ja, ja, ich erinnere mich an diese Werbung.
Hansenett. So und naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, es könnte sein, dass diese Disconnection weg ist. Es könnte sein, dass jetzt diese WLAN-Anbindung, die ich hier habe, dass die dazu führt, dass ich hier auch Wackelnetz habe. Ich hoffe einfach mal, das funktioniert wunderbar. Aber in naher Zukunft ist Besserung angesagt. Und dann wird es hier auch stabiles Netz geben und noch ein paar andere nette Features. Über die nächsten Monate werde ich hier an meinem kleinen Studio weiter basteln.
Ich habe mir zuhause jetzt ein neues DSL bestellt.
Was denn?
Telekom.
Ja, mein Beileid.
Weil es das jetzt ohne Film-Abo gibt, oder wie war das?
Genau.
Ohne Fußball.
Und? Was kriegt man stattdessen? Basketball?
Kostet, kostet, kostet.
48 Euro.
Für 50 Mbit. Und wie viel ab?
Das ist geil, 6 Mbit.
6 Mbit ab.
Also, 58 Euro kostet das.
48 glaube ich.
Glaubst du?
Ja, 48, also irgendwas um die 50.
Mit oder ohne ISDN?
Mit ISDN.
Ach.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist nämlich...
Es gibt halt mehr.
Das ist nämlich bei mir das Lustige, dass...
Nee, das ist ja dann konkurrenzfähig zu diesem, äh, des Komfort-Dings.
Ich, ich hab mal geguckt, was mich, dieses, also ich war bisher bei, ich hatte, ich hatte meinen ISDN-Anschluss, war bei der Telekom. Ich kann aus irgendeinem Grund aus, deemlicherweise nicht aus meinem ISDN-Anschluss raus. Ähm, und der war bei der Telekom und meinen DSL-Anschluss hatte ich bei jemand anderem. Das war in Summe nicht viel billiger als ein VDSL. Da hab ich mir natürlich gedacht, ach komm, jetzt, mach mal hier das volle Programm, geh mal schön zur Telekom rüber und, ähm, geh mal so richtig Gas.
Bist du dir jetzt sicher mit dem Tarif? Ich mein, du hast jetzt, du hast es bezahlt, dann musst du auch wissen, was das kostet.
Ich weiß ihn jetzt nicht auswendig, warte mal, ich kann ja mal gucken, was da auf der Seite drauf steht, was ein VDSL kostet. Aber es waren 48 Euro, ähm, also irgendwas um die 50. Da muss man ja noch hart werden auf zwei oder... Weiß ich noch nicht, werd ich's mal sehen. Ich hab's noch nicht.
Bestimmt mit Disconnects.
Ja, es ist mir, also mir fällt, ich hab meine Fritzbox so programmiert gehabt, dass sie Disconnects auf 5 Uhr morgens gelegt hat, immer. Und ich bin davon wirklich, hab die nie erlebt, bewusst.
Na, man merkt die ja auch im Schlaf. Also mich reißt es dann immer wieder an. Ja, es ist einfach eine Schwankung in der Raumzeit.
Der Stream wird unterbrochen, der Tweet-Stream.
Ja, oder was weiß ich, du startest ein Upload, der einfach verdammt lange läuft und die Nacht überlaufen soll. Gerade, damit der Tagsüber nicht die Leitung fett macht. Würde ich im Zweifelsfall per Ersinn machen? Manchmal musst du einfach mal bekloppt mit FDP irgendwo was hochladen, ist halt so.
Hab ich in den letzten...
Du solltest mal Podcasts machen, dann machst du sowas.
FDP kann auch Continue, der macht dann weiter.
Der macht dann weiter, das ist alles Theorie. Tatsache ist, du wachst morgens auf und dann steht dein Klein und sagt Error. Das ist einfach die Realität.
Kleinkind oder Kleint? Kleint ist auch bestimmt manchmal Error. Steht da und sagt Error.
So Jungs, nicht trödeln, wir haben ein volles Programm. Wir haben jetzt wieder das Pech gehabt, dass wir irgendwie mitten in unserer Pause wieder eine Großwetterlage an Macintosh News hatten.
Ich finde es aber ganz schön blöd, dass du eine Pause machst, nur weil dein iPhone kaputt war.
Ja, ich kann nicht podcasten, wenn ich irgendwie ein neues iPhone habe und ihr sitzt damit rum. Aber ja, genau, letztes Mal habe ich ja noch aufgerufen. Ich muss mal erzählen.
Und wann ist unsere letzte Sendung? Hat sich da Mainz schon?
Ja, da hat es schon.
Wir hatten das gerade alle ganz frisch so. Und eigentlich war ja geplant, dass wir das alle haben so. Und dann habe ich ja sozusagen auf Mainz verzichtet, großherzig, wie ich bin.
Das ist so, lieb Onkel Tim.
Ja, ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass es mein Telefon war, was kaputt war, es ist so, dass eins von dreien kaputt war und ich habe einfach sofort meinen Mantel geteilt. Und ja, so bin ich.
Was hat so weit gemacht?
Ich wusste halt einfach, dass ich sowieso mit so vielen Dingen abgelenkt sein werde, dass es jetzt nicht so wichtig ist, ob das nochmal da ist oder nicht.
Und dass ein 3G noch eine Weile braucht, bis es kaputt geht?
Genau, das hat es dann auch irgendwie fristgerecht geschafft. 14. August, also wir haben jetzt sozusagen 5 Wochen nicht gesendet und was ist seitdem passiert?
Eigentlich fast nix, oder?
Alter, Steve Jobs ist back!
Und wir sind alle fast umgefallen, weil er einen neuen Hardware, die er vorgestellt hat. Ach, da wollten wir ja gar nichts drüber reden.
Schöne neue iPods. Die haben wir auch noch auf der Liste, Scheiße.
Nee, die haben wir noch nicht auf der Liste, das werden wir heute nicht schaffen, die neuen iPods. Das ist was für die nächste Sendung. Das ist auch so total langweilig, oder? Nein, das ist alles nicht langweilig.
Aber ist Hammer, oder? Nichts ist langweilig. Habe weg und dann nehmen sie 20 Dollar mehr. So machen die das.
Wollen wir jetzt wirklich über iPods reden?
Ist schon fertig.
So düstere Andauertung, die keiner so... Also ich verstehe sie jedenfalls nicht.
Hast du nicht verstanden?
Ich auch nicht. Was macht denn da die ganze Zeit diesen tropischen Sound?
Ich hatte vergessen.
Unglaublich.
Das ist wirklich eine Stimmung auch gereizt.
Wo waren wir gerade?
Wir waren dabei, dass Steve Jobs wieder da ist. Bevor er wieder da war... Ja, also er war wahrscheinlich schon da, als sie dann endlich dieses Update rausgeworfen haben. So, 10.6 ist da. Wir reden hier über alte Scheiße. Ihr habt das alles schon installiert, ihr habt alles schon getestet, ihr wisst auch schon alles. Warum hört ihr euch diese Sendung überhaupt an?
Na?
Weil ihr wissen wollt, wie wir es finden. Und wie finden wir es?
Lass mal Max anfangen.
Na, Max?
Ich find's echt scheiße.
Du findest es echt scheiße. Genau, erzähl.
Ich hab, ich hab...
So wenig Bang for the Bit, oder wie sagt man? Bit for the Bang?
Ja, erstmal... Erstmal krieg ich nicht mehr... Ich krieg mein Megabyte nicht mehr voll.
Das find ich allerdings auch ganz schön...
Wie mein Megabyte ist geschrumpft.
Ganz schön scheiße, aber das ist jetzt nicht, was irgendwie mein Fahrgefühl stört. Aber ich find's bekloppt. Das ist so gegen den Stromschwimmen so absichtlich von denen. Das Thema hat ich ja keine Ahnung, wir müssen es ihm erklären. Wenn du jetzt Info über eine Datei machst und er sagt dir, dass es ein Megabyte groß ist, dann meint er damit wirklich, dass es eine Million Bytes sind.
Ach so, sie sind jetzt aufs Dezimalsystem sozusagen gegangen.
Genau, und das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum Snow Leopard angeblich so viel kleiner ist nach der Installation.
Ja, es trägt dazu bei, aber ich meine, es sind 2,4%. Na ja, 1000 zu 1024 irgendwie.
Das multipliziert sich ja schön mit. Das potenziert sich doch, oder? Es ist doch im Endeffekt mehr.
2,4% sind 2,4%.
Und 2,4% mal 2,4%? Das ist dann quasi Zinssistenz-Rechnung, stimmt nicht? Also beim Kilo Bytes sind 2,4%?
Also 2000 zu 2048 Rechner, das wird dir genauso viel helfen.
Nee, 1024 mal 1024.
20? Das ist doch ob du das mal 2 oder mal 1024 rechnest.
Das kannst du noch mehrere Male mal 2 nehmen, da wird sich nichts dran ändern.
Man findet Max das nicht gut, weil er es nicht verstanden hat.
Das ist das übliche Problem, das nennt man übrigens Pilot Error.
Also ich hab jetzt, warte mal, ich hab mir sogar extra noch meine Screenshots hier irgendwo abgelegt für die Sendung, fällt mir gerade ein. Um zu gucken, weil es war erstaunlich, wie viel bei mir frei wurde. Also das ist mit... Das ist so mit einigen... Das ist so mit Dezimalsystemen nicht zu erklären. Also ich hatte nach der Installation von Snow Leopard, glaube ich, ach verdammte Scheiße, jetzt hab ich es mir nicht so richtig gemerkt, aber es war, glaube ich, so 13 Gigabyte oder 14 Gigabyte, die das bereinigt hat. Ja, und bei frischen Installationen, bei mehreren Leuten, wo ich irgendwie gerade einen Rechner, der so mit Leopard installiert worden war und wo ich dann Snow Leopard hinterhergeschmissen habe, da waren es dann halt wirklich diese versprochenen 7 Gigabyte. Aber es war in den allermeisten Fällen sogar mehr. Und hast du auch noch eine Stunde gewartet irgendwie danach, weil er fängt auch dann irgendwie an, da rumzukomprimieren, oder macht er das alles schon direkt bei der Installation?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass man grundsätzlich ein bisschen warten muss, weil er muss ja auch erstmal mit Spotlight wieder überall drüber, und das macht ja auch wieder ein bisschen Platz auf der Platte aus.
Genau, also da ist eh noch eine Menge Luft drin, was er so an ein bisschen wegschmeißt und so.
Also bei Kilobyte sind es 2,4%, da habt ihr absolut recht. Bei Megabyte sind es 4,9%. Bei einem Gigabyte sind es schon 7,4%. Bei einem Terabyte sind es glatte 10%. Zwischen den einzelnen Rechnungen. Hat jemand netterweise im Chatten Wikipedia-Link rumgecheckt?
Echt? Aber das heißt ja, wenn es so weitergeht, dann irgendwann kriegst du ja, kommen die aber 100% an und das heißt, dass du...
Dass gar nichts mehr frei ist?
Na ja, ich meine...
Bei einem Jotter beißt du über 20%.
Ja eben, also ich meine, wenn man es so weiterführt, muss es irgendwann eine Größe geben, wo es 100% sind, nicht, verstehst du?
Ja, wo es 100% Unterschied ist. Wo du mit der Dezimal-Schreibweise offiziell doppelt so viel Platz auf einer Platte hast, wie mit der Binär-Schreibweise.
Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, warum sie das gemacht haben, ist ja klar.
Damit meine 500 GB Festplatte endlich auch mal anzeigt, dass er 500 GB ist.
Ja, weil das mittlerweile echt alle machen. Also im Netzwerk-Übertragungsbereich wird mittlerweile dezimal gezählt. Es wird bei den Festplatten-Herstellern dezimal gezählt. Also Transfervolumen und so. Oder? Ist das nicht so? Bei den Providern? Da haben sie doch auch diesen MiBi-Byte und diesen ganzen Föllefanz eingeführt, damit sie irgendwie... Weil die ganzen Sales-Trois und Marketing-Nords, die können halt irgendwie alle mit Zweier-Systemen rechnen.
Nee, sie schwaben ja schon ganz ordentlich.
Die haben schon immer mit Millionen gerechnet.
Das liegt auch daran, weil die mit irgendwelchen Frequenzen arbeiten und die haben halt mit einer Zweier-Potenzierung auch nichts zu tun.
Du kriegst bei so einer Terabyte, wenn du es in Dezimalschreibweise rechnest, kriegst du einfach 10% geschenkt.
So wie ESDN. ESDN zum Beispiel nimmt auch 64.000...
Ja, da war es aber schon immer so.
Also da waren es eben keine 64 Kilobit.
Weil die auch keiner behauptet. Na, da gibt es das kleine K und das große K. Das ist der große Unterschied. Das große K sind 1024.
Ich dachte es wäre das kleine B und das große B, wo das kleine B für bit steht und das große B für byte.
Ja, ich rede auch nicht vom B, ich rede vom K.
Ich hab grad vom...
Ich weiß, wovon du geredet hast. Ich weiß auch, wovon ich geredet habe.
Ein KB und ein KB und dann gibt es noch ein KB und dann noch ein KB.
Also die offizielle Schreibweise ist... Ja, es gibt I und ohne I drinne.
Das ist jetzt diese neue Mibi-Scheiße.
Das ist dieses Mibi-Kramm. Dafür bin ich echt zu alt. Das mach ich echt nicht mehr mit. Da hab ich wirklich meine Jugend geopfert, um einfach problemlos Zweiersystem zu fühlen. Und dann kommen die mit so einem Scheiß. Das geht nun wirklich gar nicht.
Das stimmt, aber das ist wirklich nur, um die Nerds zu dekreditieren, damit die von Tabby Byte reden.
Alte Internet-Veteranen, oder? Tabby Byte und Tabby Byte.
Man will doch keine Meeby Bytes auf seinem Rechner haben.
Hört sich auch echt gleich so an, als wenn man eine Kinderfrau darunter hält, oder?
Aber das kleine K ist halt das Dezimal K 1000 K. So, und ISDN ist halt 64 Kilobit mit kleinem K. Die anderen sind alle irgendwie großes K, und das ist halt 1024 als Basis. Lässt sich leider nicht genau so auf M übertragen, weil natürlich kleines M ist Milli und so, deswegen war das schon immer alles ein bisschen durcheinander. Aber damals bei ISDN waren es halt 64.000. Im Chat wird behauptet, es gibt kein großes K. Ihr habt doch keine Ahnung. Es gibt kein großes K, natürlich gibt es ein großes K.
Ich glaube, es hat die CT mal eingeführt, dass es ein kleines K ist.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal skippen. Was fandest du an Snow Leopard?
Das kann ich mich damit nicht abfinden. Aber ich finde es tatsächlich nervig, dass einige Programme, das hat jemand herausgefunden, dass ein QuickTime QuickTime-Intern eine andere Dateigröße abzeigt, als wenn du die gleiche QuickTime Datei im Finder aufmachst. Das ist natürlich ein Haufen Inkonsistenzen, die dadurch plötzlich zustande kommen.
Und in der Konsole zeigen sie so ein LS, als wären die in LS irgendwann nach, ich weiß nicht.
Dann fällste vom Glauben ab.
Eigentlich ist der eh schon zu spät. Wenn man heutzutage ein LS macht, kriegt man das Datum eh schon als, ne ist die da in Englisch. War das nicht mal in Deutsch irgendwie in der Konsole?
Das hängt von deinen bekloppten...
Mein System war schon immer in Englisch.
Ah, ich meinte, ich habe die Datumsettings einfach nicht auf Deutsch umgestellt?
Nein, meine Datumsettings waren immer in Deutsch.
Ich kann dir nur sagen, fass sie nicht an. Wenn du irgendwie einmal anfängst, deinen Lokal da anzupassen, dann kommst du in ein tolles Filmscreen.
Wo ist es?
Hä?
Soll ich mich verarschen?
Sprache und Text. Wo, wo, wo?
Und in Deutsch? Blöd, wo war denn das?
Ganz oben, oberste Zeile ist so... Ich hab das einfach......Ulofahne quasi.
Also was wollt ihr denn jetzt überhaupt zu tun?
Auf jeden Fall in den Systemeinstellungen hab ich...
Ich hab bei den Systemeinstellungen deutsches Datum eingestellt und natürlich ist ein LS trotzdem das englische Datumsformat.
Ja, wir wollen jetzt aber nicht über LSD, oder?
Stimmt, du hast recht, fällt mir gerade auf. 22, Sepp, lass ich 10 noch in Englisch. Egal. Ich hab einfach Probleme ohne Ende. Das ist ein bisschen besser geworden. Seit 10.6.1 bilde ich mir ein. Aber ich hab am Anfang das Gefühl, dass mein System viel, viel schneller träge wird. Was?
Hast du frisch installiert oder oben drüber?
Ich hab oben drüber installiert. Ach Quatsch, das muss gehen.
Ich kann ja noch ein Zitat von dem Pavel bringen. Und der hat mal gesagt, ich glaub ja nicht an oben drüber installieren.
Ja, ich schon. Wir sind übrigens gerade, PPOE wird gerade verbunden. Ich glaub ans oben drüber installieren. Das hat bisher auch immer ganz und gar hervorragend geklappt. Und jetzt hab ich halt dieses Problem, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass das Ding langsamer wird. Ich hatte schon zweimal den Zustand, dass ich meinen Rechner abschießen musste, weil es einfach nicht mehr weiter ging. Und das ist echt kein schöner Zustand, wie ich finde. Es ist nicht so rund, der Finer crasht ohne Ende.
Also ich glaub, du hast da...
Ach komm, der Finer crasht bei jedem ohne Ende.
Also du hast da wirklich eine andere Wahrnehmung, glaube ich. Also ich sag nicht, dass das nicht so bei dir ist. Es gibt immer Systeme, bei denen eine Installation nicht klappt und wo manchmal was durcheinander ist. Da würde ich schon nochmal einen second try machen. Ich kann das alles überhaupt nicht bestätigen. Ich finde, dass Snow Leopard eine ganz signifikante Verbesserung auf so dermaßen vielen Ebenen darstellt, dass ich mich gar nicht beruhigen kann.
Absurde Grafikkartenfehler?
Nee. Die hast du ja sowieso. Du hast dieses neue Macbook Pro. Das ist eh von Arsch.
Nee, nee. Also wenn ich hier einen Tab aufmache, mal sehen, ob es jetzt kommt, ein Safari, erstmal steht das... Habt ihr gesehen? Die ist kurz so...
Ja, deine Grafikkarte ist zu langsam. Du hast die langsam eingestellt. Also ich hab ja nicht mal sowas mit meiner Lamentkarte.
Ich hatte das mit...
Ich sagte, der Grafikkartentreiber für die Macbook Pros, der ist Schrott. Ein Freund von mir, der hat auch immer Freezes, obwohl, okay, das hat andere Gründe.
Ich hatte keiner...
Aber ich weiß, man liest doch überall, dass die mit ihren Grafikkarten irgendwie da Ärger haben.
Ich hatte... Also unter Leopard hatte ich solche Probleme nicht. Es tritt tatsächlich nur in Safari auf, wenn ich einen neuen Tab aufmache. Ansonsten hab ich das Problem nicht. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, also Safari ist mal wirklich langsamer geworden, zumindest wenn man es im 64-Bit-Modus laufen lässt. Ja. Also wenn ein Flashfilm läuft, ist das langsamer. Jahr, als ich in der davon hab ich auch schon bei anderen gelesen, dass es jetzt nicht mein persönliches kleines ist.
Ich glaub dir das ja auch alles, dass das bei dir so ist, aber ich glaub einfach deine Installation ist Schrott.
Nein.
Doch? Natürlich, also was du da alles erzählst.
Ich glaub.
Also zum Beispiel Safari langsamer geworden.
Safari ist deutlich, also wenn man zum 32 Modus aufmacht, dann nicht.
Nach diesem Update hab ich, ich hab ja fast einer Wand geklebt, als ich gesehen habe, wie diese Rendering Engine abgeht.
Was, was ist denn da, also Safari ist?
Ich mach in meinem Net News war ja irgendwie, lass ich alle Taps laden, ja. Da konnte ich bei Snow Leopard zugucken, wie er von dem einen Tab auf den anderen geschaltet hat. Blam, blam, blam, blam. Und es dauerte einfach, und es dauerte einfach, es dauerte einfach. Und mit diesem 64-Bit-Webkit-Rendering-Engine, ich starte dieses Teil, geh da irgendwie durch diese Taps durch, dass sie alle geladen werden.
Safari im 32-Bit-Modus läuft okay schnell. Im 64-Bit-Modus hab ich einfach, ich hab jetzt...
Hast du was eingestellt, dass du nur im 32-Bit-Modus...
Ja, ich will gerne, ich bin jetzt auch am Überlegen, ob ich das mache. Ich hab jetzt so eine Anwendung, die heißt Glimpse, die macht mir im Wesentlichen so ein paar, also das ist sowas wie Saft oder sowas, das sind so ein paar Features nach, ein erster Linie ist Feature, dass nach dem Starten von Safari alle Taps wieder geöffnet werden. Das gibt es aber noch nicht für einen 64-Bit-Modus. Und darum hatte ich es jetzt bis vorgestern im 32-Bit-Modus laufen und war soweit auch, naja, Safari halt, ist im Wesentlichen schnell, außer wenn der Cash mal voll wird oder sowas, wo es dann abstirbt. Und jetzt habe ich gesagt, ach, scheiß drauf, mein Arbeitsbrowser ist ja sowieso Firefox, wo ich die Taps wieder offen habe, mach ich mal 64-Bit-Modus und wollte mir gestern ein YouTube-Video angucken und ich dachte, ich spinne. Also es war ein Moment, wo der Rechner ein bisschen ausgelastet war, aber wo er normalerweise im 32-Bit-Modus definitiv ein YouTube-Video abspielen kann.
Schaust du dir YouTube noch in Flash an?
Hattest du Click-to-Flash?
Ich habe Click-to-Flash, aber ich mag den Fullscreen. Ich will eine Fullscreen-Funktion haben, gerne. Darum nehme ich dafür auch Flash. Und das ist einfach, das war wirklich... Was rattert da so? Es hat gehakt, es waren keine Frame-Drops.
Das Flash langsam ist, das war ja schon vorher so.
Ja, aber es war alle zwei bis drei Sekunden ein neues Bild. Es war wirklich absurd langsam. Und das ist einfach... Ich vermute mal, das liegt daran, dass...
Du hast einen Rechner, der ist irgendwie endmal schneller als meiner. Und bei mir läuft das ja irgendwie flüssig.
Es ist jetzt auch kein Dauerzustand. Aber es war eine Situation, in der es definitiv der Fall war. Und ich vermute mal, das ist daran... Das System ist einfach noch nicht rund. Es liegt einfach daran, die haben dieses Auslagern von Flash in einem eigenen Prozess noch nicht im Griff. Das kann mal ein tolles Feature... Oder es wird sicherlich bald ein tolles Feature werden.
Vielleicht haben wir das nicht, weil wir click to Flashblown.
Ich hab das auch ausprobiert mit diesem ganzen Flash. Ich hab da irgendwie keine leinen nennenswerten Probleme gesehen. Außer, dass man jetzt endlich mal schön sehen konnte, wie viel Prozent der CPU tatsächlich von Flash weggehen und wie viel der Browser verbraucht. Und vor allem, ich hab da mal Tests gemacht, was sozusagen Flash an CPU gegessen hat, um ein Video anzuschauen. Also jetzt gerade mit YouTube kann man das ja ganz gut vergleichen. Ne, warte mal kurz, was hab ich verglichen? Ich habe... Ach, es war schon wieder so lange her. Aber ich glaub, ne, ich hab tatsächlich dasselbe Video. Also sozusagen Flash geladen, aber da drin mir die HD-Variante, die ja die H264-Variante ist, angeschaut, geguckt, wie viel CPU das verbraucht, versus das Ganze mit einem QuickTime-Player. Beziehungsweise mit dem durch Kliktor Flash geladenen QuickTime-Plaketen im Browser. Und es war halt so was wie, Flash braucht 70% der CPU und mit QuickTime braucht er 14% der CPU.
Das ist bizarr. Wobei ich weiß nicht, was YouTube in Hintergrund macht, ob die irgendwie in heimlich Passwörter knacken oder sowas, weil wenn man sich mal den YouTube-Player anguckt, was der schon, der YouTube-Player im Leerlaufmodus verbraucht, ist schon sagenhaft. Also es ist einfach nur dadurch, dass ein YouTube-Video irgendwo auf einer Seite ist, wird dein Rechner langsamer. Und zwar um Klassen. Und nun, klar, Flash ist scheiße, aber ich hab lang genug Flash programmiert, ich weiß, dass man Flash auch so programmieren kann, dass es schnell ist.
Ja gut, aber man kann es auch langsam machen.
Dass es keine Leerlaufzeiten hat. Und dass YouTube es nicht auf die Reihe bringt, mal einen YouTube-Player zu machen, der im Leerlaufmodus, ich erwarte ja gar nichts, wenn der Film spielt, dann soll er weiter den Rechenzeit brauchen, aber im Idle-Modus einfach unglaublich viel Rechenzeit braucht, das ist absurd. Und nochmal zu dem 64-Bit-versus-32-Bit-in-Safari. Es gibt einen 64-Bit-Safari, der hat ja dieses Feature, was auch Google Chrome hat, nämlich dass jeder Tab seinen eigenen Prozess hat. Safari. Auf jeden Fall hat er es für Flash-Firme.
Er hat es für 32-Bit-Plugins.
Na gut, dann hat er es für... Nee, nee, nee, ich hab irgendwas gelesen, dass es auch für...
Kann sein, dass du was gelesen hast, aber es ist nicht so.
Die Sandboxen orieren jetzt ihre Safari-Plugins. Deswegen, wenn jetzt irgendwie der Flash crasht, dann zieht es den Safari nicht mit runter.
Genau. Aber nur im 64-Bit-Modus.
Mit Sandboxen hat das nichts zu tun.
Es gibt jetzt mehrere Sachen.
Das eine ist, Plugins, die nur als 32-Bit vorliegen, können nicht im 64-Bit-Safari geladen werden. Deswegen lagern Sie das in einen eigenen Prozess aus. Da läuft das Plugin und in der Prozesskommunikation sorgen Sie dafür, dass es sich so verhält, als würde es im selben Prozess laufen.
Ist doch fast Sandboxing oder nicht?
Sandboxing ist, wenn der Prozess selber vom Betriebssystem gesandboxt wird.
Aber es ist jetzt mal ein eigener Prozess.
Sandboxing ist sozusagen ein ähnlicher Effekt des Absicherns, aber ohne, dass du dafür einen eigenen Prozess starten musst. Sandboxing bei Mac OS X besagt im Prinzip, du kannst einen Prozess starten und ihm bestimmte Dinge verbieten. Du darfst nicht aus Fallsystem schreiben. Du darfst nicht das, was man... Es kann sehr gut sein, dass dieses Plug-In umfangreich noch gesandboxt ist, dass der eben nicht dieses und jenes darf. Das ist sogar sehr wahrscheinlich. Ich hab's jetzt nicht überprüft oder was drüber gelesen. Aber wir dürfen jetzt hier nicht mit Äpfel und Birnen anfangen. Das Hauptding ist, Snow Leopard ist ein großer Schritt in Richtung 64-Bittisierung von allem. Sowohl des Kernels als auch der Applikationswelt. Und obwohl das ja eigentlich nichts Neues ist, weil das auch mit Leopard schon gegangen ist, dieser Weg ja schon gegangen wurde, und man ja auch schon 64-Bit-Anwendungen unter Leopard hätte laufen lassen können, hat es aber komischerweise kaum einer gemacht. Jetzt gibt es allerdings verschiedene Dinge, die eben die Anwendungsentwickler, wenn nicht zwingen, aber doch zumindest so auf den Weg bringen, selber über 64-Bit-Implementierung nachzudenken. Ein Ding sind halt die WebKit-Plugins. Andere Sache ist zum Beispiel die PrefPanes. Also überall wo halt Module geladen werden, wo Bundles geladen werden in Prozesse und wo jetzt auf 32-Bit nicht mehr zurückgegangen werden sollte, da wird es dann halt irgendwie schwierig. Bei den System-Pref-Panes ist es halt so, wenn deine Pref-Pane nur 32-Bit ist, dann launcht er sich halt neu in 32-Bit-Modus, damit er auch genauso laufen kann.
Deswegen kam ja auch ganz schnell irgendwie ein neues Perian-Tool raus, weil das genervt hat. Weil es war nur 32-Bit, kam gleich ein Update. Und der Electric Sheep-Screensaver, der geht gar nicht mehr, weil der ist nur 32-Bit und 32-Bit-Screensaver gehen wohl nicht mehr.
Genau, also all so eine Sache. Wenn sowas nicht geht, das ist ja kein großer Schmerz. Aber sie wollen im Prinzip einfach die 64-Bit-Glocke läuten. Und sie haben ja auch zahlreiche Dinge gemacht, die auch noch dazu die Leute zwingen, auf 64-Bit zu gehen, wie zum Beispiel QuickTime X, was eben nur als 64-Bit-API überhaupt vorliegt. Das heißt, wenn man mit dem neuen QuickTime X direkt modern interface will, dann ist man sozusagen auf den 64-Bit-Modus gezwungen.
Und es gibt ja auch eine neue Objective-C-Runtime. Und die gibt es auch nur unter 64-Bit.
Seit wann gibt es die?
Seit Snow Leopard.
Und was ist an der anders?
Also da gibt es wohl eine Version 2.1, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Wobei das mit Objective-C nichts zu tun hat, also diesen Objective-C 2.0. Aber ich habe da noch nicht weiter richtig Doku gefunden bisher. Aber die macht irgendwas besser, schneller. Die Ladezeiten sind wesentlich kürzer. Für Programmstarten zum Beispiel.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist einfach generell so, dass natürlich beim 64-Bit-Modus einfach Dinge schneller sind. Und zwar einfach bei Design, schlicht weil die Intel-Architektur mit dem Wechsel auf AMD 64, also das ist ja sozusagen das, worüber wir reden, wenn wir von 64-Bit reden.
Weil man muss ja mal dazu sagen, dass dieses 64-Bit-Modus eigentlich eine AMD-Erfindung ist. Weil Intel hat ganz dick auf Itanium gesetzt. Und das war aber irgendwie teuer. Und CPUs, irgendwie gab es keine vernünftigen Compiler für und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und dann hat sich AMD gedacht, finden wir alles nicht so toll, wir nehmen die alte Architektur, bohren die ein bisschen auf 64-Bit auf, sodass es irgendwie Sinn macht. Und dann haben die halt 64-Bit-CPUs verkauft. Und irgendwann konnte Intel sich dagegen nicht mehr verwehren. Und dann hat sogar Intel auch CPUs rausgebracht mit diesem AMD 64-Bit.
Ja, ist echt lustig. Sie wollten ihre eigene Legacy überwinden und haben dabei im Prinzip schon fast ihren eigenen Markt geschrottet. Das ist echt erstaunlich. Ja, und warum es schneller ist, ist schnell gesagt. Also man hat mehr Register. Und vor allem die Calling Convention innerhalb der Programme ist halt, dass die Werte eben auch nicht mehr über Instagram geben werden, sondern über das Register. Und das ist nicht nur schneller, es ist auch sicherer. Das heißt, mit 64-Bit wird alles bei Design schneller. Man compilert dasselbe Programm und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es schneller läuft, ist hoch. Das hängt natürlich immer noch davon ab, was man macht. Wenn man irgendwie im Wesentlichen auf User-Input wartet, dann geht das mit 64-Bit natürlich auch nicht schneller. Und die Sicherheitsbedingungen sind nochmal deutlich gestärkt worden.
Na und auf Mac OS X gibt es ja noch diese Besonderheit, dass 32-Bit-Prozesse, die können ja den kompletten 32-Bit-Prozessraum nutzen. Speicherraum nutzen. Und das Betriebssystem hat einen eigenen 32-Bit-Speicherraum. Und darum müssen bei Systemcalls, wenn zwischen Betriebssystem und Appian und her gewechselt wird, müssen die, kennt ihr euch ja zum Beispiel besser aus, müssen die entsprechenden Register alle gelöscht werden und neu gemacht werden. Und dadurch schlugen diese ganzen Predictions fehl. Also diese Prozessor...
Die Voraussagen darüber, was das Programm als nächstes macht.
Genau, die wurden auch weggeschmissen bei jedem Systemcall. Und das hat natürlich in einer Praxis, wo man ständig wechselt zwischen System und Applikation, hat das schon mal ein bisschen was langsamer gemacht.
Wobei der Kern noch als 32-Bit läuft.
Ja, das spielt aber keine Rolle, weil es geht tatsächlich nur darum, in dem Fall, ob das System und das App im 64-Bit-Modus laufen. Frag mich nicht, wieso.
Ich weiß nicht genau, bei welcher Ebene. Du redest ja von den Frameworks oder redest du vom Kernel?
Der Kernel ist noch 32-Bit, das weiß ich sowieso. Aber es geht nicht um den Kernel, es geht tatsächlich um den Systemteil. Also um die ganzen APIs.
Ja, um die Frameworks. Der Kernel ist jetzt auch 64-Bit. Er kann jetzt auch 64-Bit sein und es hängt davon ab, auf welchem Computer du Snow Leopard startest, ob du 64-Bit bekommst oder nicht. Das war ja jetzt auch schon Anlass für einige Konfusionen. Soweit ich weiß, sind die einzigen Rechner, die wirklich mit dem 64-Bit Kernel starten, im Wesentlichen die neuen XServe.
Desktop-Rechner, also entweder der Mac Pro oder die XServe. Also alles, was kein Laptop ist, bootet per Default 64-Bit. Wenn denn das Gerät das schon kann. Also man muss halt mindestens ein Core 2 Duo sein oder besser.
Und du brauchst einen 64-Bit Firmware.
Du brauchst einen 64-Bit EFI. Und das haben nur ganz, ganz wenige. Also das dürftet ihr beide nicht haben.
Wobei es jetzt nicht so ist, dass der Kernel nicht auch in 64-Bit starten könnte mit einem 32-Bit EFI, aber aus Gründen, die außerhalb unserer Bewertungsgrundlage liegen, kann das Apple sich entschlossen, das nicht zu tun.
Kann aber auch sein, dass die Grafiktreiber für meinen GPU hier in 64-Bit schon kann sein. Dass Apple das nicht macht, weil zum Beispiel irgendein Treiber für diese ältere Kiste hier nicht 64-Bit ist.
Ach, dass sie keinen Bock haben, ihre eigenen Treiber zu aktualisieren.
Das ist der Arbeit.
Die eigenen Treiber im EFI oder was?
Nein, nicht nur im EFI, sondern das ist ältere Hardware.
Alle Treiber müssen als 64-Bit vorliegen, wenn du einen 64-Bit Kernel fährst. Hier ist ja eine ältere Grafiksoftware drin. Quatsch, wer ist das hier? Grafikfirmware? Kernel Extension ist es ja. Vielleicht haben sie die nicht auf 64-Bit gebracht, diese alte Version.
Haben sie einfach keinen Bock darauf.
Könnte sein.
Apple ist ja immer relativ faule.
Ja, warum sollen sie sich da auch einen Ballast machen?
Wenn die Kiste demnächst in den Müll kommt.
Vor allem auf diesen alten Maschinen bringt ein 64-Bit Kernel auch nichts.
Oh ja, ich hätte es schon gerne.
Ja, hätte es schon gerne. Es könnte theoretisch unter Umständen vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen schneller sein.
Aber Sie haben schon recht, meine Kiste ist drei Jahre alt. Die Lebensdauer, die zukünftig ist, vielleicht noch ein Jahr oder so, dann kommt das Ding irgendwo weg. Und selbst wenn es dann noch jemand benutzt, dann ist es keine Person mehr, die sich um so etwas irgendwie den Kopf macht. Und ein Jahr habe ich das Ding auch nicht mehr.
Das ist eigentlich das Lustige bei euch, dass ihr auf euren Rechnern theoretisch ja einen 64-Bit Windows installieren könntet. Das würde ohne Probleme laufen.
Hast du gerade gehört, was er gesagt hat? Ihr könntet euch 64-Bit Windows installieren und es würde ohne Probleme laufen. Das glaube ich ja nicht.
So gut wie halt so ein 64-Bit Windows läuft. Aber ein 64-Bit Colonel Mac OS könnte da knicken.
Ja, aber dazu müsste ich ja erst mal in den Laden gehen und mich eine Stunde erklären lassen, welches Windows ich kaufen müsste, damit ich das 64-Bit...
Mann, ich wollte jetzt hier...
Ja, ein bisschen Spaß muss sein.
Ja, Spaß, Spaß, Spaß.
Ja, also wie auch immer.
Also mir mal das Fähnchen hochzuhalten. Ich bin mit meinem Snow Leopard voll zufrieden.
Nee, ich bisher nicht.
Lass uns mal kurz bei der 64-Bit-Körner-Geschichte bleiben, weil da steckt ja noch eine ganze Menge drin. Was ich hervorragend finde, ist, dass Apple im Prinzip die 64-Bit-Transition weitgehend abgeschlossen hat. Und das ist nicht... Das halte ich für eine technische Meisterlassung. Wenn man sich mal anschaut...
Wir haben ja auch schon bei 10-4 angefangen damit.
Ja, vor allem wie viele Hardware-Transitionen Apple in der Vergangenheit schon erfolgreich hinter sich gebracht hat. Das ist das dritte Mal, das ist die dritte Prozessor-Plattform und mit 64-Bit sozusagen die vierte Prozessor-Plattform.
Mit 64 ist es 68.000, PPC 32, PPC 64, Intel 32, Intel 64. Das sind fünf.
Und ARM im iPhone. Na ja, das ist immer auch ein Mac OS.
Ja Moment, Moment, aber PPC 64, also PowerPC, war schon von Anfang an 64-Bit im Design mit drin. In dem Moment, als die PowerPC-Architektur gestartet wurde, war alles schon im Prinzip klar, dass man da irgendwann auf 64-Bit geht und da musste innerhalb der Architektur nichts geändert werden. Ja, also es gab die Prozessoren, hatten neue Technologien und so weiter. Irgendwann musste es dann überhaupt erst mal einen Prozessor geben, der auf 64-Bit war. Aber dass es irgendwann 64-Bit sein würde, das hatte diese Architektur schon immer drin. Von daher war das in dem Sinne no big news. Aber der Schritt von 68K auf PowerPC, das hat ja Apple damals auch fast das Genick gebrochen. Das hatten sie ja wirklich fast vergeigt. Eigentlich haben sie es relativ elegant gemacht mit ihrem Emulator, das war zwar langsam, aber es ging so. Allerdings haben sie dann eben die Transition auf ihr neues OS verkackt. Im Prinzip wie mit Intanium. Wir setzen jetzt schon mal auf die Zukunft und lassen den ganzen anderen Kack dahin. Dann hat es mit der Zukunft nicht funktioniert und dann haben sie sich um den alten Scheiß zu wenig gekümmert. Dann hatten sie ein Problem. Trotzdem hat es irgendwie geklappt. Dann waren sie auf PowerPC und irgendwann war dann auch alles so halbwegs nativ. Und dann mussten sie auf Intel gehen. Wie lange hat es gedauert von PowerPC auf Intel zu gehen? Ihre komplette Hardware-Basis war nach einem Jahr bereits ausgetauscht. Und sagen wir mal ehrlich, das war nicht schwierig. Also von PowerPC auf Intel, es war also nahezu schmerzlos. Jetzt das Ding auf 64-Bit zu gehen, das hat sich zwar mit PowerPC im Prinzip schon abgezeichnet, also mit dem PowerPC G5 im Prinzip schon abgezeichnet, ist aber nochmal eine andere Geschichte, weil eben, Intel ist nochmal anders. Da haben sie natürlich einen riesen Vorsprung dadurch gehabt, dass sie schon so spät eingestiegen sind. Trotzdem, du musst halt deine ganzen Applikationsentwickler auch mitziehen und vor allem, du musst eben ein OS bieten, was beides eben gleichzeitig kann. Und das haben sie irgendwie geschafft. Und jetzt haben sie es auch geschafft, nahezu alle Frameworks auf 64-Bit zu bringen. Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es noch irgendwas, was nicht, kann eigentlich nicht sein. Ich meine, jetzt sind sie glaube ich zu 100% 64-bitig.
Der ganze Carbon-Scheiß fliegt halt raus.
Genau, Carbon wird nicht 64-bit werden.
Und QuickTime?
Und fällt damit eben auch raus. Und bei QuickTime ist es eine Sondergeschichte.
Gibt es denn das alte QuickTime, aber gibt es nicht als 64-bit oder doch?
Nein. Genau, da erschlagen sich nämlich mehrere Fliegen mit einer Klappe. Und ich fand das ganz interessant. Du hast ja auch diesen Syracusa-Bericht gelesen, ne? Max, den musst du ja echt nochmal anschauen. Der Syracusa-Bericht ist einfach immer der Interessanteste. Der erzählt auch nicht alles, aber der erzählt halt ganz andere Sachen.
Ich hab schon von den einigen Sachen schon mal durchgelesen.
Aus technica.com müsst ihr einfach mal klicken.
Da muss man lesen. Der begleitet Mac OS X seit Anfang an. Seit den ersten Developer-Previews und so. Und hat im Prinzip jede Version ganz klar gebenchmarkt und verschiedenste Aspekte beleuchtet. Vor allem ist er der Einzige, der wirklich auf Kernel-Level runtergeht und genau beschreibt, was sich da eigentlich konkret getan hat. Und er hat auch diese Quicktime-Situation beschrieben. Wir hatten uns ja letztes Mal noch so ein bisschen in der Wolle, somit der Quicktime-Player kann irgendwas nicht mehr. Jetzt steht das Ganze so ein bisschen im Kontext. Was sie getan haben ist, neben Quicktime 7 haben sie ein neues Quicktime geschrieben. Das heißt Quicktime X. Quicktime X hat den Funktionsumfang, hat ungefähr 10% des Funktionsumfangs von Quicktime 7. Das heißt, viele Sachen kann das nicht. Alles das, was das aber schon kann, kann es besser, schneller, höher, weiter. Das heißt, das Ding hat keine Plugins für andere Formate und so, sondern das kann eigentlich nur den ganzen Apple-Rots sprechen. Das ist im Prinzip H264, also die komplette MPEG-4-Welt ist da drin. Das spielt es dann aber irgendwie schnell ab. MPEG-3 spielt es schnell ab, muss es irgendwie nicht laden. Also verschiedene Annahmen und Strategien von dem Urquicktime, was ja dafür gedacht war, eigentlich ein Editierumfeld für Videos zu bieten und gar nicht so sehr ein Playback-Umfeld. Das war quasi ein Abfallprodukt, dadurch, dass du diese Movie-Idee hattest. Alles ist ein Movie in Quicktime. Das hat die Sache auf der einen Seite sehr vereinfacht, für Anwendungsentwickler aber auch sehr schwierig gemacht, weil selbst wenn du nur so etwas Belangloses wie eine MP3-Datei hast, musst du sie beim Laden erstmal in einen Movie machen, bevor du sie abspielen kannst. Deswegen die langen Ladenzeiten bei langen MP3s. Wenn du ein dickes MP3 nimmst und das in den Quicktime-Player schmeißt, nicht wahr, dann lädt er sich da irgendwie tot dran.
Ja, das macht er aber nur bei den MP3s mit VBR.
Nee, das macht er eigentlich bei allen. Bei manchen dauert es halt länger und bei manchen nicht.
Bei den mit VBRs, die muss er komplett einlesen, bei den normalen muss er die nicht komplett einlesen.
Naja, er muss auf jeden Fall eine interne vollständige Movie-Dateistruktur machen, bevor er wirklich irgendwie Dinge tun kann. Und das dauert so oder so. Es mag halt schneller gehen oder weniger. Naja, so. Und jetzt halt das neue QuickTime. Kommt halt wirklich zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo sie auch eben diese ganzen anderen Transitionen machen. Das heißt, Carbon fällt weg. Damit fällt sozusagen auch eine große Legitimation von QuickTime 7 weg. Und sie gehen auf 64-Bit.
Das heißt, sie schütteln ja jetzt damit auch die letzten Mac OS 9-Rester sich vom Leib. Aus dem Fell, wie auch immer. Also Carbon halt und QuickTime.
Und den Feinen.
Und den Feinen haben sie schon, wenn ich jetzt nur noch iTunes halt.
Genau, jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch iTunes. Oder? Gibt es noch irgendwas anderes? Ein 32-Bit?
Also ich hab nix gesehen hier. Das Einzige, was bei mir noch 32-Bit ist, von Apple ist iTunes und dieser USB-Demux oder so. So ein Prozess, der da noch läuft, der wahrscheinlich fürs iPhone da ist.
Ja, aber jetzt geht's irgendwie... Also wir werden sozusagen jetzt noch mehrere Jahre eine Co-Existenz von QuickTime 7 und QuickTime X erleben. Naja, nicht unbedingt viele, viele, viele Releases, aber das wird jetzt nicht in einem halben Jahr weg sein, weil da einfach eine ganze Menge Features in QuickTime 7 drin sind, die einfach QuickTime X nicht abdeckt.
Die auch vielleicht aber keiner mehr braucht so.
Das ist die Frage. Das werden sie wahrscheinlich dann auch erstmal in Ruhe...
Also die guten Apple-Coder sind schon eigentlich immer schnell dabei. Wenn die eine neue API kriegen, dann nehmen sie die aber auch gleich sofort und lassen die alte los. Das geht eigentlich nicht.
Ja, aber nur wenn sie dasselbe kann. Also wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel einen Okoworbes-Codec bieten möchtest für QuickTime X, ist das halt derzeit einfach nicht drin. Das geht einfach nicht. Du kannst das einfach nicht programmieren, selbst wenn du wolltest. Und das ist natürlich schon eine Diskussion wert. Jetzt überlege ich gerade, was da noch alles so fehlt, aber ich erinnere es jetzt gerade im Detail nicht. Aber das ist sozusagen eigentlich eine der Hauptkriegsschauplätze bei Snow Leopard.
Wobei man ja von dem QuickTime also selbst nicht viel sieht, weil QuickTime ist ja mehr als nur dieser Player, sondern das ist ja das Framework unten drunter. Man kriegt da eigentlich nichts davon mit.
Genau, das QuickTime 7 ist komplett opark und du benutzt jetzt eigentlich nur noch QT-Kit. Und das QT-Kit selber entscheidet, ob es darunter auf QuickTime X oder auf QuickTime 7 zugreift. Das heißt, das war ja das erste, was sie gemacht haben. Also QuickTime war ja immer eine Carbon-API. Und das war, ich hab das selber mir nie genauer angeschaut, aber du hast das glaube ich auch mal gemacht.
Das war der Horror.
Genau, alle, die ich kenne, die damit gearbeitet haben, meinten, das ist einfach der Horror. Was auch erklärt hat, warum einfach bestimmte Dinge, die QuickTime schon immer geboten hat, von vielen Programmierern einfach nie wirklich genutzt wurden.
Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnern kann, musste man bei der QuickTime-API noch Pascal's Drinks übergeben.
Na ja, das ist halt wirklich richtig alte Scheiße.
Und jetzt haben sie quasi...
Wann kam QtKit? Kam das bei Leopard oder schon bei Tiger? Ich weiß es gerade jetzt gar nicht. Also irgendwann haben sie so eine Coco-Applikations-Schnittstelle halt geboten für QuickTime, was aber dann dahinter sozusagen, was nur ein Wrepper war für QuickTime 7. Und damit geht's jetzt weiter. Nein, das QtKit ist das Interface zu QuickTime. Nur, dass sie jetzt unterhalb von QtKit, also du hast die Applikation, darunter hast du QtKit und darunter hast du QuickTime 7 und QuickTime X und derzeit werden 10% der Funktionalität von QuickTime X übernommen. Piss die Wand an. Sagst du QuickTime X oder QuickTime 10? QuickTime 10, QuickTime 10, was auch immer. Das Neue. Das heißt, sie schalten quasi in dem QtKit um, zwischen den beiden APs. Aber QuickTime X ist back. Das heißt, hast du noch eine Frage zu dem QuickTime?
Genau, das heißt, auch der neue QuickTime Player spielt jetzt, sobald ich einen AVI aufmache, was er mit Perium aufmacht, weil QuickTime 10 noch nicht diese ganzen schicken...
Ist das nach wie vor QuickTime 7?
Ist das nach wie vor QuickTime 7 und deine neuen Oberfläche?
Genau.
Und der alte QuickTime 7 Player zwingt dann einfach auf QuickTime 7 runter? Ist die AP nachher...
Ich weiß nicht, ob der auch mit QtKit programmiert ist.
Das kann ich dir nicht beantworten.
Das kann sein, das kann nicht sein. Weiß ich nicht. Ist auch unerheblich. Auf jeden Fall derselbe Code. Der QuickTime Player für QuickTime 7 ist derselbe wie in Leopard. Und sie haben jetzt einen neuen gemacht, der sich auch erstmal im ganzen User-Interface-Kram reduziert und viele Dinge einfach nicht bietet, die der alte eben noch kann. Aber sie haben halt einfach beides dabei. Von daher stellt sich die Frage nicht.
Zum Abspielen finde ich ihn ja extrem schick, wenn alles so funktionieren würde, wie ich es mir vorstelle.
Es tut es noch nicht und deswegen muss man doch wieder einen Player benutzen.
Du guckst ja noch viel mehr als ich. Ich kann tatsächlich so ziemlich alles mit QuickTime abfackeln. Was ich sehr nervig finde, das war schon bei QuickTime 7, wenn man in Fullscreen-Modus gegangen ist, hat es halt immer einen Moment gedauert. Das ist jetzt im Idealfall mit QuickTime 10 viel besser geworden, dass es so instant geht. Aber ich hab auch einfach viele Momente, wo man richtig sieht, wie man den Bildschirm neu aufbaut im Fullscreen-Modus.
Du hast ein Mutters OS. Ich glaube auch.
Deine 1000 Tabs hauen den Grafikspeicher weg.
Wenn du dein System neu mal installierst, wenn du mal einen Fresh Install machst, und du hast denselben Effekt, dann glaube ich das. Aber ich glaube einfach, da ist irgendwie was drin.
Was soll da drin sein?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das auch schon häufig gehabt.
Hast du nicht die große oder die kleine Grafikkarte aktiv?
Jetzt hab ich die große.
Du hast mit beiden Grafikkarten das selbe, denselben Effekt?
Das hab ich jetzt noch nicht. Ich glaube, ich hatte denselben Effekt. Ich bin mir aber nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher. Ich werde noch mal ein bisschen rumexprumentieren, aber so...
Und dich zurückmelden.
Ich werde mich noch zurückmelden, aber bisher bin ich nicht wirklich glücklich.
Oder hast du mit Quartz Debug deinen Quartz Extreme ausgeschaltet?
Genau, das wird's sein.
Ja, wer weiß? Nachguck.
Und magst du auch die abgerundeten Ecken von QuickTimeX Player?
Ich find die super. Also ich find diesen...
ist an.
Ich find den neuen QuickTime Player tatsächlich so... Also dieses Alte, dieses Drumherum, diese riesen Buttons und so, das find ich irgendwie... also dieses Slick einfach nur Cursor rausziehen und man hat nur noch diesen Player da auf dem Bildschirm rumliegen. Ich find das extrem schick.
Ja, find ich auch. Mac OS ist back, sag ich euch. Es gab ja... gibt bestimmte Dinge, die in Mac OS schon immer drin waren, die Mac OS 10 nie hatte und die mich immer total genervt haben. So als alter... alter Scheißer.
Zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt einen Keyboard-Viewer. Du kannst jetzt da oben einfach mal anklicken und dann hast du einfach mal so ein Fensterchen, was da floated und du siehst irgendwie, welche Tasten du drückst und so weiter. Das war in Mac OS schon immer drin.
Den gab es auch in Mac OS 10 in den ersten 10.0, 10.1.
Irgendwann mal gab es einen, der war aber scheiße und so.
Wie, als separat das Programm oder wie?
Das war so ein Floating-Overlay, der halt überall drüber hängt und wenn du die Tasten drückst, dann siehst du halt auch genau, wie das gerade so ist.
Du findest auch irgendwelche Zeichen, indem du eiltrückst und dann kannst du gucken, was sich wohin verändert. Dann kannst du sehen, ah, da ist irgendwie das Pi oder das...
Du kannst einfach mal deine Tastaturbelegung lernen.
Aber den gab es doch schon vorher.
Ja, wo denn?
Wo denn?
Man musste dieses Tastaturmenü einschalten.
Du meinst jetzt nicht die Sonderzeichen, wo man die UTF-8-Listen bekommen hat.
Das sind zwei separate. Einmal eine Tastatur, so eine Mini-Tastatur.
Aber die Tastatur sieht irgendwie anders aus.
Die haben sie jetzt überarbeitet. Man kann sie jetzt größer machen, was natürlich zu totalen Gerüchten gefühlt hat, dass jetzt das Tablet direkt bevorsteht. Weil wenn man dieses Fenster ja größer ziehen kann, es kann ja ein Schild fahren.
Ist das jetzt so ein, irgendwie gab's auch in 10, 45 Jahren?
Jaja, das gab's hundertprozentig.
Da kannst du mal sehen.
Was war denn anders? Irgendwas ist anders. Mit diesen ganzen Deadkeys und so weiter, das Ding funktioniert genauso wie vorher? Ist das euer Ernst?
Shit, wir schneiden mal raus.
Genau, wir nehmen das raus. Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt. Irgendwas ist anders. Auf jeden Fall ist es gut, dass sie das jetzt direkt oben ins Menü gepackt haben, dass man das direkt aufrufen kann. Ja, aber wahrscheinlich gab's das auch schon vorher. Naja, ich hab nichts gesagt.
Jaja, man kann es jetzt größer machen.
Guck mal, ich bin das notiert mit dem Keyboard-Viewer, wenn das vorher schon da war. Das nächste, das nächste, Put Back from Trash.
Ja, das ist auch ein OS9-Feature, oder?
Ja, das ist ein OS9-Feature. Das kannst du früher schon machen, wirst du was in den Papierkorb und dann machst du Apple Y und dann kommt das Ding wieder zurück da, wo es her kam. Ging irgendwie die ganze Zeit nicht. Jetzt geht es. Dann haben sie irgendwie, was mich am allermeisten genervt hat und was jetzt endlich gefixt ist im Finder.
Wenn man was anmountain will. Jetzt kommt es.
Das war ja bei Meco S9 schon immer richtig scheiße.
Ja, aber jetzt wird angezeigt.
Ja, das ist eine generelle Verbesserung. Aber das war ja bei Meco S9 auch scheiße. Nee, der Finder merkt sich das erste Mal diesen Ausklapp-Status. Also ich schaue mir in der Regel meine Finder-Fenster immer im Listen-Modus an. Da gibt es ja auch Leute, die das anders halten. Aber ich halte einfach Listen-Modus in der Regel. Und wenn du jetzt einen Ordner hast und da drin sind Ordner. Du klappst erstmal den ersten auf und klappst dann da drin auch welche auf. Dann nimmst du den Top-Level-Ordner, den du als erstes aufgeklappt hast, und klappst ihn wieder zu und dann klappst du wieder auf. Und dann kann ich jetzt nicht sicher sagen, ob das in allen Fällen immer nicht erhalten wurde. Auf jeden Fall hat das nicht konsistent funktioniert. Es war einfach so, dass er sich nicht diesen Zustand gemerkt hat, ob ein Ordner aufgeklappt war innerhalb eines Ordners. Und das wird jetzt beibehalten. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt, wie bei Meco S9, aufklappen, irgendwie eine Aufklappreihenfolge herstellen, den Top-Level-Ordner zuklappen, wieder aufklappen und du hast dieselbe Sicht. Und du kannst auch mit Alt, kleiner, größer, mit Alt, Cursor, Dingsbums, die Dinger aufklappen, also wenn du mit Alt aufklappst, dann klappst du sozusagen den Ordner auf und alle anderen auf. Das war schon immer so. Ja, aber das merkt er sich dann halt auch konsistent und wenn du halt wieder mit Alt zuklappst, dann macht er auch alle zu und so weiter. Also das haben sie jetzt einfach hinbekommen. Das finde ich einfach eine schöne Sache, vor allem wenn man so eine Tastatur bedient und so.
Was ich cool finde ist, ich weiß natürlich nicht wie es bei Meco S9 war, aber so grundsätzlich, dass wenn man im Listen-View ist und man klappt mit den Cursor-Tasten, hier mit Cursor rechts, einen auf, wandert so ein bisschen runter, dann kommt man mit Cursor links nach oben, dass man gleich wieder schließen kann. Vorher ist man nicht nach oben gekommen. Man muss dann wieder hoch zu dem Folder, den man geöffnet hat und dann irgendwie... Das finde ich auch cool. Man kommt sozusagen schneller wieder zum Ursprung zurück.
Ja, die ganze Keyboard-Navigation ist einfach runder und besser und wir haben halt einfach wieder Feature-Parität mit Meco S9 hergestellt.
Ich meine, die haben wahrscheinlich ordentlich irgendwie ihre Auftragsliste gehabt irgendwie, was sie zu programmieren haben, dass der Finder hier genau wieder so wird.
Die haben einfach die Gelegenheit genutzt und haben das einfach mal vernünftig überdacht, was sie da drin hatten. Ich nehme an, der erste Finder wird ziemlich in Biegen und Brechen entstanden sein.
Ich glaube, alle Finder werden sehr zertifiziert in Biegen und Brechen entstanden. Dann gibt es noch ein Feature, was ich glaube ich in diesem Syracusa-Artikel, dem Ars Technica-Artikel gelesen habe, aber noch nicht ausprobiert habe. Sie haben jetzt auf Fallsystem-Ebene etwas Neues eingeführt, was ein Bookmark ist. Womit sie vor allem es für Programmierer einfacher machen. War das in dem Bericht, dass es da irgendwie 5 oder 6 verschiedene Arten und Weisen gab, wie man die Referenz auf eine Datei hält? Mit Open-File-Handles, mit File-IDs und File-Referenzes und so weiter. Und dass sie allein schon in ihrem Standard Text-Edit, um eine Datei aufzumachen, gleich 4 oder 5 verschiedene benutzen. Und das haben sie jetzt in der API komplett ersetzt durch einen Bookmark. Es gibt jetzt das Programmierobjekt Bookmark, was einfach die Referenz auf eine Datei hält. Und das ist halt einfach so ein Objekt und damit ist fertig. Und das soll auch teilweise Features geerbt haben, die halt in den alten HFS-Aliasen, in diesen Netzwerk-Aliasen mit drin sind. Habe ich aber jetzt noch nicht gesehen, also noch nicht austesten können, ob sich irgendwas geändert hat.
Was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass sie eine Menge File-Apps jetzt einfach, also dass man Files jetzt über die Url öffnet, damit es mal einherstlich ist.
Genau, das ist Bestandteil dieser Bookmark-Geschichte, dass da sozusagen mit einer Url gearbeitet wird.
Weil es macht ja Sinn, weil es mir ja total scheißegal, ob mein File bei mir liegt oder bei dir oder woanders.
Ja, aber die Url ist jetzt eine Url im Sinne von, dass sie halt die Datei identifiziert, aber es ist nicht der Pfad. Es ist etwas, was auch dann noch gilt, wenn du die Datei umbenennst. Und wenn du sie woanders hinmufst. Ja, was diese Bookmarks heißen.
Ach so, das ist quasi, ist das sozusagen...
Ja, das, was man halt haben will.
Ist das ein altes Alias quasi?
Was ist ein...
Nein, ein Alias früher... Also genau, ein Alias ist doch...
Genau, wie die Alias damals funktioniert haben und wie generell Referenzen funktioniert haben, das haben sie ja weitgehend eigentlich beibehalten mit den Fall-IDs, nur dass sich darunter eben alles geändert hat. HFS+, Unix-Fallsystem und so weiter. Und dabei ist irgendwie über die Zeit einfach eine ganze Menge akkumuliert worden, wie es eben auch geht. Und jetzt ist es so, wenn du eine Anwendung machst, die sagt, ich laufe nur ab Snow Leopard und aufwärts, dann hast du ein Clean Interface. Dann arbeitest du nur noch mit diesen Bookmarks und musst mit diesen ganzen alten Abstraktionen überhaupt nicht mehr klarkommen. Und sie haben ja diese Creator Codes jetzt irgendwie auch deprecated, aber ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, was die Änderungen tatsächlich bewirkt. Also was heißt das?
Programme können die schon noch benutzen, die darauf angewiesen sind, aber wenn du jetzt eine Text-Datei hast, Tim.txt, die als Creator Code irgendwie Berbe uns edit hatte, und du drückst da jetzt drauf, dann kommt das Ding trotzdem mit Text Made hoch.
Aber was ist da jetzt anders als vorher?
Vorher wäre Werbe uns edit hochgekommen, weil es nicht auf die Endung des Dateinamens geht, sondern auf den Creator Code geguckt wird, womit es geöffnet werden soll.
Aber es gibt doch jetzt immer noch die Möglichkeit für eine einzelne Datei zu sagen, womit es sich öffnet. Aber es basiert nicht auf Creator Codes, ne? Okay, Abteilung, wir wissen nicht genau, worüber wir reden. Ja, mir ist noch was schönes aufgefallen, was ich übrigens bisher noch nirgendswo gelesen habe. Sozusagen ein Industry First. Es gibt jetzt endlich, und jetzt würde ich den größten Tusch gerne einspielen.
Erst mal abwarten, wir kennen das ja schon seit 20 Jahren.
Also das war jetzt definitiv vorher noch nicht drin. Du kannst jetzt, wenn du einen Druckjob gestartet hast, und du siehst die Q...
Bist du so ein Internet-Ausdrucker?
Ja, ich druck das Internet aus. Und ich habe nie verstanden, ich hab's bei macOS 9 nicht verstanden, aber ich hab's vor allem bei macOS 10, wo ja die gesamte Druck-Q auf PDF basiert, nie verstanden, warum man einen Druckjob, der sozusagen in der Q ist, der das Programm verlassen hat, das Programm läuft nicht mehr, er ist in der Q, er wartet nur noch darauf, dass der Drucker bereit ist, warum man den nicht previewen kann. Und jetzt kann man das. Jetzt gibt's da so einen kleinen Button und du kannst dir sagen, was druckt der denn da?
Heißt, wenn heute was nicht gedruckt hat und ich guck morgen, alles klar, der hat ja mein Dokument von gestern nicht gedruckt, dann kann ich reingucken, was es ist.
Ja, kennst du das, diese Druck-Qs, die irgendwie voll sind mit irgendeinem Garbage, wo vielleicht schon wochenlang da was drin liegt, weil du den mal irgendwie auf Pause gestellt hast, genau, und die irgendwie, was weiß ich, unbekanntes Programm-Datum, lalala heißen und du überhaupt nicht weißt, was es ist, jetzt kannst du dir das halt irgendwie anschauen.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob es das vorher schon gab, aber konnte man vorher Drucker umbenennen?
Auf welcher Ebene?
Na, dass man im Druckendialog, wo man die Drucker ausgewählt hat, dass man da einfach einen anderen, dass man da einen anderen Namen angiben konnte beim Anlegen des Druckers und nicht einfach nur den vorhergegebenen Firmennamen hatte.
Was meinst du jetzt im Druckendialog oder beim Anlegen eines Druckers?
Wenn man Drucker anlegt, dass man dann einen anderen Namen festlegen konnte. Ging das schon vorher? Weil ich hab nämlich, ich bilde mir an, dass das nicht ging.
Du meinst jetzt für einen, der seinen Namen selber liefert?
Na die haben auch immer irgendwelche, die heißen auch immer Epson BLF 368000.
Nö, du kannst ja immer schon einen Namen angeben.
Da kann man auch schon einen Namen angeben.
Ja, ja, Name und Leakage. Das ist nichts Neues.
Unser Drucker im Club hieß immer Gutenberg und ich meine der Hersteller oder sonst jeder Drucker ist bestimmt nicht Gutenberg.
Das ist ja im Drucker.
Ja, genau, dass man diesen Namen ändern konnte. Diesen Namen, den der Drucker geliefert hat. Also einen Netzwerk-Drucker gehabt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das C0 der Fall ist, aber zumindest bei Leopard konntest du deiner Drucker noch einen beliebigen Namen geben.
Also überhaupt dieses Drucker-Ding, warum ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel einen Drucker sehe, der definitiv nicht in Reichweite ist, müsste man ihm mal etwas erklären.
Bitte was?
Ich kann jetzt hier, wenn ich jetzt drucken gehe, ich hab das Problem, ich bin öfters mal in anderen Büros, dann hab ich das irgendwie immer verpeilt mit dem Umbenennen von den Druckern, dann weißt du natürlich nicht mehr, wer hat was.
Genau, du hast dann 38, hab hier irgendwas.
Genau, und dann steht der eine in der einen Etage, der andere haben sie zweimal denselben Drucker gekauft. Ja, da hinten ist noch ein Bindestrich dran bei dem einen Drucker, konnte ich mir zumindest nie merken, welcher Drucker welcher war. Hab immer vom falschen Drucker gewartet. So, warum? Und dann natürlich noch gerne in verschiedenen Büros gearbeitet und dann kriegt mal raus, ich will jetzt gerne was ausdrucken, war das jetzt BF63 oder BF64? Und warum blenden die nicht mal? Warum gibt es sowas nicht einfach locationbasiert irgendwie? Keine Ahnung, Peppe Bonjour oder weißt ja toll, was zeigt mir die Drucker an, die da sind? Und der Rest ist einfach, wenn er außer Reichweite ist, kann ich eh nicht draufdrucken, spielt auch keine Rolle.
Ja, das stimmt, du siehst.
Aber die kommen doch schon bei Peppe Bonjour die Drucker.
Ja, aber nur wenn du ihn einrichtest.
Also Moment, zweiter.
Also es gibt Drucker über USB, da ist alles prima. Du steckst den irgendwie rein, ja, und in dem Moment, wo der angesteckt ist und sichtbar ist, dann gibt es sofort den Treiber und dann ist der irgendwie sofort überall eingetragen und du musst nicht Edprinter machen und so weiter. Drucker im Netz, vollkommen andere Geschichte. Einen Drucker im Netz musst du sozusagen als Drucker in deinem System aufnehmen. Du musst einmal sagen, ja, dieser Drucker, der da im Netz sichtbar ist, der ist jetzt sozusagen für mich auch existent und soll überall auftauchen. Nur dadurch, dass der da jetzt rumliegt, taucht der nicht automatisch auf. Wenn dann dieser Drucker aber nicht mehr da ist, hast du den trotzdem noch in allen Listen.
Das heißt, das muss mal verschwinden, diese...
Ja, und das ist auch wieder ein sehr interessanter Punkt, weil das war früher bei Mac OS 9 auch anders, nicht wahr?
Da hattest du diesen geilen Chooser mit dem geilen Apple Talk.
Mit dem geilen Apple Talk und... Ja, da hast du einfach gesehen, was da ist und du warst immer irgendwie mit diesem Nehmbeindiggen.
Nein, aber dieser Chooser, der war auch schon eher, der war auf Treiberbasis und hat einem dann angezeigt, also da hat man alle Treiber, die man installiert hat, gesehen.
Ja, aber es gab ja nur einen Treiber, nämlich Laser Freiter. Was anderes gab's ja nicht im Netz.
Ja, okay, aber es war dann irgendwann auch so, dass alle möglichen Style-Writer-Treiber mit installiert worden sind.
Ich sage nicht, dass der Weisheit letzter Schluss war. Es war aber so, dass zumindest Zugriff auf Drucker im Netz war damals immer irgendwie gar kein Problem. Und unter Mac OS X gelingt es ihnen einfach, nicht ein Interface zu machen, wo das einfach mal cool ist. Insbesondere in einer Zeit, wo eben mehr und mehr Drucker im Netz sind. Was Max sagt, er hat total recht. Ich finde das auch einfach eine totale Produktivitätsvernichtung. Weil man läuft einfach von Büro zu Büro und man hat immer wieder andere Umgebungen. Und man will einfach sagen können, wir haben jetzt Core Location hier drin. Was hält sie davon ab, etwas einzuführen, was wirklich diese Location ist, wie es auch früher, da sind wir wieder bei Mac OS 9 gar. Das Ding soll einfach wissen, ich sitze jetzt in meinem Studio oder ich sitze jetzt bei mir im Büro oder ich sitze zu Hause.
Druck du Sau!
Und dann taucht einfach ein Netzwerk-Drucker nicht auf, weil er ist nicht da, also bietet ihn mir auch gar nicht erst an. Er ist nicht da, ich bin da nicht, ich will da jetzt nicht drucken, lasse ihn einfach weg.
Drucker finde ich aber sowieso ein bizarres Thema für sich. Jede Kamera kann ich an meinen MacBook anschließen, sie ist sofort da, startet iPhoto und kann damit umgehen. Aber Drucker ist irgendwie noch so dieses, ja damals, 1982.
Aber es hat sich verbessert. Sie installieren jetzt die Drucker nicht mehr und sie machen Updates über das Internet.
Das ist, das ist, das ist, ja.
Auch Rosetta kommt übers Internet, wenn man die mal anfängt. Aber das ist ein PowerPC-Programm, startet, dann lädt er diese zweieinhalb MB aus dem Netz.
Aber bei den Druckertreibern ist es eine andere Geschichte.
Bei den Druckertreibern ist es aber trotzdem eine, ist ein, ist ein...
Was?
Es ist ein Workaround. Es ist keine, also warum jeder Drucker seinen fucking eigenen Treiber braucht, ich werd's nie verstehen. Also das ist, also ich meine, bei Laserdruckern geht's ja mit den PBDs, das ist ja schon mal, das ist ja schon mal wenigstens eine gewisse Vereinfachung. Aber warum, wenn ich, bloß weil ich einen HP-Findenstahl-Drucker an meinen Rechner anschließe?
Na ja, warum? Weil nicht alle mit demselben Protokoll arbeiten zum Beispiel und weil nicht alle Drucker gleich sind.
Ja, aber bei Kameras geht's und es geht bei DVD-Laufwerken, es geht bei allem anderen und man kann das genauso argumentieren. Und es ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ich glaube, es ist einfach ein historisches Problem, dass bei Druckern war das eben am Anfang, da war das noch nicht so standardisiert. Und jetzt heute seit USB...
Drucker haben sehr viel mehr Features.
Was haben die denn so an großartigen Features?
Drucker haben Sortierer, Drucker haben verschiedene Fächer, verschiedene Feeding-Systeme, Drucker haben eingebaute Faxgeräte, Drucker haben eingebaute Scan-Funktionen, Drucker haben dieses und jenes. Also du hast ja heute schon mit einem Großteil mit Multifunktionsdruckern zu tun. Und ein Drucker macht heute schon teilweise mehr als nur zu drucken. Und selbst wenn er das tut, musst du natürlich auch die ganzen Optionen unterstützen, was weiß ich. Du willst diese Druckertreiber, die mitgeliefert werden, die bieten dir, was weiß ich, auch die Möglichkeit zu sehen, dass deine Tinte alle ist, dass du irgendwas austauschen musst und so weiter.
Das ist nichts, was man nicht standardisieren könnte.
Ja gut, standardisieren könnte und standardisieren soll es sein. Da gibt es einfach nicht genug Triebwäder. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, das ist mehr so ein historisches Problem.
Ja genau, das meine ich. Das ist ein historisches Problem bei Kameras oder bei modernen Geräten.
Kameras sind einfach zu ähnlich. Die sammeln Bilder und bieten sie dem Rechner an. Wobei bestimmte Dinge auch da unterschiedlich sind.
Es gibt tausende RAW-Formate und es gibt schon große Unterschiede.
Ja gut, aber auch bei den RAW-Formaten einigen sie sich mittlerweile. Ja gut, das ist aber ein echtes Problem. Und da haben sie dann gearbeitet. Bei den Druckern haben sie es ja auch versucht. Aber kommen wir zu Snow Leopard. Jetzt ist es so, es sind schon zwei Updates für die HP-Triver gekommen seit Snow Leopard. Also wir sind jetzt bei Version 2.2, wo das komplette Paket HP-Triver kommt. Das heißt, dieses riesen Problem, dass du veraltete Treiber hast, ich weiß nicht, ob sie es jetzt schon gelöst haben, aber ich denke, dass sie einer Lösung dieser Treiberproblematik deutlich näher gekommen sind.
Also das war gerade mit HP was, fand ich komplett, ich musste mal wirklich auf so ein Multidink-Gerät, also so ein USB-Ast, das konnte sogar ein Netzwerk, war einfach ein Tintenstrahldrucker, der irgendwie am Netzwerk dranhängt, der kann auch faxen und kopieren und weiß ja toll was. Ich hab auch so ein Teil. Aber nicht Laser, sondern USB. Ich wollte wirklich einfach nur drei Seiten drauf drucken und ich konnte mir 400 Megabyte aus dem Netz an Treibern runterladen, konnte mein Rechnergefühlte dreimal neu starten und daraufhin ging bei jedem Start im Dock ungefähr fünf Hilfsprogramme an, die mir zum Tintenpatronenkauf gratulierten und weiß ja toll was. Ich hoffe mal, das ist besser, wenn man einfach Snow Leopard nimmt und ich hoffe mal, da ist so ein Drucker da irgendwo unauffällig drinnen.
Ja, ich habe aber die Befürchtung, dass sich das nur auf Drucken bezieht, also gerade bei den Multifunktionsdruckern. Ich habe jetzt mein Setup übernommen, deswegen weiß ich nicht ganz genau, ich muss nur noch mal schauen, aber solche Funktionalitäten wie Scannen zum Beispiel übers Netz sind nicht drin. Außerdem hat der Drucker das Problem, dass er sowohl über USB als auch über Netzwerk angeschlossen werden kann und häufig diese Treiber davon ausgehen, dass das halt USB ist. Und diese Netzseite dann sozusagen nicht berücksichtigen und dann musst du doch wieder unseren Custom-Treiber runterladen. Der dann wieder andere Probleme mit sich bringt und nicht zukunftskompatibel ist. Das bleibt spannend, das Ganze zu machen. Da fällen wir uns noch was anderes ein, was nicht mehr da ist. Was einfach ein ganz leisen Tod gestorben ist, ohne dass jemand geschrien hat. Da haben sie erst mal was dran gemacht. Ne, eine komplette alte, antike Technologie ist weggefallen. Es gibt keinen Apple Talk mehr. Was ist Apple Talk? Apple Talk ist ein Protokoll-Stack. So wie TCP-IP ein Protokoll-Stack ist. Apple Talk ist das, was die Macintoshes früher gemacht haben in ihrem Netzwerk.
Apple Talk ist kein Protokoll auf Ebene von TCP, sondern auf Ebene von IP.
Genau, es ist ein Protokoll, ein kompletter Stack. Es ist sozusagen wie die TCP-IP-Welt mit all ihren Protokollen. Das ist Apple Talk, der Name dafür, und das ist wie IP eben auch noch sozusagen zuständig für das ganze Routing usw. Und dann gibt es darin dann wiederum, muss ich gleich nochmal überlegen, wie hieß denn bei Apple Talk, wie hießen denn nochmal die einzelnen Protokolle?
Das war, man brauchte auch, über Ethernet braucht man spezielle Router, die, äh, Switches, die Apple Talk übertragen konnten, ne? Das konnte nicht jeder.
Brauchst du nicht.
Ne, für klassisches Apple Talk schon, für Apple Talk.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Du meinst das über die Serielle.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Ich meine, ich meine tatsächlich.
Der Anzahl ist no. Über Ethernet war das kein Problem. Ethernet ist bei Design Multiprotokoll und wenn du ein Ethernet-Frame, wenn du einen Switch hast, der einfach Ethernet macht, dann überträgt dir Apple Talk genauso.
Irgendwelche.
Du kannst das filtern. Du kannst das filtern, wenn du willst. Wenn du einen Router hast, der ist protokollspezifisch.
Dann war es ein Router, der Apple Talk hat.
Ja klar, ein Router ist ja gemacht für einen Protokoll-Stack. Damit sind natürlich auch solche schönen, althergebrachten Sachen, wie zum Beispiel das AFP-Protokoll, nämlich drucken über Apple Talk, APP, Print, Access-Protokoll, Papp, heißt es.
Gestorben.
Kannst du jetzt nicht mehr auf einen alten Apple Talk Drucker drücken. Aber hat halt keiner mehr. Da haben sie einfach wieder was komplett weggelassen. Hieß ja noch mal gleich das IP.
Hörten sie bei Freebies, die auch noch rausschmeißen. Da haben die das auch noch.
Gdp hieß das Protokoll, was sozusagen IP war.
Tokenring 3.
Apple Talk war geil. Also Apple Talk, noch mal dazu sagen, war einfach großartig, weil das hat einfach funktioniert. Du hast irgendwie zwei Macs gehabt.
Aber es hat nicht skaliert.
Nee, es hat nicht skaliert, aber es hat für die damaligen...
Und es hat ziemlich Overhead, glaube ich.
Ja, was heißt, es hat ziemlich... Ja, natürlich, es war kein Internet-Protokoll, sondern es war ein Netzwerk im Sinne von lokales Netzwerk. Es war ein LAN-Protokoll.
Das war so typisch Apple, das hat funktioniert.
Ja, du hast es irgendwie angesteckt und dann hast du ein Netzwerk. Du hast so drei Rechner mit einem Serialkabel verbunden und alle konnten sich gegenseitig sehen. Und wenn du noch einen Drucker dazu gemacht hast, dann konnten alle darauf drucken. Und das ging 1990 problemlos, immer ohne größere Probleme.
Diese nette Talkboxen kosten schon Schweinegeld, oder? Die nette Talkboxen? Wenn man zwei Geräte, also zwei Macs, konnte man per Serien einen Kabelpunkt aus.
Super, alles glücklich.
Also du meinst die Transceiver-Boxen.
Genau, da waren so kleine Boxen, die man irgendwie...
Man konnte doch auch drei Rechner per Serie irgendwie zusammen schalten.
Ja, aber du brauchst dieses Trans... Also, nochmal. Apple Talk ist die Software, das Routing ist der Protokoll-Stack. Local Talk war die Übertragung von Apple Talk über RS-422.
Nee, ach so, genau.
Und Ether Talk war Übertragung von Apple Talk über Ethernet. So, und dann gab es irgendwie noch Token Talk und diesen ganzen Kram und so. Hat aber wahrscheinlich eh kaum einer benutzt.
Und dann kam halt irgendwann bei Mac OS 9 oder 8 oder 7 oder wo immer kam dann Apple Talk over IP und das war dann halt...
Ja, ja, aber ich meine noch richtig Local Talk-Zeiten, dieses ganz langsame, als man glücklich war, wenn man 200 Kilobit hatte über so ein Kabel. Und da gab es so, da brauchte man, wenn man drei Geräte verbinden wollte, braucht man diese kleinen Boxen.
Genau, im Prinzip war braucht es das.
Und die waren plötzlich Schweine teuer.
Plötzlich?
Naja, mit zwei Geräten braucht es den Druckerkabel und beim dritten Gerät braucht es dann plötzlich Jing, Jing, Jing, Jing, Jing und dann...
Ja gut, so war das halt einfach. Später gab es auch mal Ethernet, da brauchte man das nicht mehr.
Mit Phone Talk, das war irgendwie so...
Das waren nur andere Kabel, das war dann...
Ja, ja, das war von so einem Drittel-Installer, der...
Das war nicht Belkin, sondern so einer, den es später auch noch gab.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr von wem, aber auf jeden Fall gleiche Box, nicht von Apple, aber ein bisschen günstiger.
Und man konnte auch noch alle Telefonkabel entwickeln. Ach ja, klondike, damals im Krieg, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, damals haben Dinge einfach funktioniert, die bei IP sehr lange gebraucht haben, bis sie funktioniert haben. Wie zum Beispiel so was wie, wir teilen uns automatisch Netzwerkadressen zu. Wie lange musste man in IP-Netzen wirklich händisch jedem Rechner noch eine IP-Adresse geben und sich über Netzwerk- und Host-Anteile Gedanken machen? Das hat erst mit macOS 10.2 gelöst, seitdem sie irgendwie Rendezvous eingeführt haben. So, jetzt funktionieren IP-Netze ansatzweise so gut wie damals Apple Talk.
Aber sie skalieren deutlich besser.
Also Apple Talk könnte sie nicht weltweit fahren. Was sie auch gemacht haben, ist, dass das Apple File Sharing-Protokoll, also AFP, bei Snow Leopard gerade die Version 3.1 ist. Sie unterstützen auch noch die Version 3.0, aber sie unterstützen keine älteren Versionen mehr. Das heißt, wenn man mit einem Mac OS 9 Rechner noch File Sharing mit dem Snow Leopard machen wollen würde, würde es nicht gehen.
Ja, ist einfach vorbei. Ja, was ist mir noch aufgefallen? Was ist euch noch aufgefallen?
Bei Snow Leopard?
Es gibt jetzt Scanner-Sharing.
Mir ist ein kleiner Bug aufgefallen. Zwar, wenn man mit Apfel-Tapp zwischen Programmen durchgeht.
Du immer mit deinen Bugs.
Habe ich öfters mal, dass einige Programme nicht mit ihrem High-Resolution-Icon dargestellt sind, sondern mit so einem Low-Resolution-Icon.
Jetzt kommst du wieder mit deinem Montags-OS.
Der hat ein Grafikkartenproblem, ist das der?
Das ist der, wenn es auf beiden Grafikkarten auftritt. Jetzt habe ich extra auf die große geschaltet, obwohl ich eigentlich nur die kleine brauche.
Bleiben wir bei Features vom OS.
Ein geiles Feature vom OS, wo wir bei Grafikkarten sind, dieses GroundCentre, nein, OpenCL, könnte theoretisch beide Grafikkarten bei mir nutzen. Parallel.
Da gibt's so ein Tool, kannst du runterladen. Soll ich mal die Uhr rausfinden für den User? Tim erzählt sein nächstes Feature und ich suche mal dieses Tool raus.
Ich werde schon wieder korrigiert, das Scanner-Sharing auch schon vorher gab.
Ja, wollte ich auch gerade schon sagen, ist doch nichts Neues.
Ist das so? Aber sie haben dieses Image-Capture-Tool irgendwie komplett überarbeitet und wahrscheinlich findet man das erste Mal Features neu.
Ja, das ist geil, weil bei Image-Capture-Tool, da kann man jetzt ein iPhone share.
Wie, was und dann?
Als was?
Als Kamera?
Als Kamera oder als...
Image-Capture, wenn du ein iPhone anschließt, kriegst du eine Liste mit allen Fotos und auch allen Videos. Und dann gibt es unten links in der Ecke so Share iPhone.
Das ist wahrscheinlich als... Tja, gute Frage, als was denn eigentlich?
Na, wer traut sich? Komm, einer von euch muss jetzt nicht trauen.
Die hatten ja schon immer dieses Sharing drin, dass du sozusagen auch so eine Webcam damit hattest. Ja, du kannst bestimmte Kameras anschließen und mit Image Capture kannst du dann über das Netz... Also, der hat dann so einen Webserver gestartet und dann kannst du dann irgendwie von anderen Rechnern aus die Kamera fern auslösen. Das hat nie so kameraübergreifend funktioniert. Ich muss gleich mal mein iPhone anschließen hier irgendwie.
Ich finde jetzt dieses Open-Side-Video...
Okay, also ich bin super hier im Ausgraben von Features, die es schon immer gab. Großartig.
Ja, was cool ist, wenn du schon nicht wusstest, dass es die vorher gab, dann gibt es wahrscheinlich noch eine Menge Leute mehr, die nicht wussten, dass es das schon gibt. Und dann ist es grundsätzlich...
Es ist jetzt schon wieder so lange her, dass ich mir das aufgeschrieben habe. Man darf nicht so lange Pausen machen.
Wir tun einfach so, als ob wir über Leopard reden würden.
Genau, die OpenCL N-Body Simulation. Damit kannst du deinen Rechner richtig volle Kanne geben.
Die OpenCL was?
OpenCL N-Body Simulation-Example. Ist irgendwie von Apple oder so, glaube ich. Wie kann ich denn mal hier den Pfeil namens so hier kopieren? Danach müsst ihr mal suchen. Da kommt so ein cooles Tool.
Dann gucke ich mir das jetzt mal an.
Jungs, wir haben jetzt schon eineinhalb Stunden hier irgendwie geredet, aber irgendwie ist noch nichts bei Robber gekommen.
Na flotter. Dann einfach ein bisschen mehr Zack hier.
Ich gucke gerade mal.
Das klingt jetzt nach total viel mehr Zack.
Jetzt hast du mich hier total angefingst mit diesem iPhone-Dingsbums. Ich muss natürlich mal kurz gucken, was dieses Sharing macht.
Mach einfach mal alles share und ich gucke mal, ob hier was in meinem Feinde auftaucht. Genau, klick mal drauf. Los, komm, trau dich. Give it to me.
Ja, ich habe es jetzt geshared.
Hast du das schon?
Wo kann man das iPhone share?
Die Frage ist, wer jetzt diesen Share sieht.
Wie heißt denn deine Kiste?
Liar Bird.
Sag jetzt noch mal ganz kurz, wo es das iPhone Sharing angeht.
Image Capture heißt das Tool.
Tim Prickler's Public Folder.
Sharing your camera. Ja, das ist einfach die Kamerafunktion.
Ah, ich muss Image Capture auch aufmachen. Das wird sein. Die Zuhörer sind jetzt bestimmt voll so gelb, langweilig. Was machen die denn da für einen Scheiß? Aber ihr könnt es ja parallel mitmachen und könnt dann auf den Rechner von Mutti draufgucken. Guck mal hier, Apple, iPhone, Liar Bird. Ich kann hier jetzt deine Bilder sehen.
Ich sehe einfach nur die Bilder.
Deine Bilder, nicht die Kamera.
Nee, ich sehe deine Bilder. Darf ich irgendwas nicht sehen? Ich wusste schon, ob ich das in den Club nicht einschalte.
Das ist jetzt nichts besonders.
Ich klicke mal 693. Ja, das sieht nach Dokument aus. So, Doppelklick. Nee, Doppelklick geht nicht. Ich ziehe es mal auf meinen Desktop. Ich bin mal so frech.
Was soll denn das? Warum sollte man denn?
Warum man alle freigeben kann, ohne sich einen speziellen Folder zu machen, ist schon ein bisschen krass. Ich habe mir das Bild jetzt rübergezogen. Das scheint aber nicht von deinem iPhone zu sein, weil es ist nur 1200 x 1600.
Wie? Nur von was?
Ich habe mir jetzt das Bild gerade rübergezogen von dir.
Ja, das habe ich mit meinem iPhone gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich mit dem Alten, oder?
Aber da steht 1200 x 1600.
Ja, und?
Ach so, so groß war das? Das zwei Ambit?
Ich weiß nicht, was war das denn?
Von dem 3G ist das noch.
Keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, mehr hatte ich nicht.
Ja, das sind 119 Millionen Pixel.
Soll ich schnell Import All drücken?
Nein, ich mache erstmal Share iPhone aus.
Oh mein Gott, du kennst das iPhone-Share.
Davon hat auch noch keiner berichtet, oder?
Naja, es gab wahrscheinlich Wichtigeres zum Bereden.
Ich habe übrigens ein Hübsches, wegen Wichtigeres, also ich finde es ganz süß, probiert mal bei der neuen Webseite, habe ich gerade vorher noch gebastelt, die Zitierfunktion aus. Ich finde die ganz niedlich geworden. Ja, das ist ein neues Snow Leopard-Feature, das man nutzen kann auf jedem Betriebssystem, wenn man auf mobilemax.de geht.
Verstehe.
Hey, wenn ihr iPhone-Kameras schert.
Das ist ein 10.6-Feature. Und immerhin eins, was es noch nicht gegeben hat. Glaube ich.
Vermutlich.
So weiter, noch mehr neue Features.
Was ich ja ganz großartig finde, sind die Änderungen im Preview. Im Vorschau-Programm.
Ja, und zwar kann ich dir schon sagen, was das Großartigste ist. Und zwar, dass du jetzt einen PDF hast mit zwei so Spalten und du willst den Text irgendwie dir kopieren. Dass du, wenn du den kopierst, nicht irgendwie den Text von den beiden Spalten direkt nebeneinander in einer Zeile hast, sondern dass er wirklich erst die eine Spalte irgendwie beim Pasten kommt und dann die andere Spalte. Also dass der Textflow von dem PDF irgendwie gewartet. Das ist schon...
Exakt.
Das war vorher einfach nicht Apple-Style.
Ja, das ist aber schon eine echte Leistung, weil das natürlich das PDF-Format so überhaupt nicht hergibt. Also diese Informationsspalte existiert nicht in PDF.
Das heißt, der Text ist da wirklich so nebeneinander auch abgelegt?
Sie schauen sich das PDF an und gucken, was da so beieinander liegt und eine Spalte sein mag. Aber PDF kennt sowas nicht wie ein Columnflow. Genau. In Flow stellen die eigentlich erst in der Interpretation des Programms her. Und von daher ist das so...
Ein Mangel des PDF-Designs, oder?
Ja gut, das kann man so sehen. Das war schon bei PostScript nicht anders.
Klar, weil der Drucker so drucken muss, ne?
Weil das halt einfach mal so funktioniert hat. Und die Idee mit... Ich meine, so Flow bringt natürlich noch eine ganze Menge Probleme mit sich. Weil in dem Moment, wo du so einen Flow hast... Ich meine, gut, alles, was wir hätten machen müssen, ist solche Text zu vergeben, dass man so Text vergeben kann und sagen kann, diese Zeile ist Zeile sowieso in einem Kontext. Und hier ist die nächste und die gehören irgendwie zusammen. Du positionierst sie aber immer noch absolut an bestimmten Stellen auf der Seite. Das ist ja das, was PDF eigentlich macht. Naja, ich finde, diese ganze Suche und die Thumbnails sind größer und so weiter. Also das Programm, finde ich, hat einfach deutlich zugelegt an Benutzbarkeit. Das ist doch schon eine erhebliche Verbesserung.
Im Doc habe ich ein Feature, das ich total toll finde. Ich finde diese Stacks, die daraus fliegen, die finde ich ganz hübsch, die neuen. Also dass man jetzt auch rumscrollen kann und so was und dass man sich in Ordnern bewegen kann. Was leider nach wie vor nicht geht, ist, dass man aus einem Stack in einen anderen kopieren kann. Also ich kann, was ich zum Beispiel gerne habe, im Doc habe ich meinen Downloads Ordner drin und ich habe im Doc meinen Programme Ordner. Wenn ich jetzt ein Programm runtergeladen habe und ich möchte es jetzt gerne in meinen Applications Ordner liegen, liegt ja nichts näher, als den Stack aufzumachen im Doc, das Programm zu nehmen und drüber zu ziehen in das entsprechende Icon im Doc. Also in den anderen Stack sozusagen.
Weil ich benutze diese Stacks?
Ja.
Aber das geht doch.
Nee, das geht nicht. Du kannst das auf den Desktop ziehen. Du kannst es auf den Desktop in einen Stack ziehen. Was hast du denn da liegen in so einem Stack?
Also guck mal, ich kann jetzt hier...
Also ich hab einmal...
Nee, guck, ich nehme das Click to Flash, ja? Nehme das raus, gehe wieder drauf. Ah, und dann öffnet das nicht, meinst du, ja? Mach's noch dunkler, aber dann öffnet das nicht.
Nee, nicht nur, dass er kopiert...
Doch, jetzt.
Dann könntest du jetzt hier einen Ordner schmissen. Dann gibt's vielleicht beim Kopieren Probleme oder irgendwie sowas. Nee, aber ich möchte gar keinen Ordner aufmieten. Ich möchte das einfach nur aufs Icon draufziehen. Warte mal, guck mal kurz, ob das geht.
Undo Move, ich kann sogar rückgängig machen.
Ich konnte das gerade machen.
Oh, stimmt, du hast recht, das geht doch.
Gut, dann ist es doch was, was jetzt geht. Das ging vorher aber auch hundertprozentig.
Ich benutze diese Stacks nicht.
Ich benutze sie ständig.
Ich auch nicht.
Wofür denn? Also was, wofür?
Ich hab da zum Beispiel meinen Download-Orner drinnen.
Ja, das ist doch das Einzige, wofür du es benutzt und dann nach Timen sortieren und dann kann man immer das neuste Icon vorsehen.
Genau, das neuste immer vorne.
Das hier, Jungs, wenn ihr Icons designt, ja immer schön mit Alpha arbeiten, weil Icons werden auch übereinander dargestellt.
Ich hab...
Das sind ja genau die Icons alle aufeinander draufgeklatscht.
Ja, das ist halt ein Stack.
Ach, das ist doch furchtbar. Was, was, was? Das ist ja also ein... Nee. Also... Also wirklich ernsthaft, ich kann damit überhaupt nichts anfangen. Also diese ganzen Stacks, die waren mir schon bei Leopard irgendwie so ein... Irgendwie, was soll das? Aber okay, wenn das Leute nutzen können, ist das völlig okay.
Ich hab mich sehr schnell mit... Also es ist ein schneller... Es ist ein bisschen so wie damals bei... Fällt mir jetzt gerade auf bei Mac OS 9, da gab es ja diese Pop-Up-Fenster, die man sich unten am Bildschirm ranklatschen konnte im Finder. Habt ihr noch dran erinnern? Die hat man so im Finder-Fenster genommen, so ganz normal, das hat sie nach unten gezogen.
Window Shade.
Und ne, Window Shade war das andere. Window Shade war, dass es in die Titelleiste reinfuhr. Das oben diese zusätzliche Box hatte.
Stimmt, das haben sie mit Mac OS 8 eingeführt. Wie hieß denn das nochmal, dass man die Fenster unten ranklatschen konnte?
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, Pop-Up-Fenster oder irgendwie sowas. Das fand ich eigentlich immer ein ganz geiles Feature, weil man das ständig gemacht hat. Und eigentlich ist DeX was relativ ähnliches. Weil es ist auch, du hast ein kleines Icon auf deinem Bildschirm, was ein Fenster für wenige Sekunden aufmacht und für genau einen Klick. Und sobald du deine Operation abgeschlossen hast, ist es wieder weg.
Also ich hab nicht einen Ordner gefunden, den ich täglich benutze, den ich immer drin kleben haben wollen würde.
Downloads-Verzeichnis.
Weil du kannst ja noch nicht mal was reindrängen und reinfallen lassen.
Das ist ja genau das, was ja mittlerweile geht. Also das ging schon immer aus dem Finder-Constitution. Immer Dinge da reindrängen und reinfallen.
Ja, aber nur in denen selber. Nicht in irgendwas da drunter. Kannst ja nicht so durch.
Na dann geht das Finder-Fenster auf mittlerweile. Ich hab den Screenshots-Ordner hab ich da drin.
Ja genau, da geht der Finder offen. Also entweder macht man das dann im Doc oder nicht.
Und mein Desktop ist da drin. Weil ich speichere, wenn ich eine Teil abspeichere. Dann mach ich gerne beim Apfel-S, dann Apfel-D, geh ich auf den Desktop. Und der Desktop ist eigentlich der denkbar blödeste Ordner, um irgendwas abzuspeichern, weil man ihn ja nie sieht. Darum hab ich mir den Desktop noch mal zusätzlich...
Wie im richtigen Leben.
Genau, darum hab ich mir den Desktop zusätzlich noch mal ins Doppelicke einfach.
Find ich ganz praktisch.
Ja, aber was liegst du denn da ab? Auf dem Desktop, wenn du ihn nicht brauchst. Zeug!
Bei mir ist alles voll.
Aktuelle Projekte landen immer auf dem Desktop.
Hier zum Beispiel noch eine komplett veraltete MySQL Installation, die ich gerne mal wegschmeißen kann.
Also ich bin auch noch nie ein Freund des Schreibtischkonzeptes gewesen. Ich find, der Schreibtisch hat sich einfach nicht... Ist ja auch scheiße, aber wo muss das solche hin? Ja, aber wozu eine Abstraktion Schreibtisch einführen und dann ein OS-Design, was in seinem ganzen User-Interface so ausgelegt ist, dass diesen Schreibtisch die ganze Zeit überdeckt? Ja, ich muss halt irgendwas drücken, um irgendwas zu sehen und das ist einer...
Ja, aber wenn das nicht auf dem Desktop liegt, musst du noch viel mehr drücken, um was zu sehen.
Ja, aber das ist nur ein Ordner von Hunderten, die ich benutze. Warum soll ich nur für diesen einen einzigen Ordner sowas einführen? Und der ist noch nicht mal praktisch.
Also da legt man Sachen ab, wo man denkt, die hat man noch nicht so lange und räumt man wieder weg und wie das halt mit dem richtigen Schreibtisch ist, die liegen dann halt da wochenlang rum. Genau. Bis man dann immer wieder aufräumt.
Ich finde das Konzept von...
also ich finde es... Also ich sag euch mal, was ich nach wie vor schlecht finde. Wo einfach keinerlei Evolution stattgefunden hat, wo meiner Meinung nach dieser ganze Desktop-Kram eigentlich hingehört. Das sind diese Open- und Safe-Dialoge. Der Moment, wo du endlich... Bitte?
Da ist doch gar kein Platz für meine 1000 Ike, die auf dem Desktop liegen.
Was? Ja, das Problem ist doch, dass du überhaupt hier so einen Ort überhaupt erst mal schaffst, wo 1000 Sachen liegen. Ja, warum können die Sachen nicht einfach irgendwo liegen, aber du machst den Zugriff auf alles, egal wo es ist, einfacher? Im Prinzip haben sie das ja mit Spotlight schon versucht, dass du sozusagen über den Inhalt irgendwie findest, aber wir wissen alle, das funktioniert bis heute auch nicht. Das ist irgendwie auch bei Snow Leopard so ein Problem.
Das ist so, wenn du sagen würdest, der Schreibtisch an sich wäre falsch, weil man da Sachen ablegen könnte.
Guck dir doch mal Schreibtische an.
Ja, stell dir vor, du hättest keinen. Stell dir vor, du müsstest jetzt bei jedem kleinen Scheiß immer irgendwie drüber latschen, Schublade ziehen, gucken, in welcher Schublade war es denn nun und so. Du brauchst doch die Sachen direkt so, damit du Dreck und Drop zum Beispiel fix machen kannst, ohne irgendwelche Fenster zu öffnen.
Ich weiß nicht, also wenn ich ein Programm starte und ich will auf irgendein Dokument zugreifen, dann liegt dieses Dokument nicht auf dem Desktop, sondern dann liegt dieses Dokument in einem Projektordner. Und dieser Projektordner ist einer von mehreren Projektordnern in einem Ordner Projekte, der in einem Ordner, was weiß ich...
Ja, sowas hab ich auch, aber jeder Ordner ist ein Projekt zugeordnet. Ich tippe irgendwo rasch eine Telefonnummer rein, ich hab irgendwie hier einen Screenshot gemacht, ich hab einen Text angefangen, den ich vielleicht noch fertig schreiben will, von dem ich nicht weiß, was daraus wird.
Ich hab massenhaft Zeug auf meinem Desktop rumliegen, aber das ist ja auch gar nicht egal, aber ich find ja gut, aber es ist unsortiert und ich finde, ja, das meiste hab ich aber in solchen Projektordnern. Hab ich einfach.
Also ich finde, man sollte mal langsam was machen, also da hat irgendjemand gerade in den Chat geschrieben, Open und Safe sollen mal sterben und in Auto Safe kommen, das ist definitiv richtig. Ich möchte gern, wenn ich BB-Edit starte und BB-Edit kriegt das mittlerweile, ich glaube sogar hin, wenn es abstürzt, dass es einfach alle Fenster restored, auch wenn ich die nicht explizit gespeichert habe oder sowas.
Ja, Assistenz, na klar, man will die saven.
Ich will nicht saven, ich möchte mir nicht Datei-Namen ausdenken. Die Suche ist mittlerweile fast so gut, dass man auf Datei-Namen scheißen könnte. Und das ist...
Da kann ich ja mal wieder Werbung für Cars-Ride Express machen. Das Thema kam nämlich genauso zur Sprache bei dem Podcast über... Mensch-Maschinen-Interaktion, CAE 131.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob es dafür nicht... Also für so eine neue Desktop-Metapher, in Anführungsstrichen, kann durchaus sein, dass es dafür zu spät ist, weil einfach das vom Web überholt wird. Vielleicht was zwangsläufig. Aber irgendwie könnte da ruhig mal was Neues her.
Finde ich.
Dieser Open-Self-Dialog, der ist wirklich ranzig. Du kannst... Also es gibt ja noch nicht mal eine konsistente, letzte benutzte Ordner.
Das sind aber die Programme schuld.
Nee, da sind die Programme überhaupt nicht dran schuld.
Aber alle sind wieder schuld.
Was?
Da wird das schon gekodet. Du kannst das machen. Du kannst ja in verschiedenen Bereichen in deinem Programm verschiedene Sachen speichern und man kann es dann pro Anwendungsfall sich den Ordner merken, wo er geöffnet wurde. Wenn du es nicht richtig machst als Programm, dann kommt natürlich immer nur einer hoch. Also immer der Gleiche.
Moment, warum müssen sich meine Programme etwas merken, was sich mein OS für die Programme merken könnte?
Weil das OS ja nicht weiß, was da gerade gespeichert wird.
Also ein Programm, was irgendwie Bilder und Musik speichern kann. Das sind ja zwei verschiedene...
Das fängt ja schon beim Öffnen an. Ja, einfach nur so die letzten Ordner konsistent einfach mal über alle Programme hinweg und sich merken, was ich zuletzt mit diesem Programm aufgemacht habe. Das passt einfach nicht. Du kannst ja Default-Folder installieren, da ist einiges besser. So habe ich aber irgendwie bei Mac OS X immer nicht gerne gemacht, weil sich das Ding auf so eine ganz eklige Art und Weise integriert. Ich finde diesen Open-Safe-Dialog einfach schwach. Da wird einfach zu wenig getan. Das ist irgendwie zu modal. Das hat sich zwar so ein bisschen verbessert, aber dass da wirklich mal darüber nachgedacht wird, dass ich da einen dynamischen Browser aufmache, der weiß, was ich tue, der weiß, welche Ordner ich meistens benutze und die mir einfach auch anbietet und mir den letzten Ordner, den ich mit diesem Programm verwendet habe, einfach bei Default wieder hochbringt. Und zwar nicht den letzten Ordner, den ich gerade benutzt habe, weil in Programm A arbeite ich halt in dem Ordner und mit Programm B arbeite ich in einem ganz anderen Ordner, weil der mit dem nichts zu tun hat.
Überhaupt ist dieser ganze Open- und Safe-Dialog total... Also das ist, würde ich sagen, das ist noch aus der Zeit, als es noch kein Multitasking gab. Daher kommt ja dieser Dialog. Eigentlich war es ja so, du hast einen Finder gehabt und da konntest du deine Detail mit organisieren. Und wenn du ein Programm offen hattest, hatte es ja plötzlich keinen Finder mehr.
Weil das systemmodal war meistens.
Weil das systemmodal war.
Das ist ja mal ein anderes Problem.
Beziehungsweise weil der Finder einfach nicht mehr lief, weil die Ressourcen nicht zur Verfügung standen. Und das ist dann irgendwann besser geworden. Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Meinst du, die Programme von heute sollten einem automatisch so einen Icon unter die Maus zaubern, was auch schon festgehalten wird, was man nur noch irgendwo abschmeißen muss?
Na ja, ich meine, eine Option ist zumindest, es gibt ja diese, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine gute Variante ist, aber es gibt ja oben diese Handles, wie die heißen, also dass das Icon noch mal oben im Dokumentfenster drin ist. Und das kann man ja nehmen und könnte es ja irgendwo hinschmeißen, wo man es gerade hin haben möchte. Zum Beispiel könnte man es ins Doc schmeißen oder so was. Oder eben in den eigenen Projekte ordnen. Und dann wär's dann drin. Und wenn man da noch irgendwie eine Möglichkeit in das Fenster direkt einbaut, die Datei umzubenennen, dann hätte man sich einen kompletten Open- und Self-Dialog gespart. Öffnen mach ich per Doppelklick, Safe mach ich eben darüber. Und also eigentlich hätte man dieses Konzept wirklich mal im Laufe der letzten 20 Jahre doch mal, mittlerweile 25 Jahre, wirklich mal ein bisschen weiter denken dürfen, finde ich. Und ich glaube, es kommt tatsächlich daher. Es hat sich nicht wirklich, also wenn man sich ein, man sollte mal als öffnender Dialoge seit System eins Screenshots von machen. Das ist im Wesentlichen immer noch die gleiche Box.
Es ist furchtbar. Das ist alte Scheiße. Features, Snow Leopard, da gibt es dann noch diese Sachen mit dem File Sharing.
Nee, doch. Ich mag's.
Willst du noch auf das alte Thema eingehen oder?
Nee, ich hab gerade einen super Feature, was ich sonst vergessen habe. Das wird, äh, das wird.
Jetzt hab ich aber gerade mit meinem Feature angefangen.
Na gut, dann fang du mit deinem Feature an.
Du kannst dir da jetzt besser merken, File Sharing, das haben wir jetzt ja schon gehört. Aber jetzt sagst du.
Fond.
Fond?
Dein Lieblingsfond, dein neuer.
Das gibt es hier, diesen neuen, wer ist er? Merl?
Ich weiß nicht, du hast ihn genutzt. Du hast gesagt, das wird toll sein.
Merlon heißt der. Und den gibt es im Terminal. Und ich glaube, den gibt es auch bei Xcode. Menlo. Menlo, genau, nicht Merlon, Menlo.
Das zentral im System eingebaut, oder?
Und das ist jetzt der neue Standardfond für Terminal und bei Xcode. Und der sieht schon schick aus. Ich weiß nicht, ob er jetzt besser ist. Kann ich nicht so genau sagen. Aber ich benutze ihn jetzt erst mal und ich find's okay.
Ich finde ihn auch okay, aber ich weiß nicht, Monaco.
Und er ist Auto-Anti-Alias. Man kann es nicht abschalten, glaube ich. So ist es nicht bei der Größe, die ich benutze.
Ah, verstehe.
Weil Monaco muss man das ja mal von Hand einschalten. Jetzt ist es per Die-Fault an.
Also ich habe ja schon seit Jahren keinen Monaco mehr benutzt, weil ich Anti-Alias ein Toll finde. Und ich bin immer mit damit benutzt.
Ich habe Monaco immer mit damit benutzt.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich fand Monaco, ich bin ein großer Freund von Deja Vu-Sans. Ich habe irgendwann einen ewig langen Artikel auf Mobile Max geschrieben.
Gut, dass ihr das erwähnt habt. Ich hatte nämlich auf diesem Menlo umgeschaltet. Ich muss jetzt mal wieder zurück auf Monaco, weil eigentlich finde ich Monaco geiler.
Ja, das ist alter.
Aber der Menlo ist ein bisschen dichter, kann das sein?
Ja, das gibt es auch. Komischerweise eine Vergrößerungsstufe. Also man kann ja mit Abfüll plus minus kleiner größer machen. Und bei einer, da wird eigentlich der Font nicht größer, aber er wird irgendwie ein bisschen mehr bowled, aber auch nur ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist voll witzig.
Geschmackssache.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber man kann jetzt ein Split-View machen im Terminal.
Wieder, ja. Das ging ja auch schon mal früher.
Ja, warum man das jetzt wird ausgebaut?
Weil es eh keiner benutzt.
Warum man das wieder eingebaut? Weil es dann doch wieder alle haben wollten.
Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht hat einer rumgeheult bestimmt. Jordan Gruber hat gesagt, er macht mal wieder an und dann... File Sharing hast du gerade gesagt.
Vielleicht haben sie es wegen den Tabs abgeschafft. Weil sie dachten Tabs sind besser als Split View?
Wie auch immer, File Sharing. Es gibt dieses neue obskure Feature, wo sie behaupten, dass du jetzt eben auch dann noch auf einen Rechner zugreifen kannst per File Sharing, wenn er schläft.
Ja, aber nur, wenn man eine Extreme Airport...
Genau, das ist nämlich das, was sie nicht sagen, wie es nämlich funktioniert. Das heißt, in dem Moment, also du hast diesen typischen Fall, du hast so einen Mac Mini und der so als Medium Server im Haus installiert ist und der gammelt irgendwie rum und du willst ihn ganz gerne als Server benutzen, aber da du ihn immer im Schlafmodus hast, um Strom zu sparen, machst du das dann irgendwie auch nicht. Und was ist halt jetzt mit Rechnern, die eben schlafen? So, und was passiert jetzt? Jetzt kannst du... Muss man irgendjemand irgendwas sagen oder ist das einfach bei Snow Leopard so? Der erkennt, dass... Weißt du es, wie es genau funktioniert?
Na, was man genau einschömmen muss, weiß ich nicht, aber auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass der Mac Mini, der sogenannte, der geht schlafen und die Airport Express Station übernimmt die IP-Adresse und announced per Bonjour, dass da Filesharing läuft und wenn jemand drauf zugreift, dann weckt die Airport Express per Wake on Ethernet oder Wake on LAN geht sogar auf, weckt den Mac Mini auf und gibt schnell die IP-Adresse ab, damit der aufgewächte Rechner... Achso. Und der wägt dann auf und dann kann der Rechner übernehmen und du connectest dann zu dem Mac Mini und nicht zu der Airport Extreme.
Da frage ich mich, ob das nicht irgendwie ein fettes Sicherheitsloch ist für irgendwas, dass man im Netz... Also ich meine, wer... Du musst dein Rechner......autorisiert denn dann die Büchse dafür, die IP-Adresse zu übernehmen, das kann sowieso jeder machen.
Ja, so lange der schläft ist egal, der Rechner hat die Adresse ja eh nicht, weil er schläft ja. Und wegen der ACP ist es sowieso eigentlich dynamisch zu gewesen. Er könnte sogar, wenn es ist, also ich weiß nicht, wie sie es genau rumfaschen...
Ja, aber woher weiß die Airport Extreme, dass sie das tun soll?
Na, das kann man wahrscheinlich im OS, im Snow Leopard einschalten. Und wo? Das weiß ich halt nicht genau. Ich hab ja keine Express... Ich hab keine Extreme, ich hab nur Express und die kann das nicht.
Ich hab ja eine Time Capsule...
Ich weiß nicht, auf welcher Seite von beiden man es einstellen muss. Das kann natürlich auch sein, dass man es nur auf der extremen Seite einstellen muss, weil der Rechner muss ja davon eventuell gar nichts wissen. Wobei der muss natürlich auch aufweckbar sein.
Also hier im Normalsharing ist nichts zu sehen.
Das war einmal bei Energy Saver war das eigentlich früher, oder? Hier, Wake for Ethernet Network Access. Also ich kann hier das auf jeden Fall einschalten, dass ich ihn aufwecken kann per...
Ja, aber vielleicht ist es dann damit verbunden, dass wenn das geht, dass dann irgendwie... Klingt wie etwas, was nicht unbedingt von Anfang an funktioniert. Wenn es allerdings gut funktioniert, ist es ein interessanter...
This informs other devices that your computer is still available on the network. Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich hier das Wake for Ethernet Access einschalte, bei Energy Saver kriegt man das.
Bei Energy Saver?
Das war doch schon immer da, aufwecken halt.
Nur der Kommentar ist ein anderer sozusagen. Wake for Ethernet Access. You may hear your computer wake up occasionally.
Krasser, ich schalte das mal ein.
Wie, was passiert da?
Also, es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass selbst wenn ein Rechner schläft, er über Ethernet und neu jetzt auch mit neuen Rechnern, da könnte unter Umständen dazugehören, auch über WLAN.
Genau, also Wake on LAN ist ja ein alter Hut.
Aber Wake on WLAN?
Wake on WLAN ist genauso alter Hut eigentlich.
Wie alt ist der Hut?
Paar Jahre? Ach, und wer macht das? Ich meine, welche?
Ja, die Heros-Karte, die hier drin ist, die bleibt einfach an, zack.
Das ist irgendwie ein Voodoo-Magic, wie bei über Ethernet-Kabel ganz normal auch.
Also sie schicken irgendwie so ein komisches Paket auf die Mac-Adresse und die Karte reagiert darauf und schaltet den Rest ein. Also das ist wirklich hingefuscht.
Aber es ist schon so ein explizites Wach mal auf-Paket und nicht jedes Paket, weil dann würde er wahrscheinlich nie schlafen.
Ich glaube in dem Paket selber muss nochmal genau wieder die Mac-Adresse drinstehen. Oder irgendwie so. Das war wirklich nur so ein hingefuschtes Zeug, weil es nichts dolles ist.
Ja, auch eine schöne kleine Änderung. Ich hatte das auch hier schon mal gefordert übrigens. Wenn du jetzt in dem Sound-Preferenzes im Menü dein Lautstärkersymbol einblendest, das, was man nie macht, weil das eigentlich zuerst rausschmeißt. Genau, aber wenn du das jetzt wieder machst und dann mit Option da reinklickst, also gehaltene Option-Taste, dann hast du so einen Input Device Selektor.
Nein.
Und einen Output Device Selektor.
Wirklich?
Ja, wofür ich mir sonst immer Sound Source installiert habe. Sound Source macht eigentlich im Prinzip dasselbe. Einziger Unterschied jetzt noch ist, du kannst hier nur In- und Output machen und das gilt dann sozusagen für System- und Default-Output gleichzeitig. Sound Source macht das noch unterschiedlich.
Die sollen den Lautstärkeregler gleich weglassen. Ich will das immer so haben.
Also das geht übrigens, du kannst gleich mal weiterklicken. Auch wenn du mit Option auf Bluetooth klickst.
Ja, das kenne ich ja schon.
Da kriegst du auch neue Sachen.
Ja und mit und auf dem Airport-Dings auch natürlich.
Beim Airport geht ja richtig mal die Luzi ab.
Da kriegst du den Bluetooth-Exporer und Bluetooth-Diagnostics-Utility und Packet-Logger. Also unglaublich, da scheint ja doch eine ganze Menge schief gelaufen zu sein. Oder ist das jetzt das iPhone?
Das war schon immer dabei. Auch für USB gibt es das. Wenn man Xcode installiert, dann kriegt man diese ganzen Tools.
Aber bei WLAN sieht man, in welchem Monus man verbunden ist zum Beispiel.
Ja, genau, man weiß endlich mal, was man eigentlich irgendwie tatsächlich für ein Netz hat. Aber es ist nicht ganz unwichtig, weil wenn du so einen ganzen Namen N und G hast, dann weißt du ja nicht.
Habt ihr eigentlich gewusst, dass wenn man dieses Airport-Menü geht und eher das Rädchen dreht, um herauszufinden, was für Stationen da sind und welche Qualität die haben, dass du in dem Augenblick kein Netz mehr hast?
Beim Scannen.
Das wird zumindest langsamer, oder?
Beim Scannen. Immer wenn ich das Rädchen drehe, das macht er ja alle paar Sekunden, hast du für die Zeit kein Netz. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt hier streams und das gerade offen hast, wird für diese Sekunden immer nichts geschickt.
Ist das aber nur, wenn ich dieses Fenster aufmache oder was?
Und das Rädchen updatet ist ja nicht andauernd, sondern das macht ja nur ab und zu mal Looking for New Networks.
Der kann nicht scannen und gleichzeitig seinen Kanal aufrechterhalten?
Ich weiß nicht, dass es bei Ice Tumbler immer so war, dass wenn man Ice Tumbler offen hat und Netzwerke suchen lässt, dass die Netzwerkverbindung, die offen ist, dramatisch langsamer wird. Wahrscheinlich probiert er dann immer so Mixed-Modus hinzukriegen, indem er einfach auf andere Fenster geht.
Du steh in deinen Rechner gerade rüber? Na dann mach mal hier Activity-Monitor auf, geh mal auf Netzwerk, dann siehst du, wie viel er gerade so rausschickt und dann klickst du da oben immer mal auf dein Netzwerk und dann müsstest du in dem Augenblick kurz wegbrechen. Das willst du jetzt natürlich nicht eigentlich.
Aber trotzdem.
Weiß nicht, ob man es schnell genug sehen kann, weil es ja ein bisschen träge der Activity-Monitor ist. Ja, das ist voll scheiße, ist das.
Na ja, ist ja ganz schön evil, war? Na ja, dann kannst du irgendwie auch auf deine Batterie drauf klicken und dann siehst du irgendwie, was Sache ist. Also ist alles irgendwie so ein bisschen auskunftsfreudiger geworden. Nur bei Time Machine gibt es nicht so richtig viele neue Informationen. Browse other Time Machine Disks gibt es dann noch da. Ach, was ist das denn? Ging bestimmt auch schon seit. Ich fange gar nicht erst an.
Ja, also bei Time Machine stand doch irgendwo da, dass sie sich halt voll den Arsch aufgerissen haben, um es mal schneller zu kriegen. Und sie haben den kompletten, wie sagt man, den kompletten Weg, den sozusagen deine Backup-Daten durch die Apis benutzen, haben sie durchoptimiert. Also sowohl, da du ja auch per Apple-File Sharing deine Backup-Daten wegschreibst, haben sie da optimiert. Also sie haben alles optimiert, was irgendwie mit Time Machine zu tun hat. Deswegen kommen diese 50 Prozent da wohl zusammen.
Ich hab auch so das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen schneller ist.
Ein bisschen. Flutscht ganz schön.
Über Netz oder über? Ich hab das Gefühl, es ist ein bisschen schlechter geworden, aber...
Mehr Daten vielleicht?
Ein bisschen besser geworden, aber es ist... Ja, es dauert immer noch alles sehr lange.
Klar, eine viele Daten.
Ja, und vor allem auch so dieses Abbrechen dauert lange und es ist immer unklar, wann er wieder aufnimmt und so. Also ich finde, sie könnten da noch ein bisschen auskunftsfreudiger sein, damit man irgendwie weiß, in welchem Zustand das alles ist.
Ja, ist aber auf jeden Fall schon reichlich besser als vorher.
Ja, ja. Was hab ich noch auf meiner Liste? Ich hab ein Problem mit dem Adressbuch, aber es hat eigentlich mit Snow Leopard... Ich weiß nicht, ob es was mit Snow Leopard zu tun hat. Ich glaub, ich hab das Problem seit Snow Leopard. Deswegen ist mir so ein bisschen unklar, was es ist.
Du benutzt ja dein Adressbuch nur im iPhone.
Du benutzt dein Adressbuch nur im iPhone? Und nicht auf dem Rechner? Aber du hast es sozusagen auch auf dem Rechner, weil das synkt?
Ja.
Hab ich auch, aber es synkt nicht mehr.
Ach.
Ich hab irgendwann festgestellt, dass Änderungen, die ich auf dem iPhone eintrage, nicht mehr zurückkommen und umgekehrt.
Hast du das irgendwie ausgeschaltet oder so?
Nö, nö. Hab alles richtig eingeschaltet, hab es auch tausendmal ein und ausgeschaltet und geguckt, was Sache ist. Ich hab auch schon, ersetze das Adressbuch das nächste Mal, wenn du verbunden bist. Und dann dauert es auch sehr lange, aber ersetzt es nicht. Es gibt keine Fehlermeldung, nix, gar nichts. Hab ich lange so im Nadel gestarrt und dann hab ich irgendwie mir mal die Konsole gestartet. Dein Freund und Helfer. Ich bin ja mal wieder erstaunt, was man alles über seinen Computer erfahren kann, wenn man mal die Konsole startet. Also Konsole, das Programm, mit dem man sich die Lockfall so schön anzeigen kann. Und tatsächlich gibt es auch einen Lockfall für Sync-Services. Und da habe ich jetzt wohl festgestellt, dass ich offensichtlich in meinem Adressbuch Zu viele Leute drin hast. Nee. Eine Inkonsistenz drin ist. Er bricht nämlich irgendwann ab. Also er schreibt nicht, dass er abbricht, aber er spuckt diese Fehlermeldung aus und dann geht er irgendwie zum Kalender-Synken über und lässt das Adressbuch halt einfach so wie es ist. Und es ändert sich halt nichts. Und er moniert eine Inkonsistenz, einen Verweis auf einen offensichtlich nicht existenten Rekord. Da hat er ja da so komische ID's drin, die man ja auch im Fallsystem findet. Und tatsächlich, da steht eine ID, die im Fallsystem so nicht da ist. Also Fallsystem sind davon in diesem Adressbuchordner, wo eben diese ganzen V-Cards abgespeichert sind. Und es bezieht sich auf diese merkwürdigen Distribution, E-Mail-Distribution-Lists. Das ist ein Feature, was keiner kennt und man könnte fast sagen, zu Recht, weil es funktioniert nicht. Eigentlich ist es eine tolle Sache, du kannst ja im Adressbuch Gruppen machen, Gruppen von Leuten. Das benutzen sicherlich eine Menge Leute, nicht jeder, aber einige. Jetzt ist es aber so, wenn du einen Kontakt hast mit mehreren E-Mail-Adressen und du möchtest dann halt eine Mail an alle Leute in einer Gruppe schicken, dann kannst du diese Gruppe aus dem Adressbuch ja in dein Mail-Programm reinziehen und dann sagst du irgendwie an alle. Dann triffst du aber natürlich, dann ist es immer vollkommen unklar, welche E-Mail-Adresse er nimmt, wenn da mehrere drinstehen und das ist natürlich beim Versenden einer E-Mail nicht ganz unwichtig, wohin du was schickst. Also gibt es in dem Adressbuch dieses Hidden Feature, dass du die Distribution List editieren kannst. Das ist im Menü vom Adressbuch, kannst du da reingehen und dann kriegst du so ein User-Interface, wo du eben auswählen kannst, welche der E-Mail-Adressen, die in deiner VK drin sind, verwendet werden im Kontext der jeweiligen Gruppe. Noch nie gesehen?
Ne, ich hab keine Gruppen.
Du hast keine Gruppen. Hier guckst du dir an, alle Podcast-Hörer schauen jetzt mal weg, du kriegst hier so ein Fensterchen, Distribution List und dann kannst du sozusagen für jeden Eintrag irgendwie anklicken, der wird dann bold, welche E-Mail-Adresse genommen werden soll. Du kannst ja auch irgendwie Change All Labels machen, kannst sagen, in dieser Gruppe alle, die home sind oder alle, die work sind und so, was natürlich auch alles nur so teilweise abgreift.
Wie wird die Gruppe auf dem iPhone angezeigt dann? Noch mal als eigener Eintrag?
Ne, die Gruppe bleibt ja dieselbe, ist ja keine neue Gruppe. Es ist nur so, dass du sagst...
Ne, also grundsätzlich, wie die angezeigt wird, die Gruppe.
Na, du hast die Gruppen dann da, kannst die Gruppen auswählen.
Kommt zusätzlich zu den normalen Namen, steht dann noch so ein Gruppenname und wenn man den klickt, dann...
Ne, du kannst ja so top-levelmäßig raus navigieren, also du kannst dann immer sagen, im Kontext welcher Gruppe du jetzt gerade rumbrausen willst. Kann ich dir auch zeigen, hier, man lernt ja nie aus, war an so einem Podcast.
Ich hab's noch oben gesehen.
Da oben stehen immer alle Kontakte, wenn du da irgendwie rumklickerst. Ich hab's jetzt gerade...
Das ist so ein bisschen wie im Kalender halt.
Und dann gehst du auf Gruppen, dann hast du die ganzen Gruppen und dann kannst du in die Gruppe reingehen und dann hast du halt nur noch die Leute. Das ist manchmal ganz praktisch.
Auf jeden Fall, weil irgendwann hat man nämlich so viele Leute und dann würde ich ein paar gerne aussortieren.
Ja, oder wenn du auch so eine Veranstaltung hast und du willst dann wirklich mal nur schnell mal die Personen, von der du gar nicht genau weißt, wie sie eigentlich heißt, finden. Und dann ist es einfach besser, wenn du so eine Gruppe hast, weil dann siehst du, wie alle die theoretisch jetzt in Frage kommen und dann hast du schnell die Personen gefunden. Weil wenn du nicht weißt, wie jemand heißt, findest du ihn auch nicht. Das ist immer das große Problem. Naja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Offensichtlich, ich hab das halt ein paar Mal benutzt, allerdings ohne Erfolg und jetzt auch noch mal der Hinweis, warum das eigentlich scheiße ist, es funktioniert nämlich nicht. Mail nimmt nicht die richtigen E-Mail-Adressen, beziehungsweise jetzt mit Snow Leopard ist es sogar so, du kannst sie irgendwie anklicken und sagst irgendwie okay und wenn du das nächste Mal wieder aufmachst, sonst noch mal editieren willst, dann werden die Änderungen einfach nicht übernommen. Mit anderen Worten...
Kann es aber vielleicht daran liegen, dass dein Adressbuch kaputt sein oder wenn du es reparierst?
Das kann jetzt daran liegen, ja bloß bitte. Erstens will ich sowas nicht und zweitens, wenn solche Fehler auftreten, dann soll er mir das sagen und wo ist bitte die Integritätsprüfung? Kann ich nicht hier einfach mal sagen, prüf mal, ob hier alles okay ist. Das ist eine Datenbank, die ja auch im Betriebssystem abgebildet wird. Das ist eine API, wo alle möglichen Programme drauf zugreifen können. Und ich hatte jetzt leider noch keine Zeit, das mal anzugehen, wie ich das Problem jetzt lösen kann. Ich könnte es vielleicht dadurch lösen, dass ich eben hier die alle nochmal neu einstelle, aber übernimmt es ja derzeit sowieso nicht. Deswegen, glaube ich, habe ich da keine Chance.
Du kannst doch auch wieder mal versuchen, auf dem Rechner einen Backup zu speichern. Man kann doch von dem Adressbuch einen Backup speichern.
Ja, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal hin und her geschaltet. Das erhält diese Inkonsistenz.
Ist also nicht so eine pfeilmäßige, sondern mehr so eine logische. Da kommt mit irgendeinem Inhalt nicht klar, ist ein Ü verwendet.
Er speichert einfach diese, ich nehme an, er speichert einfach diese Distribution-Lists und wenn da ich einmal auf eine E-Mail-Adresse verwiesen habe, die es danach nicht mehr gab.
Kommt da voll durcheinander.
So speichert aber diese Information immer weg und ich kann sie auch nicht raus elitieren oder sonst irgendwas und er zeigt mir auch nicht an, dass das irgendwie, es ist einfach braun und es hat auch vorher schon nie funktioniert. Also er hat auch dann, wenn er meine Änderungen angenommen hat im Adressbuch, in Mail einfach die falschen Mail-Adressen verwendet. Also er nimmt dann nicht die, die ich eingestellt habe für die Gruppe. Aber du kannst sie einstellen, aber kein Programm kümmert sich den Scheiß drum. Das ist einfach Dreck. Das ist wirklich, und das ist insofern auch, finde ich wirklich, wirklich oberdreck, weil ich meine, hallo, Serien-E-Mails, ja, so Serienbrief-Funktionalität. Im Jahre 2009, das muss so ein Computer einfach können. Das kann ja sogar Windows. Ja, Serienbrief, wir hatten die schon immer mit ihrem Word. Das war zwar jetzt nicht besonders schön, aber es gab diese Funktionalität und hier hast du das halt einfach nicht. So, ich werde es nochmal mit Bento testen oder so. Im schlimmsten Fall muss ich halt meine ganzen Gruppen wegschmeißen, meine Adressbucheinträge als V-Cards rauswerfen und wieder rein importieren und dann ist es wahrscheinlich konsistent, aber danach sind halt einfach meine ganzen Gruppeninformationen weg, was nicht so schön ist. So viel zum Thema Adressbuch, ich halte jetzt mal.
Ja, aber ich glaube dieses ganze Sinken zwischen den verschiedenen Geräten, das würde uns eh noch in den totalen Wahnsinn treiben. Also das ist ja wie oft ich mein Adressbuch aussortiere, weil irgendwer, und man weiß ja nicht mal mehr wer, da irgendwelche dämlichen Adressen drin ablegt, geht auch langsam auf keine Kuhhaut mehr. Ich hab entweder das Gefühl, dass Gmail da manchmal Adressen reinschmeißt oder Adium oder ich weiß es nicht. Also auf jeden Fall hab ich da... Das wird nochmal ein ganz großer Spaß, dass irgendwo auf diesem Planeten ein Backup abraucht und plötzlich auf allen Geräten unsere E-Mail-Adressen wegsendet.
Entschuldigung, ich krieg gerade hier einen Tipp im Chat, dass es eine Sync-Diagnostics abgibt.
Ja, die schickt dein Adressbuch an Apple.
Wie die fixen das denn von Hand mit Google Code?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich schau mal kurz, was das damit aussieht.
Wie heißt der? Ne, das war von Amazon, dieser Turk.
Oder so.
Mechanical Turk.
Ah, Sync-Diagnostics.
So, Tim ist jetzt erstmal für zwei Stunden beschäftigt.
Genau, da haltet jeder sich mal so.
Aber das war nicht mein Witz, ich hab den gerade ausgesucht.
Dann gib wenigstens mal ein Thema vor, du hast ja die Liste da am Start.
Chromium kann ich mal kurz zwischendurch erwähnen. Also es gibt ja... Nein, also es gibt diesen Google Chrome, dieser lustige Webbrowser.
Chromium war doch die Beta-Version, oder?
Also Chrome ist die Variante von Google, dann gibt's immer noch, also dann gibt's das ist sozusagen offizielle mit den bunten Alken und dann gibt's die Chromium-Variante, das ist die Open Source-Variante davon. Das heißt, davon gibt's so Nightly-Builds zum Beispiel und die macht mittlerweile auf Mac echt einen guten Eindruck. Das lohnt sich, den mal wieder runterzuladen. Also es ist ein Browser, mit dem man durchaus, ich hab mich jetzt in letzter Zeit durchaus dabei ertappt, dass ich den regelmäßig mal genutzt habe.
Aber was macht denn der besser? Ich mein, der nutzt doch auch WebKit.
Der nutzt auch WebKit, er ist schneller bei mir, deutlich schneller, vielleicht liegt es daran, weil er noch relativ frisches.
Ja, weil dein Safari scheint ja eh ne Marke zu haben.
Genau, mein Safari ist ja offensichtlich das toteste von allen. Ich weiß nicht, ich kenn niemanden bei dem Safari, der wirklich schnell ist, wenn man 10 oder 20 Tabs offen hat.
Okay, das ist aber halt auch wieder ein Pilot Error.
Was?
Ein Pilot Error. Ja, von dir halt, das ist halt so, wie du den benutzt. Da kann ja das Programm sein, dass das halt nicht so optimal kann, also dass es bei mir das auch nicht könnte, aber ich glaub, ich kenn echt keinen, der so viel Tabs offen hat wie du.
Dann wird's Zeit, dass sich die anderen endlich auch mal ein paar mehr Tabs öffnen. Ich weiß nicht, so mit diesem einen Tab. Also wofür hab ich denn Tabs, damit ich viele aufmache?
Ich hab doch nicht Tabs, damit sie mir den Bildschirm vollknallen.
Gut, Chrome ist auf jeden Fall, da scheint mir das wesentlich. Da ist auch so viel Tabs offen, oder?
Ich hab mal proben, wahrscheinlich, weil der nur den so kurz benutzt, da kannst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel offen haben. Kannst du also gar nicht vergleichen.
Wieso nach dem? Der macht jetzt zum Beispiel nach dem Starten, nach dem Neustart, wenn ich ihn beendet habe, macht er alle Tabs wieder auf, zum Beispiel. Das ist ja so ein Feature, was Safari auch nicht hat. Er sieht ein bisschen aufgeräumter aus als Safari. Ich find die Tabs besser gelöst. Das ist die Lösung, an der Apple verzweifelt ist. Es gibt Erweiterungen, Extensions. Die funktionieren noch nicht alle, die unter Windows funktionieren, funktionieren auch nicht alle auf dem Mac, aber wenn man in irgendeinem anderen Tab einen YouTube-Player offen hat, gibt es eine Erweiterung, mit der man den anderen YouTube-Player pausieren lassen kann. Für Gmail-Inbox und so was alles. Das ist mittlerweile ein richtig schöner, brauchbarer Browser geworden und jeder Tab hat seinen eigenen Prozess. Wenn irgendjemand dir einen Tab abraucht, raucht nur der eine Tab ab. Auch im 32-Bit-Modus ist Flash ein eigener Prozess. Das heißt, wenn ihr einen Scheiß-Flash-Player braucht, dann ist dir bloß dein eigener Plug-in abgestürzt. Was noch nicht geht, sind so Sachen wie Quicktime. Aber es wird immer mehr. Es lohnt sich, den hier mal runterzuladen. Ja, ich weiß auch, dass wenn ich in Safari erst mal dreieinhalbtausend Menüs drum klicke und sage, letzte Sitzung wieder herstellen, dass man mehr oder weniger das wieder herstellt. Aber Leute, wir leben im 21. Jahrhundert, so was kann auch gerne mal automatisch gehen, dass die Fenster und Taps der letzten Sitzung wieder geöffnet werden. Ich möchte auch per Apfel-Z ein versehentlich geschlossen Tapp wieder öffnen können.
Das geht bei Safari.
Was geht bei Safari mittlerweile?
Nicht mit Apfel-Z, aber es gibt ein öffnet das zuletzt geschlossene Fenster. Das hat mir schon ein paar Mal den Arsch gerettet.
Aber nicht per Kürzel.
So was kannst du wahrscheinlich wieder über dieses komische Keyboard-Teiler machen.
Also die Erweiterung Glimpse, die kriegt das hin, wie kann man per Apfel-Z Fenster wieder aufmachen.
So, wir schalten jetzt wieder live rüber zu Tim. Und wie sieht es aus an der Front mit irgendwie Adressbruchreferieren?
Was sagt der Ted?
Der Ted sagt, dass irgendwie das Ding nur dazu da ist, Probleme zu analysieren, danach ein TAR-File an Apple zu schicken, per E-Mail. Ohne weitere Kommentare.
Habe ich es nicht gesagt? Er schickt die Daten zu Apple.
Ja, Scheiß, ihr kriegt das nicht.
Ja, muss aber vor der Hand ran, ist doch bestimmt in SQlite 3 abgespeichert, oder?
Vor drei Tagen haben sie mir gesagt, Ihr Mobile-Me-Account ist jetzt abgelaufen. Und ich fragte mich, do I care?
Lie benutzt?
Doch, es gibt genau ein einziges Feature bei Mobile-Me, was ich irgendwie interessant finde und dafür war es mir das Geld irgendwie nie wert. Und das ist dieses Find-My-iPhone. Das können Sie meiner Meinung nach einfach zum Preis des iPhones einfach kostenlos beilegen.
Ja, das ist auch eine Schweinerei.
Und dieses Mobile-Me hat mich einfach nie überzeugt. Also so sehr ich die Idee von benutzbaren, hübsch aussehenden Services usw., dieses Mobile-Me bietet mir einfach nichts, was ich in meinem Leben wirklich brauche. Und alles, was ich wirklich brauche, finde ich bei Google. Ja, also sowas wie Google Docs, das ist etwas, was mir weiterhilft. Und wo ist irgendwie iWork für Internet? Irgendwie doesn't happen. Ja, du hast da so eine Funktionalität, wo du ein Dokument im Internet veröffentlichen kannst. Read Only und so ein Kram.
Man kann Anmerkungen machen.
Ja, aber das ist einfach immer alles too little, too late. Also wenn Sie mit diesem Feature Set vor fünf Jahren angekommen wären, dann wäre das ja irgendwie der große Wurf gewesen. Aber irgendwie passt das alles nicht. Und ich hab dann damit auch immer noch im Detail zu viel Ärger. Sag ich jetzt gar nicht mal wegen dieser Downtime, die Sie da gehabt haben. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt hab ich das überhaupt nicht nennenswert benutzt. Aber es ist alles immer irgendwie so... Pfff, weiß ich auch nicht.
Dann will ich mein ganzes Zeug nicht an die Auslagern.
Ja gut, ich mein, das ist ein generelles Problem.
Wenn man es nicht will, darf man es nicht nutzen. Das ist bei jedem so. Das ist auch bei Google so.
Ja, aber dann machen sie so Features rein wie mit Find My Phone. Das wäre halt schon cool, aber nur dafür...
Ach so, ja. Ja, oder sie können ja auch sagen, es ist alles verschlüsselt mit diesem Passwort. Aber Sync-Services und so...
Oder Sync-Services über WLAN auch nur mit Mobile Mi gehen, das ist auch blöd. Warum kann man ein Telefon nicht so über WLAN sinken?
Ich find's auch irgendwie zu teuer.
Ja, und das geht bei Google, das wird lau.
Ja.
Ich find's auch irgendwie zu teuer. Aber wo wir gerade dabei sind, bei Google, was ich das erste Mal ausprobiert habe, ist... Wie heißt es?
Google Apps.
Wisst ihr, wovon ich rede?
Ach, das ist dieses, das quasi Google auf der eigenen Domain läuft.
Genau.
Ja, davon bist du ja totaler Fan jetzt, hab ich mitbekommen.
Das ist ein bisschen übertrieben, diese Darstellung. Ich kenne bloß überhaupt keinen anderen Dienst. Also ich bin eh immer ein bisschen frustriert davon, wie wenig einem eigentlich so Internet-Service-Provider so anbieten. Diese User-Interfaces, die du dort bekommst, die sind einfach mal Gürlerotz. Und allein, um einfach mal, ich verwalte meine Domain, zu bekommen, ist das immer ein riesiger Aufriss. Und du hast da wirklich ein Web-01-User-Interface-Standard am Start, das sich einem die Zehennägel hochrollt. Ich meine, vielleicht habt ihr da draußen irgendwie bessere Erfahrungen mit irgendwas, aber zuletzt musste ich irgendwie auf so einen User-Interface von der Firma Hetzner blicken. Und ich dachte, ich werd nicht wieder. So ein Müll, so eine Vergewaltigung optischer Natur, das geht gar nicht.
Was genau hast du damit gemacht, was ich fragen darf?
Ich hab damit nichts gemacht, weil es war nicht möglich, damit etwas zu machen.
Wofür war denn das User-Interface? Also ich kann von Hetzner nur dieses DNS-Record bearbeiten.
Und damit kannst du leben?
Ich meinte das jetzt nicht so oft.
Es war mir einfach sofort unklar, was man damit überhaupt tun kann. Also diese Verkettung von Domain und was das jetzt bedeutet. Ich hab mich nicht lange damit aufgehalten, es war einfach unklar. Ich wollte auch über Google Apps reden. Was ich bei Google Apps mag, ist einfach dieses Ding mit ja, ich hab ein Domain und du machst jetzt mal die Mail dafür. Immer dieses Problem, wenn du heute mit deinem eigenen Domain irgendwas machen willst, bist du dann entweder an deinen Provider gebunden. Dann ist bei jedem Provider ein anderes Feature Set. Bei Google kannst du das einfach unabhängig davon machen. Kannst einfach sagen, hier, ich hab dieses Domain, ich hab Zugriff auf DNS. Zack! Wär schön, wenn die auch gleich den DNS-Server dazu machen würden. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das geht. Ich glaube, es geht dann, wenn du bei Google auch noch Domains kaufst. Naja, dann hast du halt auch gleich so ein Tool und kannst dann Accounts anlegen für deinen User. Dann haben die halt auch gleich Gmail. Du hast dann irgendwie gleich hier den Kalender. Also Google Docs sozusagen auch noch mit drin in deinem Dings. Und kannst irgendwie gleich sagen, dieser Kalender soll an dir und die Leute freigegeben werden. Das lässt auch noch eine Menge zu wünschen übrig. Aber es funktioniert erstmal ganz gut. Du musst nichts anderes machen, als in deinem Domain die MX-Records entsprechend zu ändern und auf Google zeigen zu lassen. Und dann kannst du einfach deine Mail darüber abreißen. Und dann bist du irgendwie add-tralala. Also jetzt hier kann man sagen, mobilemax.de läuft jetzt so zum Beispiel da drüber. Da muss man sich erstmal irgendwie keine Gedanken machen. Muss man sich keine Gedanken machen, ob man in seiner näheren Freundeskreisumgebung noch fähige Mail-Administratoren hat. Was ist jetzt schon so?
Dass mobilemax.de über Google läuft.
Ja, die mails.
Also nicht nur zum Beispiel, sondern es ist wirklich so.
Ja, ich hab den Amix auf Tims Wunsch hin, den Amix-Rekord entsprechend abgeändert. Das läuft jetzt auch.
Da machen wir halt nicht viel, aber es ist halt einfach so. Find mal einen Dienst, der unproblematisch ist, der sich unproblematisch einrichten lässt. Da gibt es irgendwie nichts. Ja, ja, unsere eingeschlafene Sendung hier. Was ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich? Wollen wir noch irgendwas zum Snow Leopard sagen? Ich meine, wir kommen jetzt schon so ein bisschen ab vom Thema.
Na ja, wir haben immer noch das mit den Blogs und Grand Central Dispatch.
Genau, erklärt mal, was Blogs sind.
Ja, eigentlich müssen wir mal darüber reden, was wirklich toll ist.
Das, was mich überzeugt ist und das auch, warum ich glaube, warum zum Beispiel die Mail-App ist ja verdammt schnell geworden. Und die meinten ja, dass Mail-App schon irgendwie ordentlich mit Grand Central programmiert wurde. Aber reichlich.
Stimmt eigentlich.
Also es ist einfach nur ratzfatz. Und wenn sie einen auch nur bescheißen, wird er die Endes Animations irgendwie die Zeiten gekürzt haben. Das machen die ja auch ganz gerne. So wie früher mit den jumpenden Icons, dass einfach die Sprungzeiten verschnellert haben, damit man irgendwie gefühlt hat, es geht schneller. Ja, irgendwie so. Aber ich finde, Mail-App flutscht einfach.
Welche Animationen haben sie beschleunigt?
In einem Doc irgendwie, wie oft so ein Programm springt. Oder sie haben es seltener gemacht, weil die Leute an den Springen haben sie mitgezählt, wie lange so ein Programm braucht.
Ich kann mich noch immer an das Steve Jobs sogar irgendwann mal richtig damit angegeben haben, wie selten das jetzt plötzlich springt und dass sie es wirklich nur an diesen Sprüngen gezählt haben.
Na, eigentlich sollte, also auf dem Desktop sollte, also so ein Programm wie Terminal springt gar nicht mehr sofort offen. Also der kommt gar nicht mehr zum Handeln.
Ja, damals als das noch nicht so war.
Kommt auf den Rechner an.
Jedenfalls Grand Central Dispatch. Also ich weiß nicht, ob wir Blocks erklären wollen. Wollen wir was erklären?
Ich finde das, genau. Wir haben ja jemanden, der sich das noch nicht durchgelesen hat.
Ich weiß nicht, was Blocks sind.
Also.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es so gut drüber krieg, das zu erklären.
Ich kann ja mal anfangen. Apple hat sich was getraut und wir haben ja schon ein paar Mal hier geredet, über so Infrastrukturen wie zum Beispiel LLVM. Du musst jetzt auch interessiert gucken.
Genau.
Nicht in deinen Rechner, sondern so. Ja, ich kenne multitas gegen Fisch.
Ja, endlich muss ich mal nicht alles erklären.
Jetzt bin ich schon wieder aus dem Konzept.
Blocks.
Ja, ja. Ich wollte ein bisschen weiter ausholen.
Ach so.
Mhm, das war diese, oh je, das Dynamisch Übersetzen in eine Binärsprache nur. Und das wird dann zur Laufzeit übersetzt.
Also kurz gesagt, LLVM ist halt dieses Projekt, was diesen Chris Lettner zu Apple gebracht hat. Und der ist mittlerweile der Head of Compiler Chain bei Apple. Das heißt, der Typ, der quasi definiert, wie Programm übersetzt wird und wie Programme laufen auf diesem OS. Und zwar konkret, also was für Code wird da generiert, was für Code wird exekutiert, wie sind die Runtimes, welche Compiler übersetzten die Programme bei Xcode und so weiter. Das ist sozusagen seine Welt. Und er hat dieses LLVM-Projekt gestartet.
Dieses C lang, das ist übrigens jetzt bei Xcode schon, die sagen, es wäre production ready.
Sie verwenden es jetzt.
Also man kann es jetzt als Anwender von Xcode...
Ich wollte das gerade alles ein bisschen herleiten. Also dieses LLVM-Projekt ist sozusagen, das könnt ihr hier auch bei Mobamex ein bisschen zurückspulen, habe ich irgendwie schon ein paar Mal predicted, wird über kurz oder lang diesen GCC ablösen. Der halt derzeit noch irgendwie da ist, aber im Rahmen des LLVM-Projektes, was ja erstmal eine Compiler-Architektur ist, mit der du sozusagen Compiler bauen kannst, wird ja jetzt auch ein Compiler gebaut, nämlich der C-Lang-Compiler, der quasi ein direktes Replacement für den GCC ist. Und der ist jetzt so ein bisschen in den Endspurt eingetaucht.
Die sagen, es ist production ready.
Aber nicht für C++, oder?
Nee, gibt's hier noch nicht. Bei C++ schalten sie immer noch auf dem LLVM-GCC um.
Genau.
Aber für Objective-C und normales C ist der schon benutzbar.
Genau, das heißt, sie kommen einfach mit diesem Compiler weiter. Und dieser Compiler stellt eben in vielerlei Hinsicht einen Fortschritt dar. Er ist schneller, er erzeugt besseren Code, er erzeugt viel besserer debuggbaren Code. Also das Debugging von Fehlern in C wird viel, viel, viel einfacher mit C lang.
Bessere Fehlermeldungen.
Viel bessere Fehlermeldungen. Du kannst einfach sehr viel besser erkennen, was eigentlich falsch ist in deinem Programm.
Und verbraucht viel weniger Speicher.
Und ist schnell, und ist C immer so schnell im Übersetzen. Und macht schneller einen Code und überhaupt wäscht ab. Und vertröstet deine Freundin, wenn du zu spät kommst. Also das ist alles.
Das ist auch nicht schwer, weil GCC ist uralt. Und C lang ist voll modern, neu programmiert. Gleich mit Strading schon im Hinterkopf irgendwie. Also es ist eigentlich auch kein Wunder, dass es war nicht schwer, wenn man was neu schreibt, besser zu sein als GCC.
Genau, und es war auch absehbar, dass Apple das verwenden wird. Und es war auch absehbar, weil ja auch die Lizensierungsgeschichte da komplett neu aufgerollt wird. Weil GCC ist halt GPL mit den ganzen Problemen, die das mit sich bringt. Du kannst halt nicht proprietär in Code damit vernetzen. Das heißt, es ist nicht möglich, den Compiler in dein Development Environment einzubauen, es sei denn, es ist auch GPL. Wegen der Freiheit.
Also du musst den als Kommandoscheinprogramm weiterlaufen lassen.
Genau, das ist dann alles separiert. Und dann hast du es halt dann mit entsprechenden Schnittstellen zu tun und so weiter. Eine Integration ist anders. Und ich vermute einfach mal, dass zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo C lang zu 100 Prozent übernommen wird von Apple in Xcode, dann fliegt der GCC einfach raus. Oder es gibt noch irgendeinen Kompatibilitätsmodus.
Man kann ja auswählen in Xcode, welcher Compiler benutzt werden soll. Und dann kann man einfach hin und her schalten. Und dann kann man den GCC noch da irgendwie als 4-2er liegen lassen.
Ja gut, aber was ich ja sage ist, meiner Vermutung nach werden sie eben auch diese ganze Fehlermeldungsgeschichte. Es wird einfach dazu führen, dass sie Xcode noch sehr viel mehr verheiraten mit diesem Compiler.
Auf jeden Fall.
Genau, was sie einfach mit GCC nicht machen können. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo sie da voranschreiten, aber trotzdem noch das GCC-Backend am Leben erhalten müssen, wirst du dann wahrscheinlich weniger Features haben, wenn du sagst, ich muss aber jetzt hier GCC benutzen. Aber im Prinzip arbeiten sie in dem ganzen LLVM-Projekt und C-Lang-Projekt schon darauf hin, GCC komplett obsolet zu machen. Das heißt, sie wollen komplett Source Code-kompatibel sein und das eben auch für C++ und das will so einiges bedeuten.
GCC ist nicht umsonst so extrem alt, wahrscheinlich weil sie sich schlicht und ergreifend seitdem nie jemand dran getraut hat.
Genau, C-Compiler ist einfach so, naja gut, es gibt den Intel C-Compiler, der hat auch so seine Stärken, der ist auch schnell und Leute sagen auch, der kann es irgendwie mit dem C-Lang aufnehmen, das kann ich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht bewerten.
Na, der ist halt besser optimiert von den Intel-Jungs. Aber GCC kann ja schon noch ein bisschen mehr als nur für Intel compilen, die können ja echt eine Menge.
Genau, also das ist einfach so ein offenes Feld, aber es stimmt schon, viele C-Compiler gibt es nicht, aber es hat eben auch einfach was damit zu tun, dass die ganze Welt sich irgendwie auf GCC eingeschossen hat und das ist keine Infrastruktur, die den von heute auf morgen mal ersetzt. Da brauchst du eben schon einen, wie man so schön sagt, bold move. So, und ich war ja im Unwissenen darüber, was jetzt eigentlich bei Snow Leopard kommt. Und diese Ankündigung, dass sie Multicore-Optimierungen machen wollen mit diesem Grand Central Dispatch, das wissen wir jetzt seit wann? Seit sie irgendwann angekündigt haben, dass Snow Leopard kommt und dass es keine Features hat, außer eben die Features, über die wir jetzt gerade sind.
Schon seit einem Jahr bekannt, oder?
Genau, also es war irgendwie klar, dass sie da so einen Framework schaffen werden und so weiter. Aber was mir nicht klar war, ist, wie sie das denn eigentlich tun. So, und jetzt kommen wir zu der Sache mit den Blogs. Was sie nämlich gemacht haben, ist, sie haben C erweitert.
Objective C ist ja nur in ihrer eigenen Sprache. Das können sie erweitern, wie sie wollen.
Nein, sie haben Objective C nicht erweitert. Sie haben C erweitert. Und Objective C schließt C vollständig ein. Und damit ist halt auch Objective C erweitert. Es ist nicht so, dass sie da was Neues...
Blogs sind aber schon Objekte.
Es gibt Blogs auch in Objective C als Definition?
Nein, Blog ist ein Objekt. Du kannst ihn releasen, wenn du willst.
Aha, okay, verstehe.
Was aber dir nicht so widerspricht, weil ja eigentlich Objective C auch alles über C gelöst ist. Also Objective C ist ja unten drunter alles mit C gemacht.
Ja, okay, aber es gibt eine Absanktion dafür sozusagen. Okay, gut, das wusste ich nicht. Anyway, Max, ja, du schaust noch nicht über rasch genug.
Wir haben ja auch noch nicht erklärt, was Bloggen sind.
Ja, aber was sie jetzt sozusagen gemacht haben, ist um überhaupt Grand Central Dispatch überhaupt zu ermöglichen.
Das stimmt aber auch nicht ganz.
Wieso?
Weil Grand Central Dispatch eigentlich keine Blogge braucht.
Ist das so?
Ich dachte, das ganze API basiert darauf, dass es Blogs gibt.
Nee.
Hab ich das nicht so gelesen?
Weiß ich nicht, was du gelesen hast. Das gibt's extra in der Artikel, wo jemand noch mehr erklärt, dass Blogs nicht Grand Central Dispatch sind und Grand Central Dispatch auch nicht Blogs sind. Das sind wirklich zwei unterschiedliche Sachen. Du kannst Blogs prima benutzen, um bei Grand Central Jobs auszulösen usw. Aber Grand Central Dispatch geht auch ganz prima ohne Blogs.
Okay, also die ganzen Cues und Threads gehen auch ohne. Das heißt, es kommt noch dazu.
Das alte Leopard NS-Operation. Damit konnte man ja schon Jobs auf den Cue legen und abarbeiten lassen. Das haben sie jetzt irgendwie umgecodet, sodass dieses NS-Operation jetzt Grand Central Dispatch benutzt. Müssen wir jetzt auch wieder erst mal erklären, was Grand Central Dispatch ist.
Das ist diese Verteilungsebene, die...
Ja, dass es ein Programm irgendwie 1000 kleine Jobs hat. Dann hättest du es früher gemacht, hättest 1000 Threads gestartet und hättest dich kümmern müssen, dass du die aufbaust, den Jobs gibst, die wieder abbaust oder wie auch immer. Also du bist die ganze Zeit nur mit Thread-Handling beschäftigt. Und das will ein Programmierer nicht. Vor allem müsstest du als Programmierer erst mal gucken, wie viele CPUs hat er in die Kiste und ist vielleicht schon ein anderes Programm dabei, die CPUs zu benutzen. Und wie viel Rechenpower kann ich denn eigentlich kriegen? Und wie viele Threads würden denn Sinn machen unter dieser aktuellen Belastung auf dieser aktuellen Maschine?
Was läuft denn sonst noch so?
Und das macht jetzt alles Grand Central Dispatch. Die halten irgendwie Threads und wenn du denen Jobs gibst, dann sind die Threads schon da, die legen gleich los und wenn du fertig bist, kriegst du wieder. Und das Grand Central Dispatch kümmert sich, wie viele Threads dein Programm kriegt und wie viele Threads andere Programme kriegen und so weiter. Und das läuft alles ein bisschen organisierter. Und Apple hat da wohl irgendwie sich zu Tode optimiert und die schreiben immer irgendwas, um so einen Call zu starten. Bei Grand Central Dispatch bräuchten sie 15 Instruktionen, damit irgendwie der Job da losrennt. Also es ist ein relativ kurzer Weg, um so einen Thread irgendwie in Schwung zu bringen. Und deswegen lohnt sich das wohl.
Okay, also sie wollen richtig viel Threads in Zukunft haben.
Aber eben auch nicht mehr als nötig, weil eben auch ein Thread zu viel Genau, kostet nur Speicher und Zeug. kann einfach schon, wenn der sozusagen nicht abgearbeitet werden kann, weil einfach kein Chor da ist, dann ist der ballast und muss geswitcht werden und kostet dann unter Umständen wieder Zeit und Speicher. Und das ist das eine Geheimnis von diesem Grand Central Dispatch, dass du einfach ein Subsystem hast, was für das gesamte System quasi für alle Prozesse, die gerade laufen, immer wieder entscheidet, wie viele Ressourcen brauchen wir denn jetzt eigentlich und wem teile ich sie jetzt gerade zu. Dass du aber als Anwendungsprogrammierer das eben sehr einfach benutzen kannst und weder irgendwas darüber wissen musst, was da für eine CPU ist, wie viel Chor sie gerade hat, nicht selber nachschauen musst, was sonst gerade noch diese Dienste in Ansprüche nimmt, sondern dass dir dieses Subsystem einfach das komplett abnimmt. Und das bedeutet aber auch, dass es eben auf sehr niedriger Ebene implementiert sein muss. Und das ist etwas, was eben auch umfangreich im Kern unterstützt wird. Es gibt ja diese Library dazu, gibt es mittlerweile Open Source. Und das kannst du halt auch auf anderen Betriebssystemen verwenden, selbst wenn du da keinen expliziten Kernessupport drin hast.
Aber du kannst das noch weiter...
Damit es halt irgendwie portierbar ist.
Genau, aber du kannst es halt noch weiter optimieren. So, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen durcheinander, was den Zusammenhang zwischen Grand Central und den Blogs betrifft. Aber vielleicht beschreiben wir erstmal die Blogs an sich.
Es gibt schon Methoden bei Grand Central, oder das ist ja C-Zeugs, also R-Funktionen, denen halt man einen Blog und die Arbeit davon halt übergeben kann. Aber nicht unbedingt alle, also es geht auch ohne.
Okay, aber vielleicht wollen wir erstmal Blogs erklären. C ist ja eine relativ dumme Sprache. Und es gibt so ein paar Sachen in höheren Sprachen, die irgendwie da selbstverständlich sind seit Ewigkeiten. Denn eine dieser Sachen ist irgendwie anonyme Funktion. Funktionen kennen wir ja alle. Und üblicherweise hat die halt einen Namen und dann ruft man sie irgendwie auf und dann wird sie durchgeführt und dann returnt sie wieder und so weiter und dann hat sie halt irgendwas getan.
Das gibt es ja in jeder Sprache.
In Sprachen wie Lisp, in vielen anderen Sprachen, gibt es aber auch eben das Konzept... Ruby und JavaScript. Für JavaScript gilt das. Bei Ruby weiß ich es jetzt gerade nicht.
Bei Ruby gibt es das mit dieser Shield-Funktion.
Wie auch immer. Die Kernidee ist einfach, dass Funktionen Objekte sind wie alle anderen auch. Dass du einfach eine Funktion benutzen kannst und auch als Parameter zum Beispiel übergeben kannst wie ein Integer oder ein String.
Bei Ruby ist es doch Clojures, oder?
Clojures ist das, was man damit dann implementieren kann. Dass man sozusagen anonyme Funktionen übergibt und dass die dann in anderen Funktionen weitergereicht werden. So der Klassiker ist sowas wie die Sortierfunktion für einen Sortieralgorithmus, die du sozusagen mitreißt. Also der Comparator, der dann sozusagen beim Durchlauf des Sortierens immer wieder aktiviert wird. Und der dann eben innerhalb der aufgerufenen Funktion dort wird sozusagen diese Funktion ausgepackt und zu dem Zeitpunkt einfach aktiviert und an der Stelle ausgeführt, wo du sie brauchst.
Also um das jetzt mal ein bisschen plastisch zu sagen, wenn man zum Beispiel so ein Array sortiert, hat man normalerweise einen relativen Wegel, weil man muss halt Sortieralgorithmus implementieren und so was. Und am besten noch einen neuen Array anlegen, die Daten hin und her schieben. Dann gibt es verschiedene Algorithmen, die für unterschiedliche Fälle am besten oder am langsamsten funktionieren. Und bei dem ist das einfach so, dass JavaScript hat eine Sortierfunktion drinnen. Und wie PHP auch, aber PHP kann zum Beispiel nur ganz dämlich nach A bis Z sortieren. Und bei JavaScript und bei sehr vielen anderen Sprachen auch, übergibt man dieser Sortierfunktion eine weitere Funktion, in der man nichts weiter sagt als vergleichen. Gib mir zwei Dinge, was von denen ist jetzt kleiner und was ist größer und davon hängt es ab, wie das sortiert ist.
Genau, das ist halt keine Funktion, die einen Namen hat, deren Adresse du übergibst oder so, so Pointer, sondern du übergibst die Funktion als solche. Genau. Die reichst du einfach weiter. So und diese anonymen Funktionen sind eine sehr kräftige Abstraktion, mit der du viele Dinge cool lösen kannst.
Theory basiert komplett auf anonymen Funktionen.
Genau, sowas. Und C kennt dieses Konzept nicht.
Außer eben über irgendwelche Pointer-Späße.
Die aber nicht das gleiche sind, weil es ja kein Typ ist. Es ist nicht wirklich etwas, was du speichern kannst in einer Variablen, was du zuweisen kannst und was du als Parameter übergeben kannst. Du kannst nur Adressen von Speicher übergeben und so weiter. Aber da sind viele Probleme nicht.
Man läuft ständig gefahren mal versehentlich mit zu Rechner.
Und was hat Apple jetzt gemacht? Sie haben das einfach mal eingebaut. In C. In die Sprache, die irgendwie seit 1970 das Weltgeschehen definiert, traut sich Apple einfach ein komplett neues Sprach-Feature einzubauen. Einfach mit der Argumentation, die Welt braucht das.
Warum habe ich den Schrei der C-Puristen nicht gehört?
Weil es von Apple kommt.
Der ein Welt daraufhin zusammengebrochen ist.
Ach so, den Schrei, den hat man gehört. Da regen sie natürlich alle auf, dass irgendwie hier Kaugummi, Eyecandy-Firma Apple herkommt und irgendwie an so Profisachen zählt.
Wer seid ihr denn?
Irgendwas bilden die sich ein und so.
Ich kann dir sagen, sie werden lange daran rumknispeln und am Ende werden sie feststellen, dass es ja an sich ein ganz cooler Move war. Bloß sowas kann sich halt wirklich nur jemand trauen, der das von A bis Z auch wirklich durchsetzt, insbesondere in die Compiler einbaut. Und an der Stelle kommt halt wieder dieses LLVM-Projekt mit rein. Natürlich ist das alles in diesem LLVM, also in den C lang mit drin. Und sie haben es aber auch, glaube ich, in den GCC eingebaut. Das heißt, sie haben sich die Mühe gemacht, das dort auch noch mit reinzuliefern. Das heißt, es gibt den Source Code dafür und du kannst den halt irgendwie Open Source da einbauen und deinen GCC so übersetzen, dass er eben auch Blog-Support hat. So, und was passiert? Man wacht morgens irgendwie auf, es ist Montag und auf einmal kann C etwas, was es noch nie konnte, nämlich anonyme Funktionen. Die Möglichkeit, einfach in einer Funktion, eine komplette Funktion mit weiterzureichen und es gibt einen entsprechenden neuen Datentyp, der eben das kann. Und das sind eben Blogs, Blog of Code. Und damit baut Apple, so und jetzt bin ich wieder an diesem Punkt, wo ich ein bisschen verwirrt bin, weil ich eben dachte, dass es mit diesem Lipdispatch enger zusammenhängt, die Möglichkeit, Asynchronizität durchzuführen. Du hast halt die Möglichkeit, einfach zu sagen, hier ist ein Stück Code und den führ doch mal aus, wenn Zeit ist. Stehst du, was ich meine?
Ich öffne mal mein Beispiel.
Du definierst halt einfach diesen Block of Code, übergibst den einfach als Parameter und sagst, das ist das, was du tun sollst, wenn es an der Zeit ist, das zu tun. Wenn nämlich der entsprechende Multicore-Prozessor irgendwie genug Kapazität hat, beziehungsweise wenn eine andere Tätigkeit, die ich auch asynchron vorher da schon mal reingestopft habe, die davon abhängt, durchgeführt worden ist. Das kommt dann sozusagen in die gleiche Queue. Und schon kannst du wieder weitermachen und mit User-Interface und mit deinem User reden. Das heißt, du siehst es im Finder. Der Finder, das wird dir auch schon aufgefallen sein, war vorher einfach eine blockige, kantige, eklige Zicke. Du hast da irgendwas getan. Ich hab hier ein Fenster aufgemacht und dieses, was ich vorhin erzählt habe hier mit alt cursor rechts, um so ein Ordner aufzumachen. Das habe ich einfach mal mit so einem Ordner gemacht, wo so 30.000 Dateien drin waren. Das ist unter Leopard und allen US und davor, ist das einfach der nahe Tod. Den Finder kannst du immer gleich abschießen bei solchen Sachen. Da blockiert einfach alles nur noch und es gibt Gummiballen und Beachball und volles Programm.
Aber ich dachte, das wäre...
Der Snow Leopard Finder bleibt vollständig responsive. Da rattern immer mehr Dateien in diese Liste rein und während er das tut, kannst du da hoch und runter scrollen ohne nennenswerte Verzögerung.
Aber ich dachte, das wäre im Wesentlichen auch ein Vorteil von Coco, weil ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, ich glaube es ist mittlerweile nicht mehr so, aber ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass man Carbon-Apps und Coco-Apps...
Coco allein bringt dir aber keine Nebenläufigkeit.
Also dass man Carbon-Apps und Coco-Apps daran unterscheiden konnte, dass wenn man in Carbon-Apps ein Fenster gezogen hat, das Programm ansonsten stehen geblieben ist, wohingegen Coco-Apps, dieses berühmte Ding Quicktime Player, läuft dann weiter und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, das ist, weil dir schon das Framework sozusagen gar nicht erlaubt hat, irgendwas zu paralysieren. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass jeder dann in seinem Coco-Programm das auch gleich so programmiert hat, dass es paralysiert ist.
Okay, das wird jetzt einfach quasi massiv vereinfacht.
Und im Final müssen sie das einfach gnadenlos eingebaut haben. Ich kann mir das nicht anders erklären. Und was du über Mail-Apps sagst, sprich das... Das Prinzip ist immer, der User löst irgendetwas aus, zeige mir Inhalt von an. So, Folder oder entsprechend bei Mail eben dann diese Mail-Folder. Und wir wissen alle, da hängt ein Ratten-Schwanz an Aktivität drin, Netzwerk, Geschichten und so weiter. Trotzdem möchtest du so schnell wie möglich wieder responsive werden für den User. Du musst aber in dem Main-Thread quasi sein, um mit dem User zu interagieren. Und auf irgendwie Mausklicks und irgendwie Abbrechen-Tasten und so weiter zu reagieren. Trotzdem möchtest du aber im Hintergrund Dinge tun, die unter Umständen sehr lange dauern, beziehungsweise wo immer wieder dieses Problem ist, dass du erstmal auf irgendwas warten musst. Pfeilzugriff, Festplatten müssen verfügbar sein, da laufen die Spindeln erstmal an, Netzwerkzugriff. Kann halt alles sehr lange dauern. Und dann machst du es entweder gnadenlos, dass du für jeden Kack, der irgendwie auch nur im Ansatz eine Zehntelsekunde oder länger dauern kann, einen eigenen Thread aufmachst, asynchronisierst das Ganze, machst dann Interprozess-Kommunikation zwischen den ganzen Threads, damit die sich irgendwie koordinieren, hoffst du, dass der ganze Brei auch funktioniert und dann hast du eben für diesen einen von zehn Fällen, wo es wirklich länger dauert, als der User es gerne möchte, hast du das dann eben so weit parallelisiert, dass es keinen Beachball wirft. Lohnt sich nicht, deswegen machen sie es dann viele Leute nicht und dann gibt es halt Beachball und manchmal, wenn diese eine Sache, von der das abhängt, aus irgendwelchen Gründen ein Kabel gezogen oder sonst irgendein Rechner ausgefallen, wo es dann ganz lange dauert mit Timeouts, dann sitzt du halt 30 Sekunden und schaust die ganze Zeit auf den Beachball und Apple ist schuld. Was sie aber jetzt gemacht haben mit diesen Blogs ist, dass du einfach sagen kannst, hier, ich hab das ganze Problem jetzt mal in 10 Teilaufgaben aufgeteilt, ich kann auch durch das Stecken in verschiedene Cues sagen, was voneinander abhängt und mach mal so. Und kannst du sofort wieder in deinen Mainthread zurückkehren, dich um den User kümmern und wenn der irgendwie auf Escape drückt und sagt, cancel den ganzen Scheiß, dann gehst du da wieder hin und sagst, das, was ich dir da alles gerade in Aufdruck gegeben habe, vergiss es. Schmeiß einfach weg. Sofort ist irgendwie alles abgebrochen. Aber wenn du das nicht machst und du fröhlich dem User andere Möglichkeiten der persönlichen Freudeentfaltung bietest, werden im Hintergrund halt diese Sachen durchgeführt und es wird halt je nach Bedarf und je nach Ressourcen, wie sie gerade verfügbar sind, neue Prozessorkurs benutzt, Dinge gleichzeitig getan oder hintereinander eben asynchron getan. Und das Ganze eben auf einer, auf der niedrigsten möglichen Ebene der Auflösung, C-Funktion. Das ist wirklich kolossal. Und ich denke, das ist eine der großartigsten Erweiterungen von...
Und das Grand Central sorgt sozusagen dafür, dass es halt nicht ganz so tief irgendwie so fein ist, sondern das halt der normale Cokor-Programmierer, das irgendwie, oder C-Programmierer, das eine eben höher irgendwie ein bisschen... Weil so einfach ist es mit diesen Blogs alles gar nicht. Da kriegt man ganz schön Kopfschmerzen, wenn man sich das...
Genau, das ist schon ein richtiges High-End-Feature für eine Logo-Sprache.
Weil was man bedenken muss bei den Blogs ist, dass da, wo man den Blog definiert, kriegen alle Variable in den Zustand, den sie zum Zeitpunkt der Bloggenerierung haben, kriegen sie auch den Wert, der gerade dort ist. Also wenn du in deinem Blog steht, also wenn du in deinem Blog i benutzt und i war kurz vor der Definition des Blogs irgendwie 5 und danach änderst du i aber auf 6, dann wenn du den Blog benutzt, ist i wieder 5, weil die Zerstellung des Blogs war i halt 5. Und das ist der Unterschied. Deswegen haben sie doch Blogs genannt und nicht irgendwie Lambda oder Closures oder sonst wie, weil es halt was anderes ist. Und das geht alles über einen Stack. Also alle diese Werte werden auf einen Stack abgelegt und wenn der Blog benutzt wird, dann werden die von da wieder geholt. Also das ist schon ziemlich komplexer Scheiß. Und wer da ein bisschen mehr Infos haben will, der muss mal nach einem Typen suchen, der Bbumganer heißt das, so ein uralt Apple Next Step Tra la la Veteran. Und der hat da ein paar Artikel über Blogs geschrieben, weil ich glaube der hat da mitentwickelt oder die vielleicht kommen nicht sogar von dem. Bbumganer.
B-U-M?
Warte mal, ich find mal kurz die Dings raus. Genau, der man nur von Essen chatet.
Bbum auf Twittert.
Genau, Bbum.
Sanitation Engineering Manager with a bucket of blogs. Codefab Inc.
Ich poste mal die Ull mit seinem Bbums Webblog-O-Mat irgendwie in Irk, dann kappt er da die Ull. Da sind auch irgendwie weiter unten.
In dem Blog hat er das...
Da sind auch weiter unten die Blogs erklärt. Weiter unten? Blogs, Tipps und Tricks und einmal Basic-Blogs. Von dem kommt dann noch mal richtig so Background-Information. Was ein Blog ist und was es nicht ist und wie man ihn einsetzt und all sowas.
Was hat er damit zu tun?
Ich glaube, der hat bei Apple das mitgemacht, so viel er drüber schreibt. Er hat auch ziemlich früh irgendwann mal über Blogs getwittert und der hat auch irgendwann schon vor einem halben oder ganzen Jahr getwittert, dass C-Lang jetzt Blogs kann und so. Also der muss es da bei Apple für zuständig sein.
Blogs are closures for C, genau, Anonymous Inline Collection of Code. Typed Argument List. Aha, okay, das ist so wirklich der Low-Level-Kram. Okay, verfügbar an GCC und C-Lang, da haben wir irgendwie das Richtige erzählt. LLVM, blablabla.
Kannst auch mit Next irgendwie, genau.
Das ist wirklich so schick. Und sie haben dann das Carré verwendet in C, also nicht so, dass da so viele Zeichen frei gewesen wären. Ja, bibum. Was hat der Chat dazu? Das war ja jetzt mal interessant, oder? Sind Sie noch wach? Ich meine, das war jetzt ein bisschen Hardcore, aber wir müssen auch mal...
Kann man auch schwer erklären, so ohne Slides?
Ja, also ich meine, wer jetzt in Programmierungen nicht so den Zugang hat und da jetzt irgendwie zugehört hat und sich fragt, was das für eine Bedeutung hat. Die Kerninformation ist die einfach, dass Apple ist einfach ein, wie ich finde, durchaus riskanten Weg gegangen, dass wir wirklich sagen, wir erweitern die uralte Systemsprache C um ein ganz signifikantes Feature, um es einfach generell einfacher zu machen, asynchron zu programmieren. Und asynchrone Programmierung ist einfach der Schlüssel zu performanteren Systemen.
Aber eigentlich stimmt das nicht.
Warum stimmt das nicht?
Na, weil die Blogs ja mit Asynchron erst mal nichts zu tun haben. Also ein Blog alleine macht nichts asynchron.
Das stimmt.
Sondern dazu brauchst du Lipdispatch. Und das hat mit der Sprache wieder nichts zu tun.
Okay, aber die Blogs machen das einfacher, Lipdispatch zu benutzen.
Du kannst jetzt Lipdispatch irgendwie so Blogs übergeben.
Ich hab zwei Sachen durcheinander gebracht. Okay, also machen wir das anders. Sie haben Lipdispatch rausgebracht. Lipdispatch ist im Wesentlichen das Feature, was asynchrone Programmierung ermöglicht, einfach macht, auf einen vergleichsweise hohen Abstraktionslevel bringt, auch wenn das Ganze sich immer noch auf einer sehr niedrigen Ebene abspielt. Zusätzlich haben sie der Sprache C noch Clojures beigebracht, um das Ganze noch einfacher nutzbar zu machen. Hab ich es jetzt richtig gebracht?
Ich kann mal ganz kurz noch in die Apple-Doku gucken.
Warum auf C-Ebene?
Warum nicht?
Weil das einfach die Ebene ist, auf der du... Weil sie nämlich auch ihre APIs so umgestellt haben, dass sie mit Blocks bedient werden. Also auch ihre APIs von System-Frameworks benutzen jetzt Blocks. Nicht alle, nicht überall, aber manche.
Um es auch auf den Ebenen nutzen zu können, die in C geschrieben sind, nämlich auf der ganzen Betriebssystem-Ebene von diesem BSD unten drunter, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten.
Genau, einfach auf OS-Ebene, auf möglichst niedriger Ebene, um einfach da einfach mehr Möglichkeiten zu haben. Das heißt, sie modernisieren die ganze Art und Weise, wie Programme mit dem Betriebssystem und auch mit sich selbst reden, signifikant.
Also wo zum Beispiel Blocks auch eingesetzt werden, und ich weiß dann nicht, ob das Framework, das unten drunter, dann multisthreaded macht, aber für ein NS-Array gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel die Methode enumerateObjects usingBlock. Das heißt, sagen wir, du hast 1000 Objekte in deinem Array, dann kannst du der Funktion, oder es ist eine Methode, kannst du der Methode dein Block übergeben, und dann wird jeder Block, also der Code, der da drin ist, auf jedes Objekt einmal angewendet. Und dafür sind Blocks da, du musst ja nicht irgendwie ein Callback haben, wie man das so früher nannte, dass du sagst, hier fühl mal das aus, ich hab das alles schon fertig geschrieben, dann übergibst du gleich fertig den Block mit den Zuständen der Variable, die gerade herrschen, das heißt, wenn du eventuell auch wieder an deinem Code vorbeikommst, können diese Variablen ja einen ganz anderen Zustand haben, und dann wäre auch dein Code entsprechend anders, also da kommen interessante Sachen, aber ich glaube, die Programmierer brauchen eine Weile, um sich dran zu gewöhnen.
Ne, Moment mal, also wie wurde das vorher gemacht? Also du konntest schon vorher einen Methodennamen sozusagen?
Also zum Beispiel mit dem Suchen, das gab's ja auch schon, da musstest du deinen Comparator, wie Tim schon meinte, musstest du mit an so eine Suchfunktion übergeben, und dann hat er die benutzt, um irgendwie seinen QuickSort da auszuführen und so weiter. Ich hab die Suche nicht mit Blocks gesehen, aber hier, dass du halt einmal auf alle Objekte aus einem Array hier so einen Block anwenden hast, das gibt's jetzt hier.
Ne, ne, wie war, also vorher gab's den Callback. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Block und einem Callback?
Der Unterschied ist, dass die anonyme Funktion an die Block, die du übergibst, sozusagen seinen ganzen State mit sich führt. Du übergibst das einmal an diese Funktion und dann kann diese Funktion sie zu jedem Zeitpunkt überall irgendwie aufrufen und dein Programm muss sich da nicht mehr groß damit rumschlagen. Im anderen Fall übergibst du eine Funktionsadresse, die dann aufgerufen wird, aber um diesen ganzen State aufrechtzuerhalten, musst du entweder dafür sorgen, dass diese Funktion diesen State hat, welchen State du auch immer brauchst, also welchen Kontext du brauchst, oder dass der dann halt noch übergeben wird von der Funktion.
Ach so, quasi, jetzt sind wir jetzt beim Thema Umgebungsvariablen sozusagen. Oder?
Nee, Umgebungsvariablen hört sich ganz doll nach Shell an.
Nee, nee, ich meine mit, mit, mit, mit, also...
Der Zustand aller deiner Variablen in deinem Programm zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du den Blog erzeugt hast, der wird sozusagen eingefroren, wenn du so einen Blog erzeugst.
Und wir sind per Default auch erstmal read-only.
Genau, aber ich kann auf, ich kann, ich brauche nicht jeden Scheißdreck als Parameter mit irgendwie zu übergeben oder sowas, sondern einfach da, in dem Moment, wo dieser Blog ausgeführt wird, ist es so, als würde er an der Stelle ausgeführt werden, wo er mal definiert wurde.
Wird da bloß nicht, wird später halt ausgeführt.
Also ist alles noch ein bisschen komplex, also ist gar nicht so einfach, sind halt eben nicht nur Funktionen, die man so benutzt, wie man, wo der Code dann so weiter reinläuft und die Variablen haben ihren Wert, den sie halt gerade haben, sondern sie haben den Wert an einem Block, den sie zur Definition des Blocks hat. Und das ist ganz schön tricky, da muss man im Kopf ganz schön umdenken. Also, aber wir sind ja die User, von Userseite betrachtet wird einfach alles nur schneller, besser, toller und die Developer müssen sich da ihren Kopf zerbrechen. Ich hab das bisher erst einmal benutzt für so einen kleinen simplen Testcase, wo irgendwie so eine kleine Scramble-Routine über einen Megabyte großen Block drüber gefahren ist. Und ich hab einfach mal gemessen und hab das hier mit dem Lip-Dispatch irgendwie gemacht. Und da hieß das hier Dispatch Apply. Und dann ruft man das einmal auf. Der hat sozusagen meine riesengroße Schleife, die ich vorher hatte pro Byte, was einmal irgendwie aufgerufen wurde, hat ja irgendwie Multiswadded für mich. Und das war anstatt, also er hat nur noch 66% ohne Lip-Dispatch gebraucht. Das ist jetzt nicht die Hälfte, wie man so denken würde bei zwei CPUs, aber für so einen simplen Case mit relativ viel Overhead und relativ wenig Arbeit war das schon mal ganz gut. Und ich denke, da kommen noch mehr schicke Sachen, wenn ich nur an SFF MPEG denke oder hier VLC und die ganzen Encoder und so.
Aus der ganzen JavaScript-Ebene, da heißen die Dinge, wie wir gesagt haben, Closures, ist es einfach, dass da irgendwie was parallelisiert abläuft oder sowas ist im Endeffekt relativ banan. Bei mir ist es so, dass ich, ich will mich endlich mal mit beschäftigen, wie die Dinge eigentlich genau funktionieren. Ich wusste es aber bis eben gerade nicht oder ich weiß es im Augenblick noch nicht, benutze sie aber trotzdem ständig, weil sie erstaunlich intuitiv funktionieren. Also ich glaube, das wird noch, das wird so dieses, ich will jetzt was parallelisieren, es ist komplett daneben, sondern einfach bei JavaScript nutzt man die um, bei jQuery zum Beispiel eben gerade besonders um, hänge mal folgende Funktion an alle Objekte meiner Seite dran, an alle Links, die drauf sind oder sowas in der Richtung und dann wird die da schön drüber verteilt über das ganze System. Also das ist, wenn das dann mal richtig genutzt wird, wird man damit wahrscheinlich wie in JavaScript eine ganze Menge Scheiße sehen, die wirklich ziemlich geil ist.
Programmieren in C wird jetzt einfacher, Punkt.
Einfacher weiß ich gar nicht.
Es wird einfacher.
Einfacher ist das alles nicht.
Ich finde das einfacher.
Du musst dich umgewöhnen, glaub mir.
Du gewinnst einfach ein Feature dazu, was in anderen Sprachen als das Nonplusultra gilt.
Mach das noch zwei, drei, also das ist meine Erfahrung. Am Anfang denkst du, hm, dann beim zweiten Mal denkst du, wow, dann hast du irgendwann dieses totale AHA-Erlebnis, wo du sagst, wie geil ist das denn? Und danach ist es einfach... Und danach machst du das eigentlich immer.
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal gucken, was ist eigentlich mit OpenCL? Ich meine, das kommt ja nun irgendwie noch mit dazu. Also die Performance-Steigerung von Snow Leopard, ich finde sie ja signifikant. Ich muss sagen, mein relativ alter Rechner, da flutscht dieses ganze OS deutlich besser. Und was nicht dazu beiträgt, ist OpenCL. Oder einfach meine Grafikkarte.
Wo halten sie das auch ein?
OpenCL wird bisher noch gar nicht genutzt, oder?
Ich glaube, das wird noch nicht so richtig eingesetzt. OpenCL? Und die neuen Rechner nicht. Wohin?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich kann mir eine Menge Stellen vorstellen, wo zum Beispiel H264, Encoding, Decoding, diese ganzen Sachen. Gut, Decoding machen sie wahrscheinlich direkt in der Grafikkarte bei diesen 9000ern, weil das haben die da sozusagen einfach in Hardware. Aber das ist ja eigentlich genau das, wovon wir reden. In der Grafikkarte Hardware Sachen ablaufen lassen.
Eigentlich könnten sie diesen Support in der Hardware auch schon wieder weglassen und das halt auch als OpenCL zur Verfügung stellen. Oder es ist vielleicht sogar schon so.
Ja, ich habe keine Erkenntnisse darüber, was unter Umständen schon mit OpenCL gemacht ist. Aber es ist offensichtlich, dass sie eine ganze Menge in QuickTime und in sonstigen Mediensachen und auch Core Audio könnte erheblich von OpenCL profitieren.
Das ist halt das Schöne bei dem Snow Leopard. Also auch wenn man eine Menge nicht sieht, aber unten drunter und an den Frameworks und Apis und so weiter, da sind so viele schicke neue Sachen dabei, dass es echt irgendwie Spaß macht. Leider muss ich ja gerade fürs iPhone coden und kann bestimmte Sachen noch gar nicht einsetzen. Also so zehn, sechs Only-Features, aber das ist echt schickes Zeug dabei.
Es könnte auch dem nächsten iPhone einen Riesenboost geben, weil wenn das nächste iPhone dann tatsächlich auch OpenCL-fähig ist und vielleicht auch noch zwei CPUs hat, damit lebt Dispatch, da geht es richtig zur Sache.
Wenn man eine Autobatterie mit dabei hat, ist sogar ein halben Tag durch.
Denke ich noch den Witz von Otto, der auf die Bühne kommt und mit dem Koffer in der Hand und mit seiner Uhr, die kann alles hier folgendes und hat 1000 Features und so, meint er aber ein Nacht, die Batterie ist so schwer und zeigt auf seinen riesen Koffer.
Woher kommt mir das bekannt vor?
Ja, von Otto.
Aber hast du irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber, wie OpenCL und dieses Lip-Dispatch miteinander Freunde sind?
Da habe ich noch nicht vorgelesen, dass sie mit verheiratet sind.
Aber das wäre doch eigentlich, das wäre doch dann hier mit LLMP, leck mich an. LLVM. Die theoretisch den Code auch auf GPUs und CPUs und mit auf Wurst verteilen könnte. Nicht?
Das ist moderner und besser.
Aber ich dachte, dass er intern einen Bytecode erzeugt, der dann auch...
Er könnte einen Bytecode erzeugen, macht er aber gerade.
Per Default macht er hier gar nichts.
Doch, der Bytecode wird erzeugt zum Zwecke der Durchführung der mehrstufigen Optimierung. Also es gibt...
Ist aber nichts mit Default hier. Da ist kein Bytecode. Dieses Limit Time Optimization ist noch nicht an.
Nein, doch. Also in dem Moment, wo das Frontend etwas übersetzt, also LLVM ist dreistufig, erst mal übersetzt du Source-Code in einen Zwischencode. Das ist dieser LLVM. Das ist diese Virtual Machine. Das ist sozusagen eine abstrakte Repräsentierung deines Programms.
Also ein bisschen so, wie man es eigentlich von Java kennt.
Ja, das ist eine VM. GCC hat sowas auch, da heißt das irgendwie Pi-Code. Da gibt es aber auch drei verschiedene Varianten mittlerweile. Hatte ich in meinem LLVM CAE. So, dann hast du sozusagen die zweite Ebene, das ist die Optimierungsebene. Da wird auf diesem LLVM Bytecode können dann Optimierungen gemacht werden. Das heißt, du kannst irgendwie N-Plugins haben, die alle in dieser LLVM-Welt sich dieses Code annehmen und ihn auf irgendwelche Dinge hin optimieren. Und dann hast du die eigentliche Generation, wo du aus diesem LLVM-Code machst du dann Executable Code. Dann kommt dann sozusagen richtig Intel oder Arm oder was auch immer raus. Das heißt, wenn du einen C lang verwendest, C lang macht C zu LLVM. Und dann kommt der Optimizer und dann kommt der Code Generator und der macht dann Intel-Code oder Arm-Code und 64 Bitten, 32 Bitten und so weiter.
Draus.
Aber noch keine Link-Time-Optimisation. Machen die noch nicht. Dazu müssten nämlich also bisher, wenn die einzelnen Object-Files... Bisher werden ja die Object-Files einzeln gespeichert und dann vom Linker zusammengelinkt und der kann dann nichts mehr optimieren, weil das schon kein Byte-Code mehr ist, sondern das ist halt schon richtiger Object-Code. Also richtiger Maschinen-Code. Und jetzt könnte LF-Alber diese einzelnen Files, die du halt compilst, zu diesem Byte-Code machen und dann könnte der Linker den Byte-Code zusammenkleben und dann optimieren, nachdem alle Einzelteile zusammengefügt wurden. Und dann kann er natürlich viel besser optimieren, weil er das Gesamtpicture sieht und nicht mehr nur noch einzelne Blöcke.
Aber das Gesamtergebnis wäre deutlich größer. Von einer Teilgröße her.
Ja klar, dein Programm, so groß wie das Programm wäre. Und dann kannst du halt zwischen den Files optimieren. Bisher kann so ein GCC, wenn du zwei Files hast, wo dein Code drin ist, dann kann er das eine optimieren, das andere optimieren, aber er kann alle Calls zwischen den beiden, was er definitiv ist, weil irgendwie müssen die sich ja unterhalten, den kann er nicht optimieren. Und der LF-Alber könnte das. Das ist die sogenannte Link-Time-Optimisation und da geht echt noch was ab dann.
Was ich noch meine ist, wäre es denn nicht über kurz oder lang denkbar, dass man zumindest Teile des Codes sagt, oder ist das mit OpenCL der Fall, dass man einfach sagt, ist mir doch wurscht, auf welchem Gerät der abläuft, kompiliere das doch erst zur Laufzeit.
Das haben die schon so vorgedacht, aber ich glaube, das gibt es noch nicht. Das ist halt so wie Java, so Byte-Code, und dass du den auslieferst und dass der dann vor Ort irgendwie, aber ich glaube, da fehlt dann auch die Runtime zu, die das der dann auch vor Ort machen müsste und so weiter und so fort, aber ich könnte mir das gut vorstellen, dass das mal so kommt.
Ich meine, genug Erfahrung in dem Bereich gibt es von Java und von diesen ganzen Interpretersprachen, die es mittlerweile gibt.
Dann kommt es aus einem Just-And-Time-Compiler und der macht das dann, ja.
Genau, wenn die Grafikkarte da ist, wie das kann, dann machst du mal der scheiß Grafikkarte. Ansonsten, also das ist doch die schöne Welt, von der wir alle träumen. Und wenn die Grafikkarte nicht da ist, naja, gut, dann machst du das halt ganz klassisch auf deinem Multicore-Prozessor.
Ja, also ich meine, das muss ich erst nochmal zeigen, ob der Code, der sich mit OpenCL gut beschleunigen lässt, auch Code ist, der auf normalen CPUs performt.
Natürlich nicht.
Und wahrscheinlich ist dem nicht so. Sondern es ist schon noch dieser Unterschied zwischen linearen Sachen mit niedriger Asynchronizität, das ist halt so CPU-Kram, und Versus gleichförmige Operationen auf großen Daten, also diese ganze SIM-D-Gerichte.
Mal sagen, die Milliardenfach wiederholen über den gleichen Speicherbereich.
Aber es geht ja auch Single Instruction, Multiple Data oder Multiple Instruction, Multiple Data.
Also genauso wie mein MacBook hier schon zwei Grafikkartenprozessoren hat, die theoretisch ja auch komplett unterschiedlich sein könnten. Es könnte ja auch sein, in einem Gerät steckt eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte drin, in einem anderen steckt eine ATI-Grafikkarte drin und ich erzeuge dynamisch den Code für die entsprechende Grafikkarte. Das ist ja das, was OpenCL macht. Ach, das macht OpenCL?
Das ist genau das, was OpenCL macht. OpenCL ist eine abstrakte Sprache, die dann eben zur Laufzeit auf die jeweilige Grafikkarte umgesetzt wird.
Auch schon von Apple indiziert und zwar relativ schnell. Die haben das wohl in einem halben Jahr diesen Standard durchgezogen.
Wobei das ja im Prinzip nichts anderes war, als eine Verallgemeinerung von diesem CUDA-Graben. Beziehungsweise Streams bei ATI. Diese Technologie hat sich an sich schon als solche abgezeichnet.
Die machen nur Streams, die machen nur CUDA. Die kriegen sich als Konkurrenzium natürlich nicht auf die Reihe. Das Apple hergegangen hat gesagt, Jungs, das geht so nicht, wir wollen euch beide benutzen, weil wir den Konkurrenzpreis billiger sind.
Die haben im Prinzip einen sinnlosen War, der Systeme von vornherein verhindert. Bevor diese Technologie wirklich zur Anwendung kommt, gibt es jetzt schon einen Standard, der auch wunderbar aufgehoben ist, wo er jetzt ist.
Chronos grob, das die auch OpenGL machen. Also es ist irgendwie kein Apple-Spielkram, sondern es ist schon...
Ernsthaft.
Es ist ernst.
Ernst. Ich kann mir richtig vorstellen, wie so die Apple-Hasser, wie Fevon, so ist ja Apple-Hasser Deluxe, also ist ja eigentlich der Top-Apple-Hasser. Und für den ist das auch eine Auszeichnung, ich finde das ja gut. Wie die abkacken, dass von unserer Alch-Candy-Firma Apple so eine Sachen kommen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich geläutnet.
Ja, nee.
Das war gar nicht von Apple.
Fevon hat sich jetzt auch schnell vor allem angeguckt. Er kommt da auch nicht dran vorbei.
Und auf Windows-Basis ist was Vergleichbares DirectX 11, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
DirectX 11 ist ja die Konkurrenz zu OpenGL.
Ja, aber DirectX 11 hat glaube ich auch so kleine Elemente mit drin, dass man auf die Grafikkarte aufnehmen kann. Das wird aber erst von zukünftigen Grafikkarten unterstützt werden, eines Ferntages.
Aber man muss schon sagen, wahrscheinlich gibt es mehr DirectX-Installationen als OpenGL, oder?
Die neue Game-Plattform heißt iPhone.
Selbst die Xbox hat die Xbox und die die Xbox hat wahrscheinlich DirectX. Aber die Sony-PlayStation und so, die machen ja auch alle OpenGL.
Alle machen OpenGL außer Microsoft. Die Zeiten, wo Microsoft die Standard-Dicke-Tier entlang...
Jetzt, Jungs, jetzt hört nochmal genau zu.
Ich hab's schon mal gesagt.
0 Uhr 14, jetzt geht das Microsoft-Gebäsche los. Ihr könnt jetzt bis 1 Uhr vorspulen.
Stimmt, wir haben ja vorhin, als du noch nicht da warst, haben wir über Liktopo schon ordentlich angefangen und wie wir deinen Partner setzen können.
Das Erste war, wir müssen über Microsoft und Nokia herziehen. Uns ja doch ein bisschen Podcast loben und schlecht machen. Also was alles noch nicht geht und wie toll Podcasten ist.
Ich zieh gar nicht über Microsoft her. Ich hab nur gesagt, dass ihr Einfluss geschwunden ist.
In letzter Zeit, falls du mal die einschlägigen Blogs liest, wird Microsoft gerade mal wieder ein schöner Hype gemacht. Und ich frag mich ein bisschen, ob die tatsächlich ein paar gute Produkte rausgebracht haben oder ob die entsprechenden End-Gadget und Gizmode wirklich gnadenlos gekauft sind. Weil, habt ihr diese Reviews von diesem, wie heißt das jetzt? Sun HD gelesen, der ja gar kein HD kann. Man kann auch ein externes Dock kaufen und das kann man dann an den Fernseher anschließen und dann kann man da so einen Tune reinstecken und dann kann der HD.
Aber ehrlich, wie viel Marktanteil hat der jetzt so einen Zoom? Keinen. Ungefähr so, nicht mal so viel wie Apple im Vergleich zu Windows hat.
Ja, aber während beim Original Tune alle noch gesagt haben, muss man schon Microsoft Fanboy sein, um das Ding zu kaufen, sagen sie jetzt plötzlich alle, oh der ist richtig toll, der ist richtig toll, obwohl ich wirklich...
Ja guck mal, das ist doch dieses Mitleidsding, das haben die doch mit Vista auch schon, und finden jetzt alle sagen, irgendwie Windows 7, das ist jetzt die Erlösung. Und Windows 7 ist vielleicht ein Stück besser, das Vista ist ja auch nicht schwer, aber ein bisschen besser heißt ja noch lange nicht gut.
Nee, also wenn jemand daherkommt und anfängt, den Tendition HD ernsthaft mit einem iPod Touch zu vergleichen und sagt, oh ja, kann man machen, dann haben die entweder wirklich einen großen Wurf gelandet oder eine sehr, sehr gute Marketing-Abteilung, die sehr, sehr viele Testgeräte sind.
Das kann ja sein, aber am Ende...
Das ist einfach, da brauchen wir überhaupt nicht drüber reden.
BD war ein bisschen neidisch auf die iPods, hat gesagt, los, macht mal so ein Geld ist egal und seitdem machen die halt. Und Verluste bestimmt auch, wie blöd.
Wem wollen die da, womit im Weg stehen mit diesem Ding?
Wie lange machen wir noch?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, wir kommen jetzt zu den iPhones und iPods, kommen wir sowieso nicht mehr. Aber man sollte schon nochmal den Part Snow Leopard so bis zum Ende bringen.
Was hast du jetzt noch für ein Thema?
Na, es gibt noch ein paar Sachen, die auch nicht mehr da sind in Snow Leopard. Ja, das stimmt, das hatte ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht. Wie nicht da ist es eigentlich? Es ist sogar der ZFS-Support, der in 10.5 drin war, ist nicht mehr da, oder was?
Ist auch nicht mehr da. Was ich gestern hatte, habe ich irgendwie eine Platte angeschlossen, da war irgendwie ein ZFS drauf. Und dann kam so ein Fenster auch und es meinte, dass da ein ZFS wäre und ich die Files nicht benutzen könnte mit dieser Version der Software. Dass aber meine Daten schon alle noch da wären, nur dass ich sie halt mit dieser Version der Software nicht lesen könnte. Und die meinten mit dieser Version der Software wahrscheinlich, dass Snow Leopard das halt nicht kann.
Keine Ahnung.
Also das ist mir wirklich ein Rätsel.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist so...
Sie haben doch da extrem viel Arbeit reingesteckt um...
Naja extrem viel, weiß nicht, auf jeden Fall ein bisschen. Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum sie dann nicht mal nach vorne treten und sagen, Jungs, alles klar, war uns irgendwie doch ein bisschen zu viele Features, das verstehen die normal sterblich nicht. Wir schaffen es nicht, das irgendwie GUI zu machen. Okay, vielleicht will man sowas nicht sagen, aber dass sie damit nicht mal nach vorne treten und sagen, dass das Projekt gecancelt ist, sondern sie schweigen einfach und sagen irgendwie gar nichts. Und das ist schon ein bisschen blöd, gerade für die ZFS-Fanboys unter den Apple-Jüngern, die wissen nicht, was sie jetzt genau tun sollen. Also die basteln sich da rum, versuchen die letzten Betas von Snow Leopard irgendwie zum Laufen zu kriegen, was auch teilweise funktioniert, aber auch nicht so richtig. Und das ist alles ein bisschen schade.
Also mich hat das ein bisschen überrascht, dass es also nicht so richtig komplett weg ist, obwohl ich immer noch glaube, dass das kommt. Also das will ich nicht annehmen. Wobei es gibt verwirrende Zeichen. Zum Beispiel dieses neue, also sie haben ja nun HFS neue Features gegeben.
Dieses Compressed Feature, was ich immer noch nicht genau weiß, wie sie das machen, aber sie komprimieren da irgendein Zeug weg.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen tricky und sie benutzen irgendwie Forks dafür.
Ja, und aber auch nur für ihre eigenen Programme, weil die man ja sowieso nicht auf einem älteren Mac gebrauchen könnte und deswegen spielt es da keine Rolle, weil es wird ja dann nicht mitkopiert, oder doch?
Für ihre älteren Programme?
Na sagen wir so, das 10-6er Mail-App, wenn das komprimiert ist und man braucht Mail-App nicht woanders hin kopieren, deswegen wird es hier komprimiert und es wäre kaputt, wenn man es woanders hinschiebt.
Wenn du ein HFS, in dem Sachen komprimiert sind, so einfach an ein 10-5 anschließt, dann wird er mit den Dateien so nichts anfangen können, er wird sie aber immerhin kopieren können.
Okay, kopieren kann es, er kann es nicht.
Er kann sie kopieren, weil es halt einfach...
Aber deswegen ist doch nur das 10-6 selbst komprimiert, weil das 10-5 muss nicht die Systemdaten von einem 10-6 lesen können. Und du installierst auch noch Leopard. Startest dann Leopard und willst von dem Leopard auf die 10-6 Daten zugreifen, die jetzt komprimiert sind. Und das geht einfach nicht, aber es ist auch egal, weil das Leopard muss nicht, das Mail-App von 10-6 kann es eh nicht starten, weil es würde eh nicht gehen und deswegen ist es auch egal, wenn es das nicht lesen kann.
Hast du Erkenntnisse darüber, bei welchen Dateien die Kompression genutzt wird? Nur bei Executable-Snails.
Also ich hab's so verstanden, dass es nur bei System-Dateien stattfindet, nicht bei User-Dateien, weil die will man ja weiterhin kopieren kann, auch mit einem 10-5.
System-Dateien, alles würde Sinn machen.
Und deswegen ist es auch ein kleineres System.
Slash-System ist sozusagen voll durchkomprimiert, aber es bezieht sich jetzt nicht nur auf...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Slash-System ist oder nur Applications oder so, aber auf jeden Fall...
Ok, also das wäre nochmal ganz interessant, das nachzurenken. Dann gibt es auch ein HFS-Feature, was weg ist. Snow Leopard kann nämlich nicht mehr HFS schreiben. Ohne Plus. Das gute, alte, prä, mech, os, 8, 1? HFS, das was seit dem...
Also wahrscheinlich ist es aber nur eine Webquery-Änderung, oder? Ich denke mal der Code hat sich jetzt...
Du kannst das wohl nicht mehr schreiben. Also du kannst HFS-Volumes nur noch Read-Only-Mounten. So hab ich's verstanden. Ich hab jetzt kein HFS-Volume mehr rumliegen.
Na ja, aber was außer... Das könnte man doch noch rumfliegen haben. Vielleicht irgendwo ein altes...
Wenn ich jetzt hier meine uralten Zip-Discs auspacke, dann ist das bestimmt noch...
Ja, ja, sowas.
Ein paar CD-Roms, aber die kann man eh nicht schreiben.
Ja, sowas. Keine Ahnung, alte Platten, Back-ups, sowas halt.
Ich hab neulich eine schöne Diskette gesehen, eine schöne Anzeige gesehen, ich hab wirklich vorne drauf geguckt, ob es ein aktuelles Heft ist, auf irgendeiner Mac-Zeitschrift. War so hinten drauf, so eine Abbildung. Man kann jetzt Druckdaten übrigens auch, man muss die nicht mehr auf die althergebrachte Weise übergeben, sondern auch auf moderne Art per Internet. Und dann haben die da zu einem Foto gemacht sozusagen, wie es vorher war, da haben die wirklich noch Disketten gehabt. Da muss irgendjemand in einen 1000-jährigen, in einen 10-jährigen Schlaf verfallen sein.
Das ist gar nicht so lange her mit diesen Disketten. Das kommt einem zwar so vor wie vor zwei Jahrzehnten, aber Disketten sind noch ein Teil dieses Jahrtausends gewesen.
Na, aber Druckdaten auf Disketten, das sind das... Wie viele Disketten hat man da verbrannt? Na ja, ich fand's auf jeden Fall ein schönes...
PDFs sind nicht so groß. Also 1,44 MB.
Wenn du so vernünftig drucken willst, wenn da ein bisschen Bilder drin sind, dann sind die schon mal ein streues Groß.
Wie auch immer. Also ich denke, dass sie mit HFS, Wraiz-Support, genauso wie auch mit dem Weglassen von Apple Talk sich nicht gerade ins Fleisch geschnitten haben, sondern das sind einfach so Sachen, wo sie gesagt haben, das ist jetzt eine Technologie, die wirklich nicht mehr in Benutzung ist und wir lassen es einfach sterben, weil jedes Stück Kot, was nicht mehr drin ist, müssen wir nicht maintainen, müssen wir nicht auf 64-Bit kriegen, müssen wir nicht testen und so weiter.
Ich meine, also dagegen ist im Vergleich dazu, dass Rosetta jetzt schon so Second Class Citizen geworden ist, finde ich da ja wesentlich dramatischer. Oder was heißt dramatischer? Das stört mich jetzt auch nicht, aber das ging ja wirklich mal schnell, das Power PC.
Das ist ja nur bei default nicht installiert und in dem Moment, wo du es brauchst und das jeder braucht, in dem Moment, wo er irgendwie Office installiert hat, weil bei Microsoft Office, obwohl es ja angeblich native ist, trotzdem noch irgendwie Power PC Code dabei ist.
Das ist ja wirklich geil.
Wenn du irgendwie auf ist, da startet sich dann irgendwie gleich am Anfang so ein blöder Microsoft-Updater, Schnickes, und kommt dann hoch und der will halt gleich Rosetta haben. Also sie haben da irgendwas immer noch in Power PC. Na ja, du hast auch kein Office installiert. Dann ist noch was weg. Und zwar haben sie die alten Java-Versionen entfernt. Also es gibt kein Java 1.4, kein Java 1.5 mehr.
Na und viel kritischer oder extremer in dem Zusammenhang? Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt der nächste, was du noch dazu sagen wolltest.
Ich wollte noch was dazu sagen. Ich wundere mich, dass du das irgendwie voraussagen könntest, was ich jetzt noch dazu festgestellt habe. Ich kannte das auch erst seit Kurzem. Es gab halt dieses Coco Java, das API, mit dem du in Java auch Coco Anwendungen machen konntest.
Das haben sie auch gecancelt.
Das ist komplett weg. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wann hatten sie das eingeführt? Mit zehn, ganz am Anfang irgendwann, als sie noch der Meinung waren, man könnte damit das machen.
Ich nehme an, das war älter als das Mac OS.
Ich würde mal behaupten, das war schon mal ein extra Java. Java war überhaupt erst mit Mac OS 10 ein Thema. Da kam das überhaupt erst.
Da kam eine kurze Phase, wo Webobjects einmal in Java neu programmiert wurden. Dann haben sie festgestellt, große Hype, aber keiner will das irgendwie.
Webobjects ist immer noch Java.
Das will auch keiner mehr.
Web-Backends sind Java. Webobjects wird noch benutzt. Von Leuten, die mit Webobjects Anwendungen machen. Ist nicht der größte Erfolg der Weltgeschichte für Apple, aber es gibt es noch. Und es ist jetzt bei Mac OS X Server aber serienmäßig auch nicht mehr dabei. Wie auch immer. Sie haben die alten Java-Versionen kassiert. Sie haben diese Coco-Java damit auch kassiert. Das heißt, ihr Java 1.6 hat das nicht mehr. Und ich bin da tatsächlich gleich in eine Falle reingetreten. Also ich hab mir fehlt jetzt sozusagen ein Feature, weil es gibt von der Firma Juniper ein SSL-basiertes VPN-Ding, was tatsächlich darüber funktioniert, dass du dir übers Web so eine Java-Coco-Java-App runterlädst, die dann nach Eingabe von Administrator-Password auf deinem Mac gestartet wird, da ein Fensterchen aufmacht und über Localhost Routing einführt und dann sozusagen dir ein VPN da auf deinem Rechner laufen lässt.
Welche Studenten haben sie denn da schon wieder mit Arbeit zugemüllt?
Na gut, die Frage ist, was können sie jetzt tun? Jetzt können sie jemanden engagieren und die Anwendung entsprechend in Objective-Scene neu schreiben. Andererseits, die Möglichkeit gab es auf diesem OS. In der Rest auch alles. Ja gut, aber es geht halt irgendwie nicht mehr.
Ich fand das damals eine schöne Option, dass Java sozusagen eine zweitsenative Sprache war. Ich habe es nie genutzt, aber auch andere, dass man seine Bibliotheken weiter nutzen konnte. Und wenn man Java-Programmierer ist, kann man sich relativ leicht reinfinden in diese Intervierprogrammierung. Ich finde das den Gedanken dahinter eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Ich finde es ein bisschen schade.
Ja, es ist aber schon immer eine krude Heirat gewesen. Also ein OS, das mit Frameworks arbeitet, was darauf basiert, dass du eine dynamische Programmiersprache hast. Dem Ganzen dann als Frontend eine statische Programmiersprache vor die Nase zu halten. Das hat schon noch nie gepasst. Und eigentlich wollte das auch nie jemand haben.
Java ist statisch? Was war denn das?
Dynamic Binding und so weiter gibt es da nicht. Java ist nicht so super modern. Java ist stark, weil es einfach von der Syntax her, vor allem für Leute, die schon C gemacht haben, sehr leicht zu erlernen ist. Java löst viele Probleme. Mit Delivery wunderbar. Dieses ganze Class Packaging und so weiter. Und natürlich mit der Virtual Machine. Das ist wunderbar und vor allem deshalb stark, weil es jetzt so mega verbreitet ist und für jeden Scheiß irgendwelche Bibliotheken und fertige Klassen gibt, die du auch ohne Probleme andocken kannst, egal auf was für ein OS du läufst. Das ist weitgehend unabhängig davon.
Aber Apple kümmert sich doch da eher gerade um McRuby. Habt ihr davon mal gehört?
Ja. Hatten wir das nicht schon mal hier?
Wir schreiben gerade McRuby komplett neu und das ist jetzt schon schneller als das originale Ruby.
Nach ihren eigenen ersten Tests einer frühen Version, ja.
Ja, aber joFrendHucke ist ja auch so ein Ruby-Coder-Business-mäßig und der ist da mal voll am Schwärmen, was Apple da irgendwie verstanden hat.
Ja, und das machen sie ja mit LLVM. Genau, und ich könnte mir das auch sehr gut vorstellen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich diese Vermutung hier schon mal geäußert hatte, aber ich hab's nach wie vor dieselbe. Wenn sie dieses Projekt verfolgen, weiter verfolgen und ernsthaft verfolgen.
Ja, das muss ja auch einen Grund haben.
Na klar. Ich meine, McRobie ist das in die Coco Frameworks voll integrierte Ruby. So wie die Base Types von Objective-C eben komplett verheiratet sind mit den Coco Frameworks, ist das eben bei dem McRobie auch so. Das heißt, ein Ruby-String ist ein Coco-String. Oder ein Core, was auch immer. Wie heißt der Layer? Nicht Core Data, sondern Core Foundation String.
Also ein NS-String.
Genau, ein NS-String ist sozusagen Bit-by-Bit exakt dasselbe wie ein... Also in McRobie ist ein Ruby-String exakt dasselbe wie ein... Er ist ein NS-String.
Es ist nicht dasselbe wie, sondern es ist... Man muss nicht hin und her konvertieren, wenn man irgendeine Coco-Funktion ruft.
Apple schreibt immer von Toll Bridge Free.
Ja, und das könnte natürlich bedeuten... Also man kann sich jetzt fragen, warum macht Apple das? Warum? Meiner Meinung nach könnte es bedeuten... Ich hab das hier schon mal gesagt, aber ich sag's trotzdem. Es gibt einen Bedarf für Programmierung in einer anderen Programmiersprache auf dem Mac. Und die Ruby-Welt ist sehr attraktiv. Und viele Leute, die sowieso Ruby machen, sind sowieso alle auf Apple. Die ganze Ruby-Bewegung ist auf dem Mac geboren worden.
Das gleiche haben wir schon mal gemacht mit Pythons. Und da hat es auch schon nicht geklappt.
Ja, aber Pythons ist nicht Ruby.
Haben sie aber auch so ziemlich dicht reingeklebt.
Nicht so dicht. Also sie haben da so ein paar Brücken gebaut und so weiter, dass du das eben machen konntest. Aber es waren halt alles...
ObjectivePython, Obi...
Sowas gab es auch. ObjectivePython.
Hat auch dieser Bebumkana gemacht. Der hat auch mal gepostet.
Ja, aber auf welcher Ebene war das jetzt wirklich eine Brücke? Das war aber eher so, dass du so Objective-C aufrufen konntest und dass du überhaupt erst mal die Frameworks aufrufen konntest. Das war aber nicht so, dass das ganze Typensystem mit... Es ist nicht so, dass das Python-Typensystem komplett verheiratet wurde mit Coco. Das Ding ist, Ruby unterscheidet sich in Python in einer entscheidenden Punkt. Es folgt derselben Syntax-Convention. Also du hast in Ruby auch diese ganze Smalltalk-Denke drin, genauso wie bei Objective-C. Das heißt, die Art und Weise, wie du mit Objekten umgehst in Ruby ist sehr ähnlich zu Objective-C. Und das macht natürlich Ruby zu einer interessanten Programmiersprache. Wenn du jetzt angenommen ein 10.7 kommt serienmäßig mit Mac-Ruby, dann könnten sie im Prinzip sagen, du kannst zwei First-Class-Applications machen. Entweder programmierst du das in Ruby oder machst du das in Objective-C. Ob sie so weit gehen, weiß ich nicht. Wäre aber vorstellbar. Und es wäre an sich auch cool.
Die Frage ist natürlich, wie lange kann man sich darauf verlassen, wenn sie Java doch relativ kurz nur drinnen behalten haben.
Da hat auch nie wirklich wer angefangen, das zu benutzen. In jedem Objective-Buch-Stand benutzt kein Java, weil es Schrott ist. In jedem Buch. Aaron Hilligast ist das Standardwerk, das gleich am Anfang steht. Man könnte das auch in Java machen, aber wir machen ja nur Objective-C.
Welche Programme gab es denn, die in Java geschrieben sind, mit dem Coco-Java?
Offensichtlich dein Programm, das du brauchtest.
Das ist aber nicht wirklich...
Aber wenn ich jetzt anfangen würde, wenn ich mir das ganze Spielchen angucke und sage, Apple hat schon mal eine zweite Sprache als First Class Fittingsen gepflegt.
Klar, First Class war das auch nicht wirklich.
Na ja, okay, aber auf jeden Fall konnte ich eine Applikation schreiben, die von außen durch nichts unterscheiden war, von einer Objective-C-Applikation. Ich brauch jetzt keine neue Sprache zu lernen, ich kann mit dem, was ich arbeite, machen. Und plötzlich nach 7, 8 Jahren, 2001, 8 Jahren geht das plötzlich nicht mehr. Lass mich da vor 3, 4 Jahren drin eingestiegen sein.
Ja, ich meine, du kannst eh nicht davon ausgehen, dass irgendein Betriebssystem eine Basis für dein ganzes Leben ist. Ich meine, du musst schon in der Zeit leben und...
Ja, aber du willst jetzt auch nicht in der Kleinigkeit einen kompletten Code-Rewrite hinlegen. Ich habe Code-Bases, die durchaus fast das Alter hat. Und PAP-Code, den ich irgendwann mal geschrieben habe, den ich heute noch einsetze. Bloß weil da plötzlich irgendwie eine Firma eine andere Entscheidung trifft. Insofern wäre ich da vielleicht jetzt vor...
Aber das ist der Apple-Berühmte. Wir haben sie mit Adobe auch schon gemacht, mit dem Carbon und 64-Bit.
Wobei Carbon ist jetzt wirklich, muss man ja sagen...
Aber erst haben sie gesagt, sie machen es.
Ja, das ist schwer zu beantworten. Andererseits schließt das auch nicht aus, dass Apple sich durchaus mal strategisch entscheiden könnte und sagt, wir wollen hier auch so eine volldynamische Scriptsprache auch mit unterstützen und die Möglichkeit bieten, noch schneller und noch einfacher vollwertige Coco-Applikationen...
Das fände ich super, wenn ich die Gefahr wäre, dass wenn es nicht klappt, sie vielleicht nach 40 Jahren...
Ich meine, so für Anwendungen, die nicht wirklich performancekritisch sind, Sachen, die im Wesentlichen so Dialoge aufmachen, Formulare generieren, die dich irgendwelche Dinge abfragen und so, und danach schreibst du irgendwie eine kleine Datei weg und so...
Ich bin großer Fan von Scriptsprachen.
Genau, da muss man ja nicht unbedingt jetzt irgendwie auf C-Ebene gehen und da könnte man irgendwie mit Ruby machen. Ich könnte mir das einfach gut vorstellen und ich sehe ehrlich gesagt keinen anderen Grund, warum sie da überhaupt forschen sollten mit McRuby, als wenn sie solche Ziele verfolgen oder zumindest nicht das Tor offen lassen wollen.
Man kann sogar einen Schritt weiter gehen, kann sagen, mach's als Prototyping, entwickle es erstmal in Ruby und dann setze systemkritische Sachen oder zeitkritische Sachen, setze da nochmal ein Objective-C, und wenn du es unbedingt brauchst, oder... Dann haltet man auch direkt in C, oder weißt du das?
Ja, irgendwas wollte ich sagen.
Ich meine, wir leben in einer Welt, wo unser Texteditor JavaScript geschrieben ist.
Macroby, wo waren wir denn vorher, bevor wir zu Macroby gekommen sind?
Blocks, C, Lang, L, LVM, OpenCL waren wir.
Ja. Und dann sind wir zu Macroby gekommen.
CyberDuck hat JavaScript geschaffen.
Genau, ich wollte mich gerade fragen, es gab doch irgendein File-Programm, was in Java geschrieben ist. War das CyberDuck? Und dann gab es auch noch irgendein Nutella-Klein, glaube ich, der war auch irgendwie so in Java.
Java läuft ja prinzipiell noch. Ich habe ja auch Eclipse. Ich habe ja auch Eclipse am Laufen.
Ja, aber pure Java. Reine Java-Programme laufen. Aber Programme, die jetzt von Java-Coco interfacen wollen.
Ich kann keinen.
Und hier ziehen gerade ein paar Leute auf. Also bei CyberDuck gab es wohl PDF-Lab, meint jemand.
Ach, was PDF-Lab läuft nicht mehr? Und jemand meint, CyberDuck läuft. Musste man updaten. Ah ja, genau. Was, mein PDF-Lab läuft nicht mehr? Macht mich nicht fertig.
CyberDuck stürzt tatsächlich, sagen wir, klanglos ab.
Oh mein PDF-Lab, ihr Schweine!
Jede sind auf deinem Rechner so, das ist bei jedem anderen.
Jede ist ja jetzt auch in Preview drin, das hab ich ja ganz vergessen zu sagen. Man kann ja jetzt auch PDFs zusammenbauen. Kannst da so Seiten rein draggen.
Echt?
Oder war das auch schon in Leopard drin? War schon in Leopard. Es gibt ein neues iTunes.
Ja, 901.
Er ist gelangweilt.
Das hat er vorhin schon installiert. Ich hab ja extra weggeklickt, weil ich dachte, es ist mal zu fett.
Echt, mein PDF-Lab läuft nicht mehr. Das ist echt...
So haben wir noch Themen jetzt hier. Zack, zack.
Haben wir noch Themen? Wir haben jetzt Core Location eingebaut. Ich frage mich nur, ob es auch als API für Programme freigegeben ist oder ob es nur für internal News drin ist.
Kann ich dir Quatsch mal weiter? Dann sag ich dir das in ein paar Sekunden.
Okay, das wäre doch mal eine wirklich interessante Sache.
Aber ich denke, es gibt...
Es gibt ja so einen Bereich, den ich schon immer ganz gerne mal exploren wollte, wo sich ja auch eine Menge getan hat bei Snow Leopard, wie auch bei dem iPhone, den wir aber gar nicht so richtig bewerten können. Das ist dieser ganze Universal Access. Also diese Screen-Räder-Funktionalität, da haben sie ja wohl ganz mächtig geschraubt. Also der Safari ist einfach quasi der erste Browser, der sozusagen mit dem Betriebssystem kommt, der irgendwie vollwertigen Screen-Räder darstellt, also von Blinden wahrgenommen werden kann. Und auch diese Bedienung von dem iPhone. Hast du mal dieses Video gesehen, wo sie demonstriert...
Das wollte ich... Das hab ich noch mit einem Notiz dann für die nächste Sendung. Das ist ja... Also das Ausgericht, dass das iPhone offensichtlich ein Gerät ist, was das erste Gerät überhaupt ist, was ein Blinder so perfekt bedienen kann.
Das will ich erstmal von einem Blinden hören.
Ich hab irgendwo einen Test von einem Blinden, den hab ich dann nicht durchgelesen.
Wie soll der denn auf dem Touchpad was erkennen? Was?
Der liest dir das vor.
Achso, aber er kann doch gar nicht klicken.
Doch, du klickst irgendwo drauf.
Irgendwo. Und dann?
Aber das mit Gesten. Guck dir das Video an.
Ich schick dir ein Link zu dem Video und dann guckst du es dir an. Die ganze Bedienung ist anders.
Also er kann ja zuhören und sich vorlesen lassen, aber er könnte doch gar keine SMS schicken.
Doch.
Guck dir an, es wird in einem Video jeder Schritt haarklein.
Wie geht das mit dem Schreiben?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber es wird haarklein.
Ach doch, du hältst deinen Finger so drauf und er sagt dann A, dann ziehst du ihn so links und dann sagt er B. Brauchst du ja Jahre für.
Du, du kannst es tun. Dann verstehst du, versus du kannst es nicht tun. Das ist für den blinden schon ein entscheidender Unterschied.
Außerdem sind die Jungs ja ein bisschen schneller, weil die gewöhnen sich an sowas schneller.
Absolut.
Weil sie müssen ja.
Ich sag nur, die hören sich Podcasts in 6-facher Geschwindigkeit an. Ich kann zweifach schon nicht abhören.
Zweifach wird schwer, aber es kommt drauf an. Bei Pawel geht es.
Nur bei Pawel geht es.
Der Core Location gibt es übrigens an 10.6, hab ich hier.
Ja, aber ich hab recht gehabt.
Es ist nur noch die Frage, wann kommt das GPS dazu?
Das ist wirklich die Frage, beziehungsweise kann man einfach einen GPS an den Rechner ranstöpseln und dann benutzt es das mit?
Von Lenovo gibt es schon Rechner mit GPS drin.
Es gibt von Vierenherrscher Rechner mit GPS drin.
Ja, aber da gibt es meistens die Schnickschnackers.
Gibt es von Lenovo dann auch ein Windows, was das als Systemdienst bereitstellt?
Na, unser Prom hat da lange installiert, bis alles ging. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange er gebraucht hat, aber er saß schon ein bisschen dran, um es irgendwie hinzukriegen. Aber ich glaube, der hat auch kein Windows, der hat ja bestimmt Linux. Du hast aber auch ganz schön viele Fenster in deinem Top-Sides-Fenster, nicht? Das sind irgendwie 24, seh ich das richtig?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, kann man das irgendwo einstellen, wie viele das sind, oder was?
Klar kann man. Also bei mir sind es irgendwie vier oder sechs, du hast da 24. Das ist auch ein Grund, warum es dann so ein bisschen rumruckelt beim Einschalten. Ich hab da sechs, eher da unten ist noch so ein Button. Da kann man Small, Medium, Large einstellen, guck mal hier. Du hast den da.
Ja, dann hab ich den da genommen. Aber wenn es da ist, soll es auch vernünftig funktionieren. Was mir gerade auffällt, das erste Mal überhaupt, dass Core Location aber nicht in Safari geht. Was ich ja noch mal ein bisschen doof finde.
Wie meinst du denn das?
Ach so, wie bei Firefox, dass er das darüber...
Oder wie bei Safari auf dem iPhone, dass ich die Position einfach abfragen kann.
Ja, das wundert mich allerdings auch, warum sie das dann nicht noch mit eingebaut haben, wenn Core Location schon da ist und sie das auf dem iPhone haben und sogar der Firefox das schon kann. Wenn du hier Google Maps startest, auf dem Firefox, auf dem Mac...
Der weiß gleich, wo man ist.
Genau, da hast du so die Möglichkeit zu sagen, locate me und dann macht er das eben auch nicht sehr viel anders. Bloß eben über eigene Geschichten. Und...
Das funktioniert...
Firefox okay und mit Google Gears konnte man es ja auch für Safari nachrüsten. Aber bei Google Gears funktioniert natürlich selbstverständlich nicht. Und Snow Leopard, weil dafür stellt sich Google immer ein bisschen doof an. Wobei, mittlerweile hab ich ja das Gefühl, dass zwischen Google und Apple so ein kleiner unterschwelliger Krieg ausgebrochen ist, oder? Der wird noch nicht so richtig offen ausgetragen, aber...
Der wird ganz offen ausgetragen gerade mit diesem FTC hier, mit welcher Applications abgelehnt wurden. Da machen die doch gerade public dreckige Wäsche waschen.
Naja, es fängt jetzt an, ja.
Ja, es ging los, seitdem sie den Schmitt rausgeschmissen haben. Wahrscheinlich schon vorher, aber...
Ja, wie gesagt, vorher war es unterschiedlich. Langsam kocht das offen. So richtig sieht man ja noch nicht. Außer beim iPhone, wo sich gegenseitig in die Quere kommen sollen, aber offensichtlich...
Wobei ich ja sagen muss, dass Google bei Apple ins Gehege pisst und nicht andersrum.
Ach, naja, mal gucken. Ich meine, sie bauen ja jetzt dieses neue Data Center, was wohl auch exorbitante Ausmaße hat. Was ist ja geil, was sie da vorher haben. Andererseits glaube ich nicht, dass Apple derzeit Google, ich glaube, dass Google derzeit Apple mehr in die Suppe spucken kann, als umgekehrt. Also, Apple, so toll sie sich entwickelt haben in ihrem Kernbereich, diese Sache mit Services und so, und Internet.
Das haben die nicht gepeilt.
Das hat niemand gepeilt.
Nee, aber immer noch nicht.
Außer Google hat es keiner so richtig gepeilt.
Nein, nur kleine Spezialbooten, die nichts anderes machen. Twitter, Facebook, Yahoo! Noch zu einem gewissen Grad.
Die werden alle eh platt gemacht oder von Google gekauft.
Aber Facebook bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Ja, bin ich auch sehr gespannt.
Ja, das ist vielleicht schon zu teuer, aber Twitter holen die sich doch irgendwann.
Da bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher.
Ich eigentlich auch nicht, weil so toll ist Twitter gar nicht.
Doch, Twitter ist toll.
Ich hab letztens wieder zwei rausgeschmissen. Ich bin jetzt auf 20 runter. Irgendwann habe ich 1.500 Follower und ich Follower keimen.
Das ist geil.
1.500?
Dann ist es auf jeden Fall...
Wirklich?
1.463? Na, dann packen wir doch mal ein bisschen auf hier. Dennis erzählt immer interessantes Zeug auf Twitter und ist cool. Dennis2342, follow now!
Stimmt das denn?
Heute ist doch gar nicht Follow Friday.
Ach doch, es gibt immer wieder interessante Sachen. Naja, du schreibst ja auch ab und zu was Interessantes.
Ja, das stimmt.
Du schreibst Tweets für die Ewigkeit.
Genau.
Du müsstest ja sehr gebauchpinselt gewesen sein. Auf der Demo.
Ja, klar war ich natürlich. Hallo, da rennt jemand ein Schild mit meinem Tweet drauf.
Das ist super.
Heute bin ich das erste Mal mit Namen im Handelsblatt zitiert worden.
Wirklich?
Ja, wegen diesem Tweet. Das erste Mal überhaupt.
Du wirst in die Geschichte eingehen. Für 100 Jahre werden Kinder in der Schule Bücher lesen, wo drin standen.
Damals bist du ja noch als Max diesen Tweet-Absetzter.
Eigentlich fände ich es viel cooler, wenn er zum Ausdruck einer Bewegung wird.
Ja, ist doch schon. Die heißen jetzt viel Raten.
Ja, aber dieses, dass durch die gesamte Presse, die immer schreit, dass niemand aufs Urheberrecht achten würde, das ist von denen, der ist 20-mal erwähnt worden, in komplett überregionalen Zeitungen. Und nie, wirklich nicht einmal geben die eine fucking Quelle an. Das ist nicht, dass ich deswegen tot umfalle, aber es ist, komm, eat your own dog food.
Sie kennen die nicht. Aber ist doch schön, wenn das Handelsblatt, das es jetzt irgendwie rausgefunden hat.
Nein, Thomas Gnüwa, der twittert ja selber sehr aktiv.
Der muss es ja wissen. Stimmt, Handelsblatt. Ich finde, jetzt kommt nicht mehr sehr viel mehr bei uns raus hier. Es ist schon ganz schön spät, wir beschränken uns jetzt mal ein bisschen.
Und wir hatten keine Schokolade diesmal.
Wir hatten keine Schokolade, das stimmt. Das ist ja auch noch ein echtes Problem.
Wir müssen hier echt so ein bisschen für Essen noch besorgen, bei so einer mega Monster-Sendung.
Weil jetzt kriegt man nämlich nichts mehr. Es gab Angebote hier.
Und endlich ist genug Zeit für Schlafplätze.
Es gab Angebote, uns hier mal eine Pizza kommen zu lassen. Wobei ich schon vorher immer noch esse. Ich weiß ja, was auf mich zukommt. Ich bin vorbereitet.
Ich komme von Arbeit und hab nichts gegessen.
Ich werd jetzt auch gleich was essen.
Ich werd hier auch noch eine Mikrowelle reinrennen. Na was denn? Mit Ofen? Kannst du Pizza reinhauen?
Kannst lieber stollen.
Na mal gucken, wie die Spendenlage so aussieht. Dann können wir hier vielleicht noch ein bisschen...
Ich bringe demnächst einfach mal was mit.
So, in zwei Wochen, kann man jetzt schon sagen, werden wir noch mal diese ganze iPhone-Geschichte aufarbeiten.
In zwei Wochen erst.
Genau, dann erfahrt ihr, wie Apple es schafft, mit weniger Farbe 20 Euro mehr zu nehmen.
Dennis kann nächste Woche nicht, von daher bietet sich das eh an.
Na gut, dann in zwei Wochen.
Ja, zwei Wochen ist super.
Gut, und dann kommen wir ja auch irgendwann vielleicht wieder mal so hinterher, dass wir nicht über so alte Scheiße reden müssten. War?
Ja, mir erwähnt, dass iPhone, nee iTunes 901 draus ist. Aktuell muss erst meiner sein. Wollen wir mal das Resümee von der Geschichte, die Moral von der Geschichte, dass eigentlich in Snow Leopard fast nichts neu war. Weil es gab es alles in 10-5 schon, das Meister.
Jaja, das haben sie wirklich hinbekommen. Es ist einfach dasselbe in Schnell.
Da gab es, äh, ich glaube, das ist jetzt schon die erste Woche, eigentlich bringst du das von diesem Geek & Poke Comic, habt ihr den gesehen? Wo zweimal dasselbe Bild nebeneinander ist und ähm, dann so, ähm, einer zum anderen erklärt, jaja, die Farben sind anders und es hat auch nur 29 Dollar gekostet. Snow Leopard, kurz erklärt. Ich glaube, das trifft es relativ gut.
Es wird trotzdem ein mega Erfolg sein und es verbessert einfach viele Sachen. Man darf gar nicht unterschätzen, was allein diese Exchange-Sache für ein Interesse erzeugen wird. Und viele Leute werden sich jetzt auch mal ein Update offiziell kaufen, die vorher immer irgendwie sich das gekauft haben.
Damit sie auf einen legalen Weg kommen und beim nächsten Mal es dann wieder machen können.
Ja, für 29 Dollar macht man das dann auch mal.
Na, ein Kumpel hat sich ja gleich irgendwie die Family-Dings gekauft. Für sich und Freunde, zack.
Zack! So hört sich das.
Bum-Zack-Return.
Ich glaube ja, dass darunter eine Menge passiert ist, aber bisher, das, was unten drunter ist, soll mal richtig schön stabil laufen.
Also, so wie Apple das auch sagt, ist es eigentlich auch. Sie haben im Motorraum einfach alles ersetzt oder alles auf einen neuen Stand gebracht. Und die Auswirkungen davon werden wir erst im nächsten OS feststellen.
Das ist kein nächstes OS, sondern ein nächstes, bis zum nächsten OS, wenn die Leute ihre Programme updaten.
Nee, aber ich denke, dass sie auch mit ihrem OS einfach neue Schweinereien anstellen werden, wofür sie aber jetzt diese ganzen Tätigkeiten, wie zum Beispiel Grenz-Central Dispatch, brauchen werden. Also ich erwarte für das nächste OS-Release einfach ein voll durchasynchronisiertes OS. Ich erwarte, dass alle Programme einfach maximal performant mit Coors umgehen können.
Ich glaube, ich hatte mit Snow Leopard bisher mehr Probleme als mit jedem anderen größeren Update, das Mac OS und ich höre auch von anderen, dass die auch größere Probleme haben. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man nicht mit arbeiten könnte oder sowas, aber das 10.5. Was war die letzte Version? 8? Lief bei mir nicht zu meiner absoluten, totalsten Bezüglichkeit.
Du hast ein Montags OS.
Ich muss ja auch dazu sagen, dass dieses Update auf 10.6.1, das war ja kein wirkliches Update, weil ich weiß nicht, was genau der Grund ist. Vielleicht war es wirklich wegen dem Adobe Flash Plug-In, was wir irgendwie verunst haben bei der Auslieferung, dass wir mal updaten mussten. Aber da waren ja fast gar keine Änderungen drin in diesem 10 Megabyte Update. Also ich glaube, das richtige 10.6.1 Update kommt erst noch. Das war nur so ein Zwischending, was schnell raus musste. Bei mir war das 9 Megabyte groß oder sowas. Das war kein wirkliches Update, was den Namen verdient hätte.
Das sind so die Bugs, die sie zwischen der Golden Master und irgendeinem anderen Stichtag mal eben gefunden haben, die sie so schnell wie möglich noch...
Aber was wollten sie denn so schnell? Da war nichts so schnell wie möglich, hätte gefixt werden müssen. Also nichts wirklich Schlimmes. Ich glaube, das lag an diesen Adobe-Flash-Dings oder sowas. Vielleicht haben sie noch ein Security-Bug unten drunter schnell gefixt, aber...
Ich denke, wir werden nachher schon eine Menge finden.
So richtig doll war das nicht. Ich glaube, das 10.6.2, das ist das, was man haben will. Und dann wird vielleicht auch alles schick. Und dann ist vielleicht auch Max happy.
Tja, und vielleicht kommt dann eine 10.6.7, dann doch noch irgendwie ZFS. Oder 10.6.3. Aber es sieht nicht wirklich danach aus, ne? Das ist echt bitter. Das ist wirklich bitter. So, Leute.
Da sollte man mal eine Online-Petition machen.
Jetzt machen wir mal Schluss hier, wa? Wenn der Chat nichts... Kann der Chat noch irgendwas interessantes fragen, irgendwie?
Die schlafen alle schon.
Ja, ich glaub auch. Immerhin haben wir heute mal wieder was erklärt. Das find ich doch mal ganz schön. Das haben wir sogar recht gehabt. Und nächstes Mal... Bisschen zwei Wochen, oder? Der Flash beklagt sich hier zurecht, dass wir irgendwie seinen Element mit dem Upstore noch nicht erwähnt haben. Aber das war jetzt auch irgendwie gar nicht so das Thema.
Und wir sind nicht auf dieses, wie heißt das, Podcast... eingegangen auf dieses... Wie heißen die beiden da? Die beiden Mädels, die den Postgast da gemacht haben.
Ach so, die Geschichte. Das machen wir auch nächstes Mal.
Genau, machen wir nächstes Mal. Haben wir nicht vergessen, machen wir nächstes Mal.
Würdest du mit dem Flash lange dauern?
Das ist eine Geschichte, die klang schon ziemlich abenteuerlich, als ob man da ein bisschen ausführlicher sagen würde.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine umfangreiche... Also kurz gesagt, diese Applikation Roms auf dem iPhone wartet seit vier Monaten auf einen Release einer neuen Version.
Das war doch das, wo du am Anfang erzählte, dass du seinen Programm nicht annehmen wollen, weil die Buttons nicht okay wären und so.
Lass uns das einfach beim nächsten Mal machen.
Wir packen jetzt mal den Link mit in die Sendungsbeschreibung. Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr in der Lage. Nächstes Mal kommt irgendwie iPhone und iPod.
Genau, er schreibt gerade selber, dass er bis in zwei Wochen... Das ist ja bestimmt noch viel, viel mehr passiert.
Aber seine alte App ist noch drin.
Ja, die alte Version. Okay, dann passt das. Wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören bei Mobamex.
Im wieder neuen Studio.